GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE HEARING WE
ARE CNTINUING TO PRACTICE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE'RE ALSO REQUIRED THE
MASTERY WARNING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY
EVERYONE PRESENT HERE IN THE
ROOM OR IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROBABLY
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. TODAY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR TWO WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND LIMITED
NUMBER PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE
CAN MAINTAIN APPROPRIATE
SPACING. THERE ARE ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCE THE PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITOL. FOR THOSE
HERE IN THE ROOM. IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE UBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL
PLEASE LISTEN TO ME FOR MY
PROMPT FOR MISTER LUCKY'S
PROMPT. TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM ONCE YOU HAVE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL. INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. WE WILL ALSO
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE. THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS YOUR- TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO WHEN THE
AUTHORS BILL IS UP SO YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON A TESTIFYING
BEGINS WE ARE AT THEIR
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU
WERE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MEETING
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST IN YOUR
SMART DEVICES. THREE REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED THAT IF IN THE MAIN
WITNESS- IF YOU ARE A MAIN MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY
FORGETS TO BILL YOU'LL REMAIN
ON A LIFELINE THEN YOU WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
GET ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU HAVE ARE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE A
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. THREE NINE FIVE
EIGHT AND MY STUFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
CONTINUE USING MATHIS TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS. WE STILL FACE. NOW
LET'S COVER THE GROUND RULES
FOR APPROPRIATE CONDUCT
ASSEMBLY HAS EXPERIENCED A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO
COMMITTEE AND POOR PROCEEDINGS
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS. CONTACT
THE DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. SUCH CONTACT MAY
INCLUDE REMOVING I'M ASKING
REFUSING TO PUT IT BACK ON.
TALKING OR MAKING LOUD NOISES
FROM THE AUDIENCE. UTTERING
ALLOWED THREATENING AND ABUSIVE
LANGUAGE SPEAKER LONGER THAN
THE TIME ALLOWED IT. EXTENDED
DISCUSSION OF MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF THE
HEARING OR OR THE BILL. IN ANY
OTHER DISRUPTIVE ACTS. TO
ADDRESS ANY DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT
CONDUCT. HI AND MR LUCKY WILL
TAKE THE FOLLOWING STEPS. IF AN
INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR HEARING
PROCESS I WOULD DIRECT THEM TO
STOP AND WARNED THEM THAT
CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS MAY
RESULT IN REMOVAL FROM THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. I WILL ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED IN THE
NATURE OF THE DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT I MAY TEMPORARILY
RECESSED THE HEARING. IF THE
CONDUCT DOES NOT STOP I WILL
REQUEST THE ASSISTANCE OF THE
SERGEANTS AND ESCORTING THE
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. WE HAVE FOURTEEN
MINUTES FOURTEEN ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY FOR THOSE ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT. I CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSISTS OF THE
FOLLOWING. ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
TEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW. ITEM
SEVEN AB FORTINO NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE. I DON'T
EIGHT AB FORTY FOUR FOURTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
ITEM ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN. IN ADDITION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS WILL
PRESENT NUMBER TWO AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. WE WILL
HEAR ALL OTHER BILLS IN THE
ORDER SHOWN ON OUR AGENDA.
WE'LL TAKE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PREACH
BILL. THESE WITNESSES WILL HAVE
THREE MINUTES EACH TO PROVIDE
THEIR TESTIMONY ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THEIR
NAME. ORGANIZATION AND THE
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY ALL
SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION MAY PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN ANY ORDER- WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM WE DO HAVE
A QUORUM HOLD GOOD. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU- SO WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM AS SECRETARY WOULD YOU
CALL THE ROLL. WE ARE HERE
PRESIDENT. AIR FRANCE LOW. OR
RELIGION DURING. YOUR CUSTOMERS
AND- HOW CAN I THIS. YEAH. I
AND I WAS SERVER HE CAN WE DO
HAVE A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR LOOP. OUR MOTION THE
SECOND. HI ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. I'VE TRIED TO
SUPPORT. BOERNER HORVATH OUR-
RIGHT. I ALRIGHT THIS IS ROBERT
BOTH OF RIGHT- I WILL BE
REMOVED ALL UT OF THE ROOM ARE
GOING TO GO FOR A BILL AND SOME
MEMBER WILL SHARING THE CAN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AT THE-
READY FOR THE FIRST AUTHOR- I
DO TOO WE HAVE A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS HERE. I DO
NOT SEE HIM. AND I DO SEE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO. I WOULD
LIKE YOU TO THE LECTERN THERE
SIR. RIGHT. YET THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF. AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX
WOULD PERMIT THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA NDL HAMMER UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO CONDUCT A
SPECIAL ELECTION IN ORDER TO
PROCEED WITH ITS TRANSITION
FROM AT LARGE TO BY TRUSTEE
AREA ELECTIONS FOR MEMBERS OF
THE BOARD OF EDUCATION IN ORDER
TO COMPLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING RIGHTS ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE. CV OUR EIGHT
DURING THE NOVEMBER THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY GENERAL ELECTION
MEASURE G. WHICH APPEAR ON THE
BALLOT SOUGHT TO REMOVE FROM
THE CITY CHARTER ALL REFERENCES
TO THE ALHAMBRA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. HOWEVER MEASURE G.
ONLY APPEAR ON THE BALLOT SO
VOTERS RESIDING IN THE ITY OF
ALHAMBRA AND NOT ON THE BALLOT
SO VOTERS IN ALHAMBRA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WILL ALSO
RECITE OUTSIDE OF CITY OF THE
CITY BOUNDARIES. NOW UNDER
EXISTING LAW CHARTER AMENDMENT
FOR CITY MUST BE SUBMITTED TO
VOTERS AT AN ESTABLISHED
STATEWIDE GENERAL ELECTION. SO
CONSEQUENTLY THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
ARE PROHIBITED FROM CONDUCTING
A SPECIAL ELECTION TO AMEND THE
CHARTER PRIOR TO THE NEXT
STATEWIDE ELECTION ON NOVEMBER
THE EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THEREFORE WE NEED TO CREATE A
SPECIAL EXCEPTION IN THE
GOVERNMENT CODE TO PERMIT THE
CITY OF ALHAMBRA. AND THE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
CONDUCT A SPECIAL ELECTION
BEFORE THE NEXT STATEWIDE
GENERAL ELECTION. TO ACHIEVE
THIS I RECENTLY SUBMITTED AN
AMENDMENT FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TO ADDED URGENCY
COST TO THIS VERY IMPORTANT
DISTRICT BILL. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IDOL.
THANK YOU. OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. I BELIEVE
WE HAVE A TWO WITNESSES AND
MODERATOR COULD YOU STILL COULD
YOU ALLOW A- MISS SARAH
BERLINSKI. OR CHRISTOPHER
BLINDER OPEN. FOR CHRISTOPHER
L. INDOOR. THIS. I'M SORRY
BELIEVE WE'RE TESTIFYING ON
EIGHT THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO
THAT'S A MISTAKE IT WOULD BE
EITHER- DEAN LOGAN OR JONATHAN
SALT. GREAT GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
MR OF VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME'S DEAN
LOGAN AND I'M THE REGISTRAR
RECORDER COUNTY CLERK FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. AND I
TESTIFYING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
OUR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
SIX AND I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHILD FOR
OFFERING AS WELL AS THE
ALHAMBRA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND CITY OF ALHAMBRA
FOR CO SPONSORING THE BILL WITH
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. EIGHTY
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX SUPPORT THE
EFFORT AND INTENT OF THE
ALHAMBRA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO ESTABLISH DISTRICT
BASED ELECTION BOARD OF
TRUSTEES A LINE TO THE FAIR AND
DISTRIBUTED REPRESENTATION
PROVISIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING RIGHTS ACT. AB FIFTEEN
FORTY SIX ALSO ADDRESSES THE
UNIQUE SITUATION WHERE OUTDATED
REFERENCES IN THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA CHARTER RELATED TO
ELECTION FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT CONFLICT WITH THE
DISTRICT EFFORTS TO ADOPT THE
TRUSTEE AREA ELECTION MODEL. TO
ADDRESS ISSUE- AS THE AUTHORS
STATED THE CITY PLATE THE
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO REMOVE THE OUTDATED
LANGUAGE AND REFERENCES TO THE
DISTRICT AND THE CHARTER.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO AN ERROR
IN THE INTERPRETATION OF THE
CITY'S ELECTION REVOLUTION THAT
MEASURE ONLY APPEARED ON
BALLOTS FOR VOTERS WITHIN THE
CITY OF ALHAMBRA. AND DID NOT
APPEAR ON BALLOTS FOR VOTERS IN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT RESIDE
OUTSIDE THE CITY'S BOUNDARIES.
THEREFORE THE MEASURE HAD TO BE
PLACED ON THE BALLOT AGAIN IN
THE FUTURE ELECTION. WAITING
UNTIL THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
STATE GENERAL ELECTION WOULD
DELAY THE DISTRICT EFFORT TO
ESTABLISH TRUST THE AREAS THAT
ALIGN THEIR ELECTIONS. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT
PRIOR TO THE NEXT ELECTION OF
THE GOVERNING BOARD MEMBERS-
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTEEN FORTY SIX.
CREATE A SPECIAL EXEMPTION THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE DISTRICT TO
PLACE THE MEASURE ON THE
BALLOT. AT ANY ELECTION
IDENTIFIED IN THE ELECTION
CODE. BASED ON THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAN THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT TO
ADVANCE THEIR AND DISTRIBUTED
REPRESENTATION ON LOCAL
GOVERNING BOARDS. THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND MODERATE WERE NOW
READY FOR- JONATHAN SALT.
MISTER CHAIR AND IF THE MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JONATHAN FAULT AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY AT THE EDUCATION LAW
FIRM OF FAGAN LEAVING UNTIL
FROST. OUR FIRM REPRESENTS THE
ALHAMBRA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THE DISTRICT IN CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES AND CITY OF
ALHAMBRA IS PLEASED TO CO
SPONSOR AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX.
THE L. HAMMER CITY CHARTER
CURRENTLY GOVERNS THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ELECTIONS AND REQUIRES
THE USE OF AN AT LARGE MATHIS.
THE DISTRICT DESIRE TO
TRANSITION TO A DISTRICT BASED
ELECTION SYSTEM SOMETIMES
REFERRED TO AS A BY TRUSTEE
AREA THE STEM. GINGER
COMPLIANCE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING RIGHTS ACT. IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY AT THE DISTRICT
REQUEST THE CITY PLACE THE
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT TO REMOVE
ALL REFERENCES TO THE DISTRICT
WITHIN THE CITY CHARTER. THE
PURPOSE OF THIS ACTION WHAT THE
DECOUPLE THE DISTRICT FROM THE
CITY CHARTER TO ALLOW THE
DOCTOR TO CONTINUE WITH ITS
TRANSITION FROM AT LARGE TO BUY
TURKEY AREA ELECTIONS. IN TIME
FOR THE NEXT BOARD OF
EDUCATIONAL ACTION IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO A COUNTY
CLERICAL ERROR THE BALLOT
MEASURE WAS ONLY AVAILABLE TO
CITY RESIDENTS AND NOT ALL
DISTRICT RESIDENTS AS REQUIRED.
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW THE
CHARTER COULD NOT BE AMENDED IN
TIME FOR THE DISTRICT TO
COMPLETE ITS TRANSITION AND
HOLD IT FIRST TRUST THE AREA
ELECTIONS BY NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. RESULTING IN
FURTHER DELAY UNTIL THE
DISTRICT DESIRED HE VERY
COMPLIANT ELECTION SYSTEM COULD
BE IMPLEMENTED. I ADOPTION OF
AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX WOULD
PERMIT THE CITY TO PLACE AN
IDENTICAL MEASURE ON THE BALLOT
A STUDENT THIS NOVEMBER AND IF
APPROVED ALLOW THE DISTRICT TO
COMPLETE COLLECTION TRANSITION.
BACK THE COUNTY CITY AND
DISTRICT ARE ALL IN SYNC AS CO
SPONSORS AND- THE COMMITTEES
EITHER ON AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SO-
MANIMALA MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER OF WITNESSES OUR
CALLERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE A ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE SIX SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO HAVE A
SUMMIT. OKAY MISTER CHAIR WE DO
HAVE A FEW MORE Q. ONE UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF ONE THE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN AND IF WE
COULD JUST ADVISE. WE JUST NEED
THEIR NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION
AND THEIR POSITION PLEASE. YES
THIS IS JUST A BONTA THEN THE
CITY ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF ONE AND NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON BRIAN SKIN ROBERT
HALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
PROPER BOXERS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND ONE MOMENT
WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE IN Q. THERE
IS A REMINDER WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND
WE'LL GO TO NEXT LINE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF TO- FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS SID KAPOOR FROM THE
STATE TO PERMIT ONE AND I'M
INTO PART OF AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
TWO THANKS. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY. DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO A BE A FIFTY
FORTY SIX. APPARENTLY I HEAR
NON. NOT A MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY COLORS IN OPPOSITION TO AB
OF FIFTEEN FORTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX YOU MAY PLAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
ZERO FOUR IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX. AND WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE STAFF. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. DO IT DO WE HAVE IN
THE COMMENTS. AND I THINK WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND YOU'RE
WELCOME TO CLOSER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY ONE OF
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI. I WILL GUARD FOR THAT
BOERNER HORVATH RIGHT LEARN
MORE ABOUT- OUR- WELL HI YEAH
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS HELLO
VOEPEL VOEPEL MOVIE. YOUR
AVAILABLE. AGUIAR-CURRY. GOOD
MORNING FOR ME FOR. K. FOURTEEN
VOTERS FOUR ZERO I THINK YOU
NEED ONE MORE RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HOLDING. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS. OKAY. I
DIDN'T ANNOUNCES SUPPORT. FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER GUY HAD
I THINK A- YOUR UP SIR. OKAY.
THANK YOU. ABOUT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS AS YOU
ALL KNOW THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS EXPOSED CRITICAL
SHORTFALLS AND HEALTH CARE AND
HEALTH SERVICES FUNDING ACROSS
THE STATE. COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
HAVE BEEN ESPECIALLY IMPACTED
BY THE EMERGENCY. NOW MORE THAN
EVER WE HAVE SEEN THE LIFE
CHANGING IMPACTS OF DEVOTING
EVERY POSSIBLE DOLLAR. TO THOSE
WE SERVE. AB NINE OH THREE THE
DISTRICT BILL TO TAKE STRIDES
TOWARDS ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE.
THE BILL EFFECTIVELY CREATES
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN FUNDING. FOR BUT
BADLY NEEDED HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IN MY REGION. EIGHTY
NINE OH THREE IS GOOD
GOVERNMENT. THE LASKO HAS
APPROVED OF THE DOES DOES
ALEUTIAN THE EXISTING HEALTH
CARE SKEWS ME HELP ME SORT OUT
OVER. LAUGHTER HAS APPROVED OF
THE DISSOLUTION OF THE EXISTING
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT AND THE
COUNTY ALREADY SERVES
COMMITTEES WITHIN DISTRICT
BOUNDARIES. THE DISSOLUTION WAS
PARTLY APPROVED DUE TO THE
DISTRICT HIRED MINISTRY OF
EXPENSES WHICH TOP 60% IN SOME
YEARS. THAT'S SIMPLY CONSTABLES
A PARABLE CAL PROGRAMS OF THE
COUNTY RUN IT 15% COST NEARLY
NEARBY HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS
RUN IT NO MORE THAN 20% RATHER
THAN LOSE OVER HALF THE FUNDING
TO HUESO ADMINISTRATIVE
EXPENSES AB NINE OH THREE
DEDICATES WAS DOLLARS DIRECTLY
TO THE COMMUNITY. FINALLY THE
BILL CREATES ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ENHANCE THE SUPPORTS FOR
REQUIRING THE COUNTY TO DEVELOP
AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE. AND
HEALTH PLNS SPECIFIC TO
IMPROVING OUTCOMES IN OUR
COMMUNITY. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE OH THREE.
HELLO I WOULD. AND DOES THE
CHAIR FOR MY HOME JOINT
AUTHORED TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. BEFORE THAT HAPPENS
COULD I JUST I CLARIFY WHETHER
OR NOT YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES- AMENDMENTS I
APOLOGIZE MISTER YES OF COURSE.
THANK YOU. REUTERS REPORTS. YOU
MAY YOU MAY PROCEED. VERAPAZ
COMMITTEE MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON AND REPOSITION OF THE
NUMBER HAS BEEN A LONG TERM
QUESTION FOR CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND THIS BILL IS AN
EQUITABLE SOLUTION TO THE
HEALTHCARE CHALLENGES FACED BY
THE REGION AB AS WILL BE NOTED
THE DISSOLUTION OF THE DISTRICT
WILL REDUCE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS AND MAKE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
AVAILABLE FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH
PROGRAMS TO SERVE OUR
CONSTITUENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I DON'T THINK. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I DO HAVE TO
EXPERT WITNESSES THE FIRST IS
COMMISSIONER DON BLUBAUGH ON
BEHALF OF CONTRA COSTA LASKO.
AND ITS SUPERVISOR FEDERAL
GLOVER REPRESENTING. OF THE
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IS ALSO
HERE TO SUPPORT. AND I ASSUME
THEY'RE BUILT BY A TELEPHONE
YES SIR. OKAY MODERATOR COULD
YOU PLEASE OF OPEN THE LINES
FOR A MISTER BLUE BALL. HELLO
YES YOU MAY PROCEED WE CAN HEAR
YOU. IS THAT MR BLOOM ON THE
LINE. YES I AM ON THE LINE ARE
YOU HEARING ME NOW WE SURE ARE
YOU YOU MAY PROCEED SIR. OKAY I
AM DONE BALUBA MISSION- WITH-
CONTRA COSTA LASKO- THE LAST
ADONIS- COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT HAS STRUGGLED FOR
YEARS WITH THEIR HOSPITAL
CLOSURE BANKRUPTCY AND OTHER
CHALLENGES- IT IS NOT PROVIDED
DIRECT HEALTH CARE. FOR TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS- IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR WHEN IT ACTUALLY CLOSED
THE LOS MADONNA'S COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL THE COUNTY OF CONTRA
COSTA NOW RUNS THE PITTSBURGH
HEALTH CLINIC OUT OF THE
FORMER- COMMUNITY HOSPITAL
SITE. THIS IS THE LARGEST
HEALTH CLINIC IN MY COUNTY
HEALTH SYSTEM IT HAS MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DISTRICT
PATIENT VISITS EACH YEAR. THE
DISTRICT COMING BACK TO IT NOW
IS NOT A DIRECT PROVIDER OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. AND
INSTEAD PROVIDES A LIMITED
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO THIRD
PARTIES THAT PROVIDE HEALTH
WELLNESS AND PREVENTION
PROGRAMS. CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
GRAND JURIES OVER THE YEARS
REPORTED THAT- THE DISTRICT
SUFFERS FROM FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES MANAGEMENT
INEFFICIENCIES AND EXCESSIVE
SPENDING ON ADMINISTRATION AND
OVERHEAD IN PAST YEARS. THE
DISTRICT HAS SPENT UP TO HALF
ITS TOTAL REVENUES ON
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENSES IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE GRAND JURY
RECOMMENDED THAT THE DISTRICT
BE DISSOLVED. AS AN ASIDE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION USE THIS
DISTRICT AS AN EXAMPLE AMONG
OTHERS AS TO WHY INEFFICIENT
DISTRICT SHOULD BE DOES ALL. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OUR LASKO
APPROVED THE DISSOLUTION OF THE
DISTRICT AND NAMED CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AS THE SUCCESSOR AGENCY
AS A CONDITION OF IT. BLASCO
REQUIRED THE COUNTY TO
ESTABLISH A GRANT PROGRAM- MUCH
LIKE THE ONE CURRENTLY IN USE
BY THE DISTRICT AND ONE VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT IS OUTLINED IN
AB NINE THREE. THE COUNTY RUN
GRANT PROGRAM WOULD ASSIST
THIRD PARTIES THAT PROVIDE
HEALTH WELLNESS AND PREVENTION
PROGRAMS. SUBSEQUENTLY THE
DISTRICT SUED LASKO AND THE
COUNTY AND THE MATTER IS STILL
IN THE COURTS SO OUR LAST
COLUSA. PORT NINE OH THREE- WE
ALL DO NOT VIEW THIS AS AN END
RUN AROUND LASKO NINE OH THREE
WOULD HAVE THE SAME EFFECT AS
THE DISSOLUTION APPROVED BY
LASCO IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER MOVE OFF NO WE WERE
HERE FROM THE FEDERAL GLOVER. I
DO NOT SEE HIM ON THE LINE BUT
IF HE IS ON THE LINE HE MAY
PRESS- STARTED ZERO AND WE WILL
OPEN HIS LINE. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. MISTER GLOVER YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME WE
CAN. AT GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR-
EVERY GO CURRY. MY NAME IS
SUPERVISOR FEDERAL GLOVER AND I
REPRESENT DISTRICTS FIVE WITHIN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. I'M CALLED
AND THEN TODAY TO OFFER STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE OH THREE
S. INTRODUCED BY ASSEMBLYMEN
FRAZIER ON BEHALF OF CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. THE LOS MILAN
ITSELF YEAH DISTRICT HAS BEEN
THE SUBJECT OF. NUMEROUS CALLS
FOR DISSOLUTION OVER TWENTY
YEARS INCLUDING FOR A SEPARATE
GRAND JURIES AND MOST RECENTLY.
A UNANIMOUS DECISION BY THE
CONTRA COSTA MEDICAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSION AND TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FOLLOWING UP
A PROPOSAL BY THE COUNTY. AFTER
COSTA COUNTY IF THE PRIMARY
PROVIDER FOR HEALTH SERVICE
THAT CANNOT MOST FOR MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT
ITS OPERATIONS WITH THE COUNTY
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS UP IN AFTER
TORY CARE CLINICS. AND SAT.
ALEX LARGEST THE PITTSBURGH
HEALTH CLINIC- WHAT THAT ONE
TIME LOS MADONNA'S COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL A FACILITY OPERATED BY
LAOS MADONNA TELLS NEAR
DISTRICT. IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR THE DISTRICT WENT STATE
ROUTE AND THE HOSPITAL CLOSED
ITS DOORS. TO ENSURE THAT
SERVICE CONTINUE TO THE
RESIDENTS OF THE DISTRICT THE
COUNTY RENOVATED THE FORMER
HOSPITAL BUILDING AT OPEN THE
PITTSBURG HEALTH CLINIC IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. SINCE
THAT TIME THE COUNTY HAS BEEN
VESTED OVER TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS INTO THE BUILDING AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE DIRECT MEDICAL CARE FOR
THE RESIDENTS. AT THE FACILITY
AT THE DESK TODAY. WITH
DISTRICT DOES NOT BY YOUR
RECORD MEDICAL CARE TO
RESIDENTS. IN FACT PRIOR TO
LAST HELLO- THAT IN THIS- VOTE
TO DISSOLVE THE DISTRICT IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE DISTRICT
HAS BEEN BUDGETING MORE SIGNS
FOR JUVENTUS CREATION AND
SERVICES TO THE PUBLIC. THIS
WAS CONFIRMED BY REPORT ISSUED
BY THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
AND. TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WHICH RETURNS- THE- REPEATED
CRITICISM ABOUT THE DESPERATE
FOR THE HIGH OVERHEAD HOUSE.
THE DISTRICT HAS CONTINUED
SPEND THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS MOUNTING LEGAL
ACTION AGAINST CONTRA COSTA.
NAPCO UNANIMOUS DECISION TO
DISSOLVE THE DISTRICT ALL FUNDS
THAT CAN AND SHOULD BE PROVIDED
TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO OUR
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS.
CONTRA COSTA STANDS READY.
SERVICE S. SETTLERS TO THE
DISTRICT WHEN A. B. NINE OH
THREE IS SIGNED INTO LAW THE
COUNTY IS ALREADY PROVIDING.
MEDICO SERVICES TO RESIDENTS
WITHIN THE DISTRICT AND OPERATE
THE HELPS CLINICS WITHIN THE
DISTRICT JURISDICTION THAT WILL
NOT CHANGE. PLEASE JOIN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMITTEE. NUMBER IS GRAND
JURIES AND SPEAKING VERY THE
EVOLUTION OF LOS MADONNA'S
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT AND
ENSURING THAT PUBLIC FUNDS. OUR
DIRECT CAN PROVIDE THE NEED
THIS HEALTHCARE SERVICE TO THE
PUBLIC I RESPECTFULLY ACTS FOR
AN AYE VOTE AT EIGHT BE. NINE
OH THREE. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR WELL NOW HEAR FROM THE-
FIRST OF ALL WE NEED TO DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER CALLERS IN
SUPPORT MINIMUM OR. THANK YOU
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
AND SUPPORT ONE ZERO AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE A BLUE TENT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
MADELEINE COOPER FROM NIELSEN
MARKS WERE ALSO. THANK YOU
ANOTHER REMINDER. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. AND
ONE MOMENT WE HAVE ONE MORE IN
Q. ONE ZERO IN SUPPORT. ONE
MOMENT SORRY. AND WE WILL GO
LINE OF TWO EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO DO
WITH A MUTE. HELLO YES PLEASE.
ARE YOU. YES OKAY I'M NOT QUITE
ON THE- OF PETITIONS. ALL WELL
WELL OKAY. WE HAVE NUMBER
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
NUMBER SUPPORT YOU ON THE PHONE
LINES. MISTER CHAIR. I'M SORRY
THAT'S IT WE HAVE NO MORE
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINE THAT
YOU SAID YOU HAD ONE MORE
SUPPORT OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE HAVE-
LAMAR THORPE AND VICTORIA ADAMS
IN THAT ORDER IF WE COULD
PLEASE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THE
MARK FOR I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LEFT ON. HEALTH
CARE DISTRICT. I'M ENTERING MY-
SECOND YEAR OF THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE HEALTHCARE
DISTRICT. AND THAT THE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK- WE'RE CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY NINE OH
THREE- THE FACT MATTER IS THIS
OUR FRIENDS ON THE OTHER SIDE
ARE FRANKLY BEING THE FINEST
THERE CITING TOLD REPORTERS-
THAT. TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE'VE
ACTUALLY REDUCE THEIR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS TO TWENTY
PERCENT- INFO AGAIN THEY'RE
BEING DEFINING THEIR ALSO BEING
THE PLANET. AS IT RELATES TO-
THEY COMPLETELY MISSED THE FACT
THAT VOTERS IN RESIDENTS GET TO
HAVE A SAY IN THE DECISION
PROCESS- THEY'VE BEEN DIVIDED
BEEN NOT POINTING OUT THAT THEY
KEEP LOSING IN COURT- AND SO
THEY- ARE TRYING TO DO. A GO
AROUND VOTERS AND RESIDENTS AND
HAVING A SAY IN THIS VERY
IMPORTANT MATTER. THEY BROUGHT
IT UP TO THE STATE LEGISLATURE
WHICH IS A COMPLETE IN MY
OPINION WASTE OF YOUR TIME. AT
THE PROPERTIES UNDER WAY AND
THE VOTERS SHOULD HAVE A CHOICE
IN THAT PRODUCT THAT. THEY HAVE
BUILT DEEP COMMUNITY HIGH COURT
THE COR COMMUNITY THE CUT THE
COLOR IN PITTSBURGH BREAKPOINT
HAVE BUILT THE EQUITY AROUND
THE HEALTHCARE DISTRICT. IF YOU
HAVE A WILL FADE AND WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WANT TO DEVELOP THEIR
HELP YOUR DOCTOR. FOR AT LEAST.
THE HEALTHCARE DISTRICT-%
PROVIDE A GRANT PROGRAM FOR THE
POOREST- THE MOST VULNERABLE.
YOU WHICH IS CRITICALLY. WE
LITERALLY FIND THE FREE CLINIC
INCOME AND THAT YOU'VE- OF THE
CALL FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE NO.
ABSOLUTELY NO ACCESS TO HEALTH
INSURANCE. WE FIND THAT WE
PROVIDE- DIRECT SERVICES IN THE
FORM OF MENTAL HEALTH. HEALTHY
AGING AND- ARE AND CAN BE ARE
HEALTHY COMMUNITY FOOD
INITIATIVE TO OUR COMMUNITY
GARDEN THESE ARE DIRECT
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE. THE
BEGINNING OF THE PUBLIC
PANDEMIC. WE HAVE BEEN ON THE
FRONT LINES PROVIDING OUR
COMMUNITY WITH CRITICAL
RESOURCES THAT NEED TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM THE VIRUS. WELL.
THE COUNTY WITH PUTTING IT- TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO THAT IN FOR-
AND SPENT WE AT ALL. RYING ALL
INFO. VIDEO GETTING. GOING TO
OUR MOST. TO WE PEOPLE GETTING
BEGIN. GET THEM COLD AND- AT
AND GET THE- GET LOCAL ETHNIC
MARKET- I PART. THAT THE LOCAL
LOCAL HEALTH BOARD AND SO THAT
THEY LET- WHILE. ACCOUNT COULD
NOT THAT. IT CENTER. THIS IS.
DIFFERENT A LOT BUT NOW TO MEET
HER GET TO IT. IN ORDER. THAT'S
FOCUSED PROVIDING. TO A- LEFT
BEHIND- IF THE- WITHOUT THE
PEOPLE. WILL LEAVE THAT. CRITIC
HELP UP- AND THEY WERE BE THERE
THERE THERE OUT. ISSUES BE
MAPPED OUT BY THE COUNTY. FROM
THE VERY CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
QUESTION- IS WRONG IT IS
ABSOLUTELY WRONG IN ITS ANTI-
ANTI- THAT TECHNICAL. TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS- INTO WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE A. B. AT NINE OH EIGHT-
AND- WE HOPE WE URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO. SO THAT THE VOTERS CAN
HAVE THE CHOICE IN OUR POWER TO
MAKE THAT DECISION FOR
THEMSELVES. ARE NOT NOT THE
STATE LEGISLATURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUST START. A
VICTORIA ADAMS. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR PAST YEAR- THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AGAIN MULLIN TONY ADAMS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE EAST
COUNTY GRANTED NATIONAL
PROTECTION FOR THE BATTLE OF
COLORED PEOPLE IN A FEW. AS AN
ORGANIZATION WE ARE HERE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
NINE OH THREE. ON THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHO PUT THIS BILL
TOGETHER APPEARS TO RECOGNIZE.
THAT THE COULD NOT THE BALLOT
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER
DISTRICT WELL DONE THIS IS TO
HELP THE- HOWEVER INSTEAD OF
TAKING AWAY TO PARTNER WITH THE
BOARD. AND ORGANIZATION THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR- ASSEMBLY
THE FRAZIER HAS DECIDED THAT HE
SAID WE WANT. HOSTILE TAKEOVER.
I HELPFUL BECAUSE IT. IT IS
UNDER. FOR THE EQUIVALENT WITH
THE- ACCOUNT THE BOARD INCOMING.
OR TO ADDRESS IN CONCERNS MAY
HAVE. A HAND IN MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE COURT
HAS. DECIDED. ALSO LET ME BE
CLEAR. THE NAACP SUPPORT STRONG
BLACKLY. THAT IS SEEKING TO
FURTHER STRENGTHEN OUR
COMMUNITY. ALL TO A THE
CENTER DISTRICT EMBODY THAT AND
MORE. AT THE BLACK LEADERSHIP
TEAM TO GO ABOVE AND BEYOND TO
MEET HE NEEDS OF CONTRA COSTA
RESIDENTS HERE IN THE COUNTY.
BY PUTTING NOTHING HAPPENING TO
HEALTH SERVICES YOU THIRTY
EIGHT THIS WILL JUST PROGRAM
SUCH AS FOOD PANTRIES. AND DO
TENDERLY AT THE PHOTO AND
DIRECTORS. PROVIDING PP DURING
COLD IT AND MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE VACCINATED GETTING
INFORMATION ON REGARDING THE
SCOPE OF PANDEMIC IN THAT
CIRCLE WITH YOU. WE GOT OF THE
ISSUE. BAPTIST BODY FACES.
STATE STREET FOR THOSE WHO ARE
LEFT BEHIND. THE NEGATIVE
SERVICES THEY CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
CANNOT PROVIDE WHAT IS THE
POINT IN HERE. BODY PROVIDE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD NOT TYPICALLY BE MADE
AVAILABLE THROUGH TRADITIONAL
MEANS. THE COMMUNITY HEALTH
DISTRICT HAS BEEN SUPPORTED BY
THE VOTERS IN THIS COMMUNITY.
IT IS SUPPORTED BY TWO THOUSAND
SIGNATURES THAT HAVE BEEN
GATHERED BY COMMUNITY MEMBERS
ATTESTING TO THE FACT THAT THEY
DO NOT WANT THIS BOARD
DISMANTLED. NOT TO MENTION
FAVORABLE COURT RULING. IT IS
IMPORTANT BOTH CONTAIN TO WORK
FOR THIS INDUSTRY. OF NEW YORK
HOURLY WHO WOULD BE UP. AND IT
IS SUPPORTED THE JOB THEY
DIDN'T BEACH AND EVERYTHING.
AND ARE CURRENTLY. OF
RECOGNIZING THAT WE HAVE TO
STAND IN SUPPORT OF SOCIAL
JUSTICE ISSUES. VOTING NO ON
EIGHTY NINE OH THREE GIVES YOU
THAT OPPORTUNITY AND THE
PROCTOR AND LOCAL POLITICS
AROUND ITS CREATION ARE WOUNDED
IN THE DECISIVE CULTURE. OF
LAWS OF OUR SOCIETY WHICH IS
SEEKING. TO CORRECT THAT TODAY.
EIGHTY NINE OH THREE IT'S NOT A
GOOD SOUND GOVERNMENT BILL THAT
THE FLEX THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE. THEREFORE I URGE YOU TO
PLEASE VOTE NO ON EIGHTY NINE
OH THREE THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU MODERATE OR DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER CALLS ABOUT IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION OF
AB NOT ALL THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO THROUGH A LINE OF ONE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I AM
WORKING WITH THEPHYSICIAN THAT
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF THE TWO OH TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I THINK YOU JUST WHEN
YOUNG PRESIDENT OF THE LOOK BUT
I DON'T COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY NINE OH THREE. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE A
SEVENTY TWO YEAR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU ANTHONY CHANNEL WITH
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION. REPRESENTING OVER
ONE THOUSAND INDEPENDENT LOCAL
AGENCIES AND AFFILIATED
ORGANIZATIONS IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AT THE TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU- THE C. TO HAVE
ANYBODY. IN THE ROOM THAT HAS
ANY SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
ANYBODY IN THE WAITING ROOM.
OKAY HOW ABOUT TO COMMITTEE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. SEEING
NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
YESTERDAY STRUCTURE. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE.
AS A LIFETIME MEMBER OF THE N.
DOUBLE ACP AND A MAN OF COLOR
THE NATIVE AMERICAN IN IN THIS
WORLD. I'D LIKE TO REMIND THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS THOSE WHO SPOKE AGAINST
A BILL THAT DOESN'T LUCIEN. OF
A MISMANAGED HEALTHCARE
DISTRICT IS NOT NEW IN TWENTY
TWELVE THE CONTRA COSTA LEFT
WHO VOTED TO DISSOLVE THE
NOTABLE HEALTH CARE DISTRICT
AND ITS FIVE MEMBER ALEXA BOARD-
OF THEIR AUTHORITY INTERNET
OVER. INSURED THE PROPERTY TAX
REVENUES AND DUTIES OF THE CITY
OF CONCORD. THIS WHOLE BILL
COMES DOWN TO ONE SIMPLE
QUESTION. IF YOU HAD A MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD YOU GIVE HALF OF
IT AWAY TO LAWYERS NON ELECTED
BUREAUCRATS. OR WOULD YOU SPEND
EVERY RED CENT HELPING THE
WOMEN AND CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
IN YOUR COMMUNITY THAT REALLY
DO NEED IT. FOR ME THAT'S AN
EASY DECISION. MY PEOPLE COME
FIRST. AND THAT'S WHY AT THE
REQUEST OF THE COMMUNITY. WELL
THAT I SERVE. I URGE MY VOTE
FOR A BI NINE OH THREE THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY TO HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND. OKAY AND I
SHOULD ALSO ADD THAT THE
CHEROKEE ARE CURRY. RECOMMENDS
A SUPPORT. THE CALL FOR THE
QUESTION. LACKEY HI LACKEY I
BLOOM BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH.
ALTHOUGH. RIVERS BERMAN HI
READERS LAUDABLE FOR FAR BEHIND.
OKAY ZERO. ROGER THANK YOU FOR
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES. OKAY
LET'S GO BACK TO. I AM TOO I
UNDERSTAND THAT OF MYSTERY US
ARE YOU PRESENTING. OKAY IF YOU
WOULD DO SO. RIGHT. WELL
COLLEAGUES IN SURVIVES CHAIR
COULD SEE THIS AFTERNOON WHEN I
THINK OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR CONSIDERATION
ENGAGEMENT ON ON THIS BILL AND
I'VE ACCEPTED- OR DO ACCEPT ALL
THE PROPOSED CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS- AND SO AS WE ALL
KNOW UNFORTUNATELY I. DID TOO
WELL IS THAT- THE MANY FACTORS
THAT- HAVE CONTRIBUTED AND-
THEY CONTINUE TO LOOK. AT QUé
EXCUSE ME CONTRIBUTED TO
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CRISIS- THE
YOU KNOW THE IMBALANCE BETWEEN
THE AVAILABLE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOMES TO GROWING
HIGH DEMAND OF HOUSING- IT HAS
LED TO EXCESSIVE RENT BURDENS
HOUSING INSTABILITY AND
INCREASING HOMELESSNESS. ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SO THE REALITY IN
MOST CITIES AND TOWNS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AS WE HAVE LOCAL
PLANNING. AND REGULATORY
SYSTEMS THAT DIRECTLY AND
INDIRECTLY RESTRICT HOUSING.
PRODUCTION AND DO SO IN MANY
WAYS WE SEE REQUIRING PARKING
SPACE MINIMUMS IMPOSING- SOME
BUILDING HEIGHT LIMITS HAVE
BEEN LINKED THE SOME PERMITTING
AND ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. VIEW-
SOME PROCESSES. AND HAVING VERY
RIGID ZONING AND DENSITY AND
YOU SPACE PLANNING SYSTEMS.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS PUBLISHED
BY THE L. A. O. LOCAL ANTI
GROWTH POLICIES AND LOCAL
BALLOT MEASURES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ACROSS OUR STATE.
HAVE EXPLICITLY AIMED TO LIMIT
HOUSING GROWTH HISTORICALLY.
AND SO AS A STATE OFFICIALS AND
THIS LEGISLATURE OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS. HAVE ATTEMPTED TO DO
MORE IN ADDRESSING CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS THE COMMITTEE
BILL ANALYSIS NOTED. VERY
ACCURATELY THAT WHILE CERTAIN
LOCAL VOTER APPROVED MEASURES
MAY NOT HAVE- CONFLICTED WITH
STATE HOUSING LAW AT THE TIME
OF THEIR ADOPTION. I STATE
HOUSING LAW EVOLVES AND HAS
EVOLVED AND WILL CONTINUE ABLE.
EVOLVE THESE INITIATIVES MAY
CREATE A CONFLICT THAT RENDERS
IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE LOCAL-
THE GOVERNING BODY TO COMPLY
WITH LOCAL MEASURES AND STATE
HOUSING LAW. AND SO CLEARLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- CITY
COUNCIL'S BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THERE IN A VERY CHALLENGING
SITUATION HAVING TO BALANCE
LOCAL PLANNING AND REGULATORY
HOUSING MEASURES. AND SYSTEMS
AND WORKING TO COMPLY WITH
EVOLVING STATE HOUSING LAW. AND
SO ENFORCEMENT POWERS GRANTED
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF H. C. D.
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. THEY ARE CHARGED
WITH THE AUTHORITY TO REVIEW
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMPLIANCE
WITH HOUSING LAWS. AND
DETERMINE THAT LOCAL HOUSING
ELEMENTS ARE IN COMPLIANCE FOR
MEETING STATE HOUSING GOALS AND
TARGETS NOW SUBSEQUENT ISSUES.
OF NONCOMPLIANCE BY A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WITH REGARDS TO
STATE HOUSING LAWS AND HOUSING
ELEMENTS. ARE TO BE REFERRED TO
THE SATE ATTORNEY GENERAL
COULD RESULT IN FEES PENALTIES
AND OTHER CONSEQUENCES. AND SO
THIS LEGISLATION. ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE THREE TWO TWO. IT'S A
PROCESS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND OPTIONAL PROCESS AS A TOOL.
FOR ANY CITY OR COUNTY TO SEEK
JUDICIAL VALIDATION THAT A
LOCAL HOUSING OR GROWTH MEASURE
IS IN CONFLICT WITH STATE
HOUSING LAW. SO THIS OPTION
WOULD RESULT IN AN EXPEDITED
JUDICIAL REVIEW OR A JUDICIAL
RULING ON THIS ISSUE OR THIS
QUESTION OF STATE AND LOCAL
PREEMPTION RELATED HOUSING
LAWS. IT WOULD PROVIDE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH IT WOULD YOU
KNOW WITH WITH WITH THIS OPTION
IT WITH WITH LEGAL CERTAINTY.
ABOUT THEIR HOUSING OBLIGATIONS
AND REQUIREMENTS IT'S A WITH ME
TO TESTIFY BY PHONE IS SERRA.
KARLINSKY SENIOR POLICY ADVISER
FOR THE CENSUS GO BAY AREA
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATIONS BURKE. AND
CHRISTOPHER ELMENDORF A LAW
PROFESSOR AT UC DAVIS WITH
EXPERTISE IN LAND USE THANK YOU
MISTER MISTER BASHER. THANK
YOUR MODERATOR COULD WE OF
PLEASE LISTEN TO THE MESSAGE
KARLINSKY IF SHE'S ON THE LINE.
YES HELLO- CAN YOU CAN HEAR ME
OKAY WE CAN'T THANK YOU. OKAY
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH MY
NAME IS ERIC KARLINSKY AND I AM
SENIOR ADVISOR IT'S BURKE A
PUBLIC POLICY THINK TANK
FOCUSED ON CREATING A
SUSTAINABLE EQUITABLE AND
PROSPEROUS REGION AND STATE.
BRAD TO SPONSOR AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO THE HOUSING ELEMENT
LOCAL OPTIONS ACT. I'D LIKE TO
FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON WHY THIS
BILL IS NEEDED. I LIVE IN A
SMALL TOWN CALLED PIEDMONT.
WHICH IS AN INCORPORATED CITY
WITHIN THE CITY OF OAKLAND.
HE'S NOT AS WEALTHY AND 70%
WHITE. IT WAS ONCE KNOWN AS THE
CITY OF MILLIONAIRES. THE
AVERAGE HOME PRICES ALMOST TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. IN
THE WAKE OF THE MURDER OF
GEORGE FLOYD MANY OF THAT COULD
NOT JUST STAND BY AND ALLOW
BUSINESS AS USUAL. WE FORMED A
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATION CALLED
THE PIEDMONT RACIAL EQUITY
CAMPAIGNER PRAC. CORRECT WORK
IS FOCUSED ON EDUCATION
POLICING DIVERSIFYING CITY
LEADERSHIP AND HOUSING. SHE AND
HER HUSBAND WORKS WE QUICKLY
LEARNED THAT THE CITY PIEDMONT
HAS WITHIN ITS CITY CHARTER
REQUIREMENT DATING BACK NEARLY
A HUNDRED YEARS THAT ANY DINING
CHANGES NEED TO BE APPROVED BY
VOTERS. WE ALSO LEARNED THAT
PIEDMONT IS LIKELY TO BE
ALLOCATED ALMOST SIX HUNDRED
UNITS OF HOUSING TO PLAN FOR AS
PART OF ITS REGIONAL HOUSING
NEEDS ALLOCATION INCLUDING A
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX UNITS ARE
VERY LOW INCOME HOUSING.
THERE'S NO WAY FOR PIEDMONT TO
ACCOMMODATE THREE ALLOCATION.
WITH ITS CURRENT CHARTER
RESTRICTIONS. WE ALSO LEARNED
THAT THERE ARE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS AROUND THE STATE
THAT SHARE THE CHALLENGE AS SO
CALLED ENTRENCH CONSTRAINS.
HE'S GONNA TRANSFER ENCOUNTERED
STATE HOUSING LARA AND SHRINE
RACIAL SEGREGATION. THE USER
NOT BY ACCIDENT BUT BY DESIGN.
INTRANSITIVE STRAIGHT CODIFIED
EXCLUSIONARY ZONING FOR
APARTMENT BUILDINGS IN SMALLER
HOMES ARE RENDERED ILLEGAL.
EXCLUSIONARY ZONING RUNS
COUNTER TO THE FAIR HOUSING
GOAL OF RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
INTEGRATION. MANY CITIES OF
THOSE WHICH STATED RELYING ON
TO ACCOMMODATE MORE HOUSING OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF LEVELS OF
AFFORDABILITY IN ORDER TO
FURTHER IF THERE HAVE BEEN
CALLS. BUT THE CITY THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO FURTHER
FAIR HOUSING WITHOUT AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO. FINALLY
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
OF LOCAL CONTROL. WE SEE THIS
MEASURE AS RESTORE LOCAL
CONTROL AT THE COMMONLY WORK IN
THE VAST MAJORITY OF
JURISDICTIONS IN THE STATE. AND
THAT RESTORED LAND USE
DECISIONS TO LOCALLY ELECTED
BODIES WHO NEED TO USE THEIR
GOOD JUDGMENT AND DISCRETION
ABOUT BALANCING THE DESIRES OF
SOME NEIGHBORS WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF STATE LAW. WE
WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THIS TO
IT'S COMPLETELY OPTIONAL FOR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. WE THINK
THAT THIS MEASURE CREATES MORE
LOCAL CONTROL IN THE CURRENT
SITUATION. AND PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY TOOLS SO THAT CITIES
DON'T FIND THEMSELVES STUCK
BETWEEN A ROCK AND A HARD
PLACE. IF THEY TRY TO MEET
THEIR REQUIREMENTS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION MY
COMMENTS WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO AND MOVE
IT FORWARD. THANK YOU MS
KARLINSKY NOW- CHRISTOPHER.
ELMENDORF IF YOU'RE ONLINE. I
AM YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
BYE SURE LACKEY MEMBERS I'M
CHRIS ON THE DOOR I'M A
PROFESSOR OF LAW AT UC DAVIS
AND MY REMARKS THIS AFTERNOON
WILL PROVIDE LEGAL CONTEXT WITH
THE BILL. AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
TWO USERS A WELL ESTABLISHED
LEGAL MECHANISM TO HELP CITIES
AVOID THE TRAIN BACK THERE WILL
OTHERWISE RESULT CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CLIMATE ADAPTATION
NEEDS CRASH INTO VOTER ADOPTED
BIRTH CONTROL AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. THIS LEGAL BACK IS
CALLED VALIDATION. IT WAS
ORIGINALLY DEVELOPED THE CITY'S
COULD PROVIDE ASSURANCES TO
MUNICIPAL BOND INVESTORS. AFTER
CITY COUNCIL PASSES A
RESOLUTION AUTHORIZING THE
ISSUANCE OF DEBT. AS A BRIEF
WINDOW OF TIME IN WHICH ANY
INTERESTED PERSON CAN SHOW UP
IN COURT TO CONTEST OR TO
CONFIRM THE VALIDITY OF THE
RESOLUTION. COURTS ARE REQUIRED
TO SCHEDULE VALIDATION ACTION
HEAD OF OTHER CIVIL MATTERS. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO BUT USE
THIS MECHANISM TO CONFIRM THE
VALIDITY OF A RESOLUTION BUT
ACKNOWLEDGES. THAT A PROVISION
OF A CITY CHARTER OR PROVISION
ADOPTED BY THE VOTERS HAS BEEN
PREEMPTED BY STATE HOUSING LAW.
IMPORTANTLY AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
TWO DOES NOT ITSELF PREEMPTS
ANY LOCAL MEASURES THAT ARE NOT
NOW PREEMPTED. NOR DOES IT
CHANGE THE LEGAL STANDARD FOR
PREEMPTION. IT SIMPLY CREATE
THE PROCEDURAL FRAMEWORK
THROUGH WHICH CITIES MAINTAIN
BEAGLE CERTAINTY AT LOW RISK
ABOUT THEIR OBLIGATIONS.
WITHOUT THIS FRAMEWORK THREE
DAYS THE NORMAL STRESS. THE
CITY DESPITE THE HONOR VOTER
ADOPTED GROWTH CONTROL
EXPENSIVE STATE LAW THE
RECORDING HOUSING ELEMENT THE
CERTIFIED RESULTING IN
PROTRACTED LITIGATION AND IF
THE CITY LOSES LOTS OF LOCAL
CONTROL OVER MAX. CONVERSELY
THE CITY NOTED THAT IT WILL NOT
HONOR VOTER ADOPT RESTRICTIONS
BECAUSE IT THINK THEY'RE
PREEMPTED THE CITY'S LIKELY
FACE LAWSUITS FROM LOCAL ANTI
DEVELOPMENT GROUPS. THE CITY
THEN MOVE IN COURT IT WILL HAVE.
TO PAY THE PREVAILING PARTY'S
ATTORNEYS THE- UNDER HUNDRED
EIGHTY THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO.
CITIZENDIUM TO USE THE VALIDATE
MECHANISM TO GET A SPEEDY
RESOLUTION OF A LEGAL QUESTION.
AND WITHOUT BEING MADE TO PAY
FOR ANYONE ELSE LAWYERS. BEFORE
CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THIS BILL HAS BEEN A
REAL GROUP THAT WORKS. SPUR
ABOUT THE BALL ROLLING I HAD
SOME IDEAS AND A HOST OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ADVOCATES AND
ATTORNEYS. ALSO FOCUSING
STREAMLINED THE BILL. ARE THE
WINDING GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE
WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA BAPTIST MUCH THE
TAXED. I ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOUR ISRAEL NORTH.
WATER DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
CALLS OF SUPPORT AT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OVER THE NEXT LINE OF ONE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRACY RYAN ON BEHALF OF
THE WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTS
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES URBAN
COUNTY TO CALIFORNIA IN THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
WE JUST WANT TO GIVE OUR THANKS
THE AUTHOR SPONSORS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THERE DOES
IT WORK. TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN WITHIN MINUTES TAKEN TODAY
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BOTH GO TO
LINE A ONE NINETY THREE A LINES
OPEN. ONE NINE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE NINETY THREE
YOU'LL FIND UP IN DO YOU HAVE
IT ON MUTE. OKAY WE'LL GO TO
MAKE FUN OF UP TO TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BUT THE LEGACY OF CRYING IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO
ON BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY AT
HOME. THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
WORK. THANK YOU NEXT TO VOTE SO
LINE OF ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU ADD
BACK BOWLING ALAMEDA FOR
EVERYONE REPRESENTING CITIZENS
ALAMEDA COULD BE DIRECTLY
POSSIBLY AFFECTED BY THIS
LEGISLATION CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ZAKOPANE GARY CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
STE HI THIS IS AMBER PATTERSON
CITY CAMPBELL. SOMETHING YOU'D
BE AT SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO THANK. THANK YOU NXR
GO TO LINE OF ONE NINETY FOUR.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS DAVID KING I MEAN YOU
NEED CITY CALLING WITH EAST BAY
FOR EVERYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE THREE TWO TWO. THANK YOU TO
THE NEXT TO GO TO A LOT OF ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRIN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CERTAIN
CRIMES ON BEHALF OF THE
POTENTIAL YOUNG DEMOCRATS
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO. THANKS SO
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT ALAINA TWO
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MACINNES FROM OXNARD ON BEHALF
OF VENTURA COUNTY UNITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
OF A LINE OF- TO ALL FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TO- FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. DON'T GO TO LINE OF
ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO VALLUM RIGHTS ARE
MEMBER LUKE BRONTE- ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIAN BE HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
A BI. THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO.
THANK YOU. NEXT OVER A LINE OF
TWO OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALL RIGHT SO WE MORE SHAUNA
CALLING FROM- LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA ACT HAPPENS DENMARK
INDIANS REPORT. THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON- I TURN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE DOESN'T MATTER
NOT LIKE HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF TMG
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT AGENT.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF TWO OH
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS JOSH AMERICAN SOUTH PASADENA
RESIDENTS FOR RESPONSIBLE
GROWTH THIS COULD AFFECT OUR
CITY AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND NEXT TO THE LINE
OF TWO TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS HENRY FONG FOR
OF PEOPLE FOR HOUSING LOC IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU NOW
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. REPORTER ACTUALLY
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT GO AHEAD SIR
MISTER VICE CHAIR ALEX FOR THE
STRATEGIES THREE SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THE ROOM. WELL
NOW GO TO WELL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AND HERE SEE ANY
HERE ANY. MODERATOR WE HAVE ANY
CALLS FOR A OPPOSITION. GIVEN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. IN OPPOSITION OF
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ANDWE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YES MISS
PERHAPS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
A PERSON IN THIS BILL- MY CITY
IS ONE OF THE CITIES THAT HAS A
BALLOT INITIATIVE THAT PASSED
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN- AND WHEN I
READ THIS BILL- I HAD VERY
MIXED FEELINGS ABOUT IT BECAUSE
ONE I FEEL- THAT IN THIS
COUNTRY. A VOTE OF THE PEOPLE
IS ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL
INDICATIONS WE HAVE ABOUT THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS HAVE THE OBLIGATION
TO REPRESENT THAT WILL OF THE
PEOPLE. ON THE OTHER HAND MY
CITY HAS STRUGGLED FOR YEARS.
ON THE ISSUE OF DOES OUR BALLOT
IT IT DOES OUR PROP PROP A
CONFLICT WITH STATE LAW HCD
SAYS IT DOES. WE SAID IT
DOESN'T WE GO BACK AND FORTH
AND BACK AND FORTH BACK AND
FORTH. IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR
FIVE YEARS NOW. SO THE GOOD
THING ABOUT THIS BILL THAT
WOULD GIVE A QUICKER
RESOLUTION. THE PROBLEM THAT I
SEE WITH THIS BUT I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO ADDRESS THIS.
IS YOUR REQUIRING A LOCAL
COUNCIL TO MAKE AN AFFIRMATION
THAT THE BALLOT INITIATIVE
VIOLATE STATE LAW. MANY SMALLER
CITIES ARE NOT TO BE IN THE
POSITION TO MAKE THAT
AFFIRMATION IF THEY'RE NOT ABLE
TO HIRE VERY EXPENSIVE LAWYERS.
INTO IF THEY'RE UP HOLDING THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE THEN THE
FINDING THAT. THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE IS IN VIOLATION OF STATE
LAW IS IN CONFLICT WITH THEIR
DUTY AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL TO
UPHOLD THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE.
SO I WOULD SUGGEST THAT A
BETTER. RESOLUTION OF THIS IS
THAT THE COUNCIL CAN PASS A
RESOLUTION THAT SAYS IT'S A
VIOLATION AND- IT'S IN CONFLICT
WITH STATE LAW. OR NOT IN
CONFLICT WITH STATE LAW.
BECAUSE REALLY CITIES DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DETERMINE
THE CONFLICT IT'S YOU KNOW IN
STATE LAW. SO IT WOULD BE
BETTER I MEAN THE BEST
SITUATION WOULD BE IS IF. THERE
COULD BE SOMETHING WHERE THE
CITY SAYS I'M NOT SURE IF THIS
IS A VIOLATION OF STATE LAW.
COULD THE COURTS CLARIFIED AND
THERE COULD BE AN EXPEDITED
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE THEN THAT
PUTS THE COUNCIL IN A POSITION
WHERE GETS CLARIFIED IN THE
COURT. AND THE COUNCIL CAN
STILL UPHOLD THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE AT THE SAME TIME GET THE
CLARIFICATION SO THERE'S NOT I
MEAN I CAN'T I CAN'T TELL YOU
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
LEGAL FEES MY CITY IS GOING
THROUGH. TRYING TO GET THIS
CLARIFIED AND STILL THERE'S NO
JUDICIAL RULING ON WHETHER OR
NOT PROP THEY IS OR IS NOT IN
VIOLATION OF STATE LAW IN MY
CITY. SO ON THE ONE HAND I
WOULD LOVE TO SUPPORT THIS BUT
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
BECAUSE IT'SAN OPTIMIZER. I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A VERY
RARE CASE THAT A COUNCIL SAY.
THE WILL OF MY PEOPLE VIOLATE
STATE LAW THAT'S LIKE US.
STRANGE THING TO DO AND I'M
HOPE THAT HE WOULD BE WILLING
TO TAKE. A CONSIDER SOME
AMENDMENTS IN THE FUTURE- ALONG
THOSE LINES. YES I APPRECIATE
THOSE COMMENTS AND YOU KNOW- TO
BE QUITE HONEST WITH YOU I'VE
FOUND OUT. RELATIVELY RECENTLY
THAT I'D BE PRESENTING THIS
BILL TODAY AND THAT'S NOT MY
BILL- AND SO I. BUT YEAH YOU
KNOW I BELIEVE IN THE POLICY
AND SOON I'M GOING TO YOU KNOW
WORK WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS THAT
I HAVE YET TO ENGAGE WITH AS OF
TODAY IS NOW JUST- HAVE BEEN
PREPARING ALL MORNING. BUT E.
AND BUT I THINK IT YOU KNOW I
THINK YOU BRING UP IN IT YOU
KNOW IMPORTANT- POINTS IT IT'S
A GOOD QUESTION- YEAH I THINK
WHEN I LOOK AT. THIS THIS IS A
BILL- CERTAINLY IT REQUIRES
NOTHING BECAUSE AS YOU
MENTIONED IT'S OFTEN IT'S- YOU
KNOW IT'S AN OPTION I THINK
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE PROCESS.
AS IT'S STRUCTURED. AS PROPOSED
IN THE BILL AS YOU KNOW- IF YOU
TRIGGER- YOU KNOW WHAT ADOPTION
HORIZON- OF- A RESOLUTION AS AS
AS AS STIPULATED REQUIRING A
PUBLIC HEARING A- THE YELP. A
PUBLIC HEARING TO HAVE
DISCUSSION TO HAVE THAT PUBLIC.
INPUT IS A CRITICAL STEP YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY FOR YOU KNOW AT
I MYSELF AM SPENT EIGHT YEARS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THE KINDS OF
VISOR- YOU KNOW ITS- YOU KNOW
VERY IMPORTANT BUT- YOU KNOW
HOW YOU KNOW I'VE- YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND SPONSORS- TO
ADDRESS YOUR CONCERNS- AND- YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY. BE HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU THANK YOU SO
I WON'T BE SUPPORTING TODAY BUT
I DO HOPE THAT WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER. AND I CAN SUPPORT ON
THE FOR THE FUTURE. OKAY DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHE. OR FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SAYING NINE
ONE YOU'RE WELCOME TO CLOSE. I
TO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE STRUCTURE THANK YOU TO
HAVE A MOTION SECOND. YOUR OKAY
RECALL FOR THE QUESTION A- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMANDA
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY HIGH
COULD ADD REAL QUICKLY THE
CHAIR AGUIAR-CURRY- RECOMMENDS
A SUPPORT. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS A MAN TO HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT BLACKIE.
NO LACKEY NOW BLOOM. HELLO I
BOERNER HORVATH NOW
BOERNER HORVATH NO RAMOS. RAMOS
I THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
NUMBER RIVERSIDE VOEPEL WILL
TELL NOW YOU CURRENTLY HAVE A
THREE THREE. OKAY SOLD OUT FOR
A- PUT IT ON CALL FOR A LATER
AFFIRMATION NEEDS BUT TO MORE.
K. WHICH TO WORK OKAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTINO. ONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THINK- THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK
ON THE BILL I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINE OF THE
ANALYSIS IN THE BOTTOM OF PAGE
SIX REGARDING EASY PARKING AND
PARKING SPACES FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES I WANT TO TALK FOR
A SECOND ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
VALUES HAS REFLECTED ITS
POLICIES. ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES THERE'S AN AVERAGE OF
ONE THOUSAND SQUARE FEET
PROVIDED PER CAR BUT ONLY EIGHT
HUNDRED SQUARE FEET PROVIDED
PER PERSON PER HOUSING WE
DEDICATE MORE LAND FOR CARS
THAN WE DO FOR HUMAN BEINGS IN
THE UNITED STATES NOT L. A.
COUNTY PARKING MANDATES HAVE
LED TO AN ASTONISHING TWO
HUNDRED SQUARE MILES JUST OF
PARKING. THAT'S FOUR TIMES AS
MUCH LAND AS IN THE ENTIRE CITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO. AND YET A
STUDY FROM THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO OF TWENTY ONE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS FROM THE
39% OF PARKING THERE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED SPACES RUN USED. ACOSTA
BETWEEN TWELVE AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS. I CAN TELL YOU
ANECDOTALLY. FROM MY OWN
EXPERIENCE MY DISTRICT OFFICE
AND BURBANK. SHE HAS A PARKING
GARAGE IN. A PARKING STRUCTURE
THAT EVEN BEFORE COLLUDED WAS
MAYBE 15% OF CAPACITY ON EVERY
GIVEN DAY AND YET. THE SAME
CITY. RIGHT WHAT WITH WHERE THE
AREAS RIGHT NEXT TO A METROLINK
STATION. REQUIRES A LOT OF
PARKING BE BUILT FOR EVERY
SINGLE DEVELOPMENT WITHOUT EVER
TAKING STOCK OF HOW MUCH
PARKING IS AVAILABLE AND HOW
IT'S BEING USED. ONLY TALK FOR
A SECOND ABOUT THE CITY OF
BUFFALO NEW YORK. THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN REMOVE
PARKING RESTRICTIONS FROM THEIR
ENTIRE CITY. A NEW REPORT CAME
OUT THAT SHOWED. THAT WHAT
HAPPENED WAS DEVELOPERS WHO
NEED A PARKING STILL PROVIDED
PARKING BUT A LOT OF DEVELOPERS
BUILD SHARED PARKING
PARTICULARLY COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPERS. THEY ALSO FOUND
THAT A LOT HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF NEW
HOUSING UNITS WERE PRODUCED.
PARTICULARLY FOR STUDENTS AND
LOW INCOME PEOPLE WITH LESS
PARKING THAT WOULD HAVE
OTHERWISE BEEN. REQUIRED AND
YET WITH ENOUGH PARKING TO
PROVIDE FOR THOSE RESIDENTS. SO
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS THAT
WITH IN AREAS THAT ARE IN HIGH
QUALITY TRANSIT DISTRICTS. IT
WOULD SAY THAT IT'S UP TO
DEVELOPERS TO RIGHT SIZE THE
AMOUNT OF PARKING THAT THEY
PROVIDE FOR THEIR DEVELOPMENT.
THAT CITIES CAN NO LONGER
ARBITRARILY- AND UNEVENLY
DECLARE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
PARKING FOR THOSE. FOR THOSE-
NEW DEVELOPMENTS. A CROSS
CALIFORNIA IT RANGES FROM A
CITIES THAT WILL REQUIRE WATER
ONE AND A HALF SPACES PER
HOUSING UNIT UP TO TWO AND A
HALF SPACES PER HOUSING UNIT
REGARDLESS. OF THE TYPE OF
DEVELOPMENT IT IS. OF THIS IS A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL MANDATE
ACROSS THE STATE THAT IS NOT
SERVED AS TO WHAT IS A DONE
WHAT IS DONE AND IS IT'S
CREATED OF A SITUATION WHERE
IT'S HARD TO BUILD HOUSING IN A
LOT OF OUR AREAS BECAUSE THE
PARKING CAN RANGE FROM THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER SPACE
UP TO I'VE SEEN EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER FACE RACE FOR SOME
SUBTERRANEAN PARKING WHICH
MEANS THAT PROJECTS THAT ARE
MAYBE ON THE BUBBLE THAT ARE
TRYING TO CREATE HOUSING FOR
THE MISSING MIDDLE DON'T
COUNCIL AND THE DEVELOPERS JUST
WALK AWAY. SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO
ADD ONE UNIT LET'S SAY- LET'S
LEGAL. IN A MULTI FAMILY AREA
OFTEN CAN'T DO THAT BECAUSE OF
SPACE CONSTRAINTS. EVEN IF
THERE IS ALREADY SOME PARKING
ON THE WATER ENOUGH FOR THOSE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS. THE
POLICY ALSO ENCOURAGES A CAR
CENTRIC APPROACH THAT MAKES
WALKABLE BIKEABLE COMMUNITIES
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE. BECAUSE ALL
THAT PARKING SPREADS.
DEVELOPMENTS APART TO WHERE YOU
CAN'T WALK EASILY FROM ONE TO
THE NEXT. THINK ABOUT OLD
DOWNTOWNS AND HOW WONDERFUL IT
IS TO STROLL DOWN MAIN STREET.
IMAGINE TODAY ALL OF THOSE SAME
LITTLE SHOPS ALL HAVING TO
PROVIDE FIBRE TEN SPACES ON
THEIR OWN SITES YOU CAN'T BUILD
THOSE AREAS. AND YET CITIES ARE
FULLY CAPABLE OF CREATING
BETTER TRANSIT FOR PEOPLE. AND
SHARED PARKING IF THEY NEED TO.
MANY DOWNTOWNS HAVE MUNICIPAL
STRUCTURES BUT TAKE THE BURDEN
OFF OF. THE INDIVIDUAL
BUSINESSES SO CITIES HAVE A LOT
OF FLEXIBILITY. BUT THERE'S NO
REASON FOR THEM. TO CREATE GOOD
TRANSIT. IF THEY'RE JUST HAVING
EVERYBODY BRING THE CARS AND-
WHAT THAT DOES IS IT INCREASES
CONGESTION INCREASES BAD HEALTH
EFFECTS. IS A TERRIBLE USE OF
LAND. AND THIS BILL ONLY
AFFECTS AREAS THAT ARE ALREADY
CONSIDERED HIGH QUALITY TRANSIT
AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT IF YOU
FEEL THAT YOUR HIGH QUALITY
TRANCE IT'S ENOUGH.
THIS IS WHAT YOU NEED TO CREATE
THE POLITICAL WILL TO CREATE
THAT TRANSIT. BECAUSE OTHERWISE
IF YOU KEEP INVITING MORE MORE
CARS IN. IT'S VERY EASY TO SAY
HEY WE'VE GOT ALL THE PARKING
WE'VE GOT ALL THE CARS WE DON'T
NEED TO DO ANYMORE. IT'S TIME
TO END THAT MADNESS. TO REFLECT
OUR VALUES TO PUT THE FOCUS
BACK ON HUMAN BEINGS AND
INDIVIDUALS AND HOUSING UNITS.
AND THIS IS A SENSIBLE MEASURE.
THAT IS A LONG TIME IN COMING
IN SEVERAL CITIES IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE ALREADY MOVED. TO THIS
APPROACH AS YOU WILL HEAR FROM
ONE OF OUR WITNESSES. AND I
WITHOUT AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT THIS
MORNING ARE JEFF AND YOU ENDED
MAYOR OF BERKELEY. AND MEET A
KING THE SENIOR PRICE AS A
PRESIDENT OF RELATED CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BONTA
MODERATOR COOLEY PLEASE SURE
FROM. JESSE THE MEREB.
AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME GO
SOMEWHERE YES. GOOD AFTERNOON
AS THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
BERKLEY I AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT
AB FORTINO ONE NINETY THIS BILL
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO PROMOTE
SUSTAINABLE GROWTH TO MAKE
HOUSING MOREAFFORDABLE. WE
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
REDUCE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
BY 15% IN ORDER TO MEET IT'S SB
THIRTY TWO CLIMATE GOALS EVEN
IN A SCENARIO WITH FULL VEHICLE
ELECTRIFICATION. STUDIES IN
MULTIPLE CITIES INCLUDING
BERKELEY SHOW THAT MANDATORY
PARKING REQUIREMENTS HAVE LED
TO AN OVERSUPPLY PARKING BY
ELIMINATING PARKING MINIMUMS
CITIES CAN REDUCE ACCESS
PARKING AND ENCOURAGE THE
RESIDENTS TO TAKE MORE
SUSTAINABLE MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION THAT'S REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND IT
BE ICAL MISSIONS. FIGHTING
CLIMATE CHANGE REQUIRES BOLD
ACTION AND CHALLENGING LONG
HELD ASSUMPTIONS ON HOW WE LIVE
AND HOW WE COMMUTE. IN ADDITION
REQUIRING ACCESS PARKING HAS
BEEN SHOWN TO TRY WITH THE
COSTA HOUSING. MANDATORY
PARKING REQUIREMENTS WORSE IN
CALIFORNIA SEVERE HOUSING
SHORTAGE BY RAISING THE COST OF
HOUSING PRODUCTION. ON AVERAGE
A GARAGE COSTS TWENTY FOUR TO
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER SPACE TO BUILD AND THAT
COST IS PASSED ON TO
HOUSEHOLDS. REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THEY OWN A CAR. LIKE
WITH SO MANY ISSUES I AM PROUD
THAT BERKELEY IS JOINED OTHER
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN LEADING
THE WAY ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. IN JANUARY OUR CITY
COUNCIL VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO
ELIMINATE THE REQUIREMENT THAT
NEW DEVELOPMENTS PROVIDE OFF
STREET PARKING SPACES. ARE LAW
ALSO ESTABLISHED A PARKING
MAXIMUM APPOINT FIVE PARKING
SPACES FOR TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT. AND THIS WAS BASED
ON PARKING SURVEYS THAT SHOW
THAT MANY PARKING SPOTS IN- OUR
COMMERCIAL DISTRICTS IN IN
TRANSIT RICH AREAS OFTEN ARE IN
HOUSTON THIS IS CERTAIN THE
CASE IN CITIES LIKE BERKELEY.
THAT HAVE SOME OF THE HIGHEST
PEDESTRIAN BICYCLIST COMMUTE
RATES IN THE COUNTRY. REMOVING
OFF STREET PARKING WILL MAKE
PROJECTS MORE AFFORDABLE. AND
ALLOW MORE UNITS TO BE CREATED.
LIKE BERKELEY SLOT. BILL
FORTINO ONE GIVES DEVELOPERS
TOOLS TO RIGHT SIDE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS. AND NOT TO BUILD
MORE THAN WHAT IS NEEDED I WANT
TO THANK ASEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION TO MOVE
US TOWARDS REDUCING OUR
RELIANCE ON FOSSIL FUELS. AND
MAKING HOUSING MORE AFFORDABLE
AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. I KNOW THAT
THIS LEGISLATION WILL HELP US
ACHIEVE OUR GOALS OF ADDRESSING
THE INTERLOCKING ISSUES OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND
TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT MAKER PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS AMIR
KHAN AND I'M A SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT WITH RELATED
CALIFORNIA AND I'M ALSO A BOARD
MEMBER FOR THE COUNCIL INFILL
BUILDERS ONE OF THE BILL'S CO
SPONSORS- I'VE BEEN DEVELOPING
AND BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE LAST
TWENTY FOUR YEARS IN RURAL
URBAN AND SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND I'M
HERE TO TESTIFY IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI FORTINO ONE.
AS YOU HEARD- FROM THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN MOST
JURISDICTIONS STILL REQUIRE
EXCESSIVE ONSITE MINIMUM
PARKING REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL
DEVELOPMENT AND BUSINESSES
WHETHER THEY'RE NEAR TRANSIT OR
OR NOT- IT TENDS TO BE A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL ON SITE PARKING
REDUCES THE HOUSING SUPPLY BY
FRANKLY TAKING UP VALUABLE
SPACE THAT COULD OTHERWISE BE
USED TO BUILD. HOME PROVIDING
ONSITE PARKING AS YOU HEARD IS
A VERY EXPENSIVE DEPENDING ON
THE TYPE OF PARKING YOU KNOW WE
TYPICALLY WILL- ESTIMATE
PARKING TO COST BETWEEN THIRTY
AND. THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STATE BILL. A NEW
CAR TO PASS DIRECTLY. ON TO
HOUSE THE- IN DEVELOPER.
RENTERS AND HOMEBUYERS MAKING
HOUSING THINK. AGAIN LAY MORE
EXPENSIVE TO PRODUCE OWN
IMPRESS. ANY DECADE OLD MINIMUM
PARKING REQUIREMENTS FRANKLY
MAKE IT COST PROHIBITIVE FOR
ANY NEW DEVELOPMENT TO OCCUR
NEIGHBORHOOD BUSINESSES BUT
ALSO NEED TO ADAPT TO OUR
CHANGING. EIGHTY FORTINO ONE
WOULD REDUCE THE OVER OF
PARKING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IN
TURN THE BILL WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA REDUCE TRAFFIC
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
ENCOURAGE TRANSIT USAGE AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY IT WILL REDUCE
THE HIGH COST OF HOUSING TO
RENTERS HOMEOWNERS AND
DEVELOPERS YOUR HIGH QUALITY
TRANSIT. AND IT WILL ALSO HELP
TO CREATE REVITALIZED AND
PEDESTRIAN FRIENDLY WALKABLE
COMMERCIAL CORRIDORS IN
DOWNTOWN THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT
PROPERTY OWNERS FROM BUILDING
ON SITE PARKING RATHER AS YOU
BIRDS IT GIVES DEVELOPERS
FLEXIBILITY TO DECIDE. ON HOW
MUCH PARKING IS SUITABLE FOR
THEIR DEVELOPMENT RATHER THAN
STICKING TO THE ONE SIZE FITS
ALL MANDATES. WHILE SOME
GOVERNMENTS ARE TAKING BOLD
STEPS LIKE BERKELEY TO REDUCE
FEES UP PARKING MINIMUMS DOING
SO AND IN MANY PLACES IN NOT
ONLY BE EXPENSIVE BUT
POLITICALLY CHALLENGING- ALSO
AS A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC IN
THE CLOSURE OF MANY RESTAURANTS
SMALL SHOPS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE TEMPORARY ALLOWED
BUSINESSES TO UTILIZE ONSITE
AND STREET PARKING SPACE. TO
EXPAND THEIR OPERATIONS
OUTDOORS. LONDON FROM. OF
STEAKS OUTDOOR DINING AND
SHOPPING AS PROVEN THROUGH WITH
ALL THAT THERE ARE. MORE
PRODUCTIVE USES FOR EMPTY
PARKING SPACES SHOWING US A NEW
WAY FORWARD THAT CREATEA MORE
INVITING AND SUSTAINABLE
CALIFORNIA THIS CALL. MALL
BUSINESSES. YEP TO SURVIVE AND
IN SOME CASES DRIVING THE
PRODUCT AND INK WORLD
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE COMMITTEE
I VOTE ON AB FORTINO ONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU- BOTH THE CHAIR
AND THE VICE CHAIR- ARE UNABLE
TO BE. WELL THAT WAS SHORT
LIVED. I'M GONNA I'M GONNA
HANDS TO GET PEOPLE BACK TO THE
CHAIR. I APOLOGIZE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN WE HAVE ALREADY
DONE SUPPORT I ASSUME ANY
OPPOSITION SO TRUE- NO
OPPOSITION JUST THE SUPPORTERS
THE TO SUPPORT WITNESSES HAVE
SPOKEN OKAY GREAT AND WE HAVE
ALL THE- OTHERS THANK. WE
HAVEN'T DONE THE ANY OF THE
OTHER TESTIMONY TO THE TO
SUPPORT WITNESSES OKAY WELL
WHAT WE DO THAT OPERATOR PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR SUPPORT.
FIRST ONE WE DO YOU IF YOU
AREN'T SUPPORT. I'M SORRY GO
AHEAD THAT'S OKAY GO HEAD TO
THE LINE. THANK YOU IF YOU
AREN'T A PART OF AB FORTINO ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO OUR FIRST
LINE OF ONE SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE SEVEN THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN- OKAY WE WILL GO TO THE
NEXT LINE OF ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ZAKOPANE
GUARANTEE COUNCILMEMBER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU XO BOTTOM
LINE OF ALL ONE NINETY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS ALEXANDER ESPINOZA
PEOPLE I'M WITH CUPERTINO FOR
ALL AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
FORTINO ONE. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWO THIRTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER
WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE'RE
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF TO ALL ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS NEIL
PARK THE PROJECT WITH CUPERTINO
FOR ALL ON THE CHAIR AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTINO ONE.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF ONE AND SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON
I MEDICARE MEMBERS LOSE BRONTE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIAN BE
HERE TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
FORTINO ONE AS A CO SPONSOR.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINED UP TO
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROBERT BROCKMAN
SAN FRANCISCO YET IN THE- IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ANOTHER NOT LIKE HOW
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ASEAN HELD TMG
PARTNERS AND FIELDS THAT IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF
TWO THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWO THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LET ME YES. YEAH THANK
YOU- MY NAME IS OFTEN TELL
THEM- CALLING I'M TRYING TO
CALL ON BEHALF OF HELPING SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY AND SANTA CRUZ IN
BE IN A STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF TWO FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SORRY
THEY HUNG UP SO WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF ONE EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT ENSURING MEMBERS AREN'T
ABLE AND FAIR REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
SUPPORTED COMMENDED POSITION
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE
NUMBER TAKEN SO FAR AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR- SPECIFICALLY
ON THE RESIDENTIAL PORTION OF
THE BILL TO INSURANCE- THERE'S
NOT AN UNDERMINING OF THE
DENSITY BONTA FOND REQUIREMENTS
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
EXCHANGE FOR PARKING REDUCTIONS
BUT APPRECIATE THE GOAL OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
THAT WILL GO TO LINE UP TO
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S MY
NAME IS HENRY OCCUR CALLING
FROM SANTA CRUZ REPRESENTING-
SANTA CRUZ SENIORS FOR HOUSING.
IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTINO ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MEXICO
LINE OF TWO THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
KATIE HELPING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB FORTINO ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANKS OVER LINE
OF ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
ADAM BOOKBINDER CITY CAN'T STOP
THE INDIAN ACT OR AB FORTINO
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU LIKE
SOBRE LINE OF TWO OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND TWO ZERO NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THE
CONSTRUCTION WORK WITHOUT
PAKISTAN'S FIRST BAKUL GROWTH
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU NEXT OF ALL LINE OF- TWO OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT
TO BE MORE SHAUNA CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES WITH WEBSITE FOR
EVERYONE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF TWO HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MACINNES A VENTURA
COUNTY IN BE STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK TOOK OUT A LINE
OF ONE NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN- HI MY NAME IS DAVID KING
I'M WITH THE STATE CAPITAL ONE
CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TWO THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ROGER
DICKINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU XLR LINE UP
TO TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS- PUBLIC
MORE- YEAH THOUSAND EAST BAY
FOR EVERYONE AND- CALIFORNIA B.
AS WELL- AND- TONY THIS
PORTABLE. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
OF TWO FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS KATHY
BAME CALLING FROM PALO ALTO
WITH STUDENTS LEFT FOR EVERYONE
AND YOU'LL BE ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWO
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN WHITE KP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
MODULAR BUILDING INSTITUTE ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT LOCAL LINE UP TO FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS JORDAN
CRIMES ON BEHALF OF POTENTIAL
YOUNG DEMOCRATS CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FORTINO
ONE. THANK YOU NEXT WILL GO TO
ONE OF YOU ALL FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HEY THIS IS SAID
COMPORTED WITH THE STATE FOR
EVERYONE- IN SUPPORT THANKS.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF TWO THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWO THREE TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NEXT WE'LL GO TO A
LINE OF- TWO FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON J.
ARE- IN CALLING FROM CUPERTINO
FOR ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FORTINO ONE. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF TWO TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
RAVI COOKING OUT AND I'M FROM
SAN DIEGO AND LIKE- SPEAKING
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO A LINE OF
TWO THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M A
LAWYER SHOULD AMEND PRESIDENT
OF THE DAVIS COLLEGE DEMOCRATS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWO
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CAN YOU HEAR ME GO AHEAD. I
DON'T KNOW THIS IS A LIFE. HI
MY NAME IS EMILY AND I'M
CALLING FROM NOW CAN YOU GIVE
ME WHICH FROM COURT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK LINE OF TO SIR
THREE YEAR LINE IS OPEN. THEY
DROPPED ARE YOU SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
KATHY CARRIAGE FROM THREE FIFTY
BAY AREA ACTION AND WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TWO FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS CHARLES WHICH
IS HAPPENED SENTENCES BILLION
B. I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB IN A ONE. THANK
YOU MEXICO CAROLINA OF ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI IS BANKROLLING- REPRESENTING
YOU IN THE ACTION IN THE BAY
AND ALAMEDA FOR EVERYONE
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE A ONE
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN-
HI THIS IS AN ALL REPLICA
BETWEEN ACROSS- I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE UP TO
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS MATTHEW LEWIS OF SOUTH
BERKELEY NOW AND CALIFORNIA B.
I'M CALLING STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
UP TO FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS ARJUN COSTS ALONG
I'M CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FORTINO
ONE. THANK THANK YOU
EXTROVERTED LINE OF TWO FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON KIMBERLY DONE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN OH ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. EXTROVERT
A LINE UP OF TWO FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ACTOR BROCK-
WITH CALIFORNIA YIMBY A
COMPETITOR COUNTY CALLING
INSTRUCT THE PARTY BEFORE YOU
KNOW WHAT THANK. THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO LINE UP TO FIFTY
THREE. POINT HI. WATSON WITH
MOUNTAIN VIEW YOU'LL BE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FORTINO ONE.
THANK YOU AN I TOOK OUT A LINE
OF A TWO TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HENRY FONG OF THE
PEOPLE FOR HOUSING ORANGE
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO SO LINE OF TWO FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS BRIAN PRESS KIT I'M
CALLING IN FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA AS A MEMBER OF SOUTH
BAY YIMBY I'M ASKING YOU TO
SUPPORT A. B. ONE FOUR ZERO ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
TO GO TO LINE OF BY TWO FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ANTHONY TO DO
SINCE FROM ABUNDANT HOUSING LA
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FORTINO ONE WHICH WE ARE
COSPONSORING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BUT I'M SURE WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU FOR FROM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MY AUNT
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- SKEWS ME I STILL
HAVE- SOMEONE IN SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY HERE YEAH APOLOGIES OUT
MADAM CHAIR ALEX TORAH'S WITH A
STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF
OF THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION
IN SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR NOT ACKNOWLEDGING SOONER.
OKAY LET'S SEE WE HAVE OUT
THERE DO YOU WANT IN OPPOSITION
FOR THIS BILL. OPERATORS ARE
ANYWAY AND WHEN YOU WANT TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
DO YOU IF YOU'RE IN A POSITION
OF AB FORTINO ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN OPPOSITION. AND
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THE
TIME MANAGER GREAT THANK YOU-
OTHER ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR ON EARTH. I'M THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION-
WHEN I LOOK AT THIS I SEE THAT
YOU HAVE SOME VERY VALID
ARGUMENTS ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN PARKING- IS. REDUCED TO
THAT HOW THAT GENERATES DEMAND
FOR TRANSIT THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
I HAVE TO SAY MY DISTRICT IS
OUR TRANSIT IS VERY LOW
QUALITY. WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING WHICH IS NOWHERE IN
SIGHT. REDUCING THE PARKING
MINIMUMS DOWNTOWN CREATES A
MASSIVE PROBLEM THAT WILL TAKE
TEN TO TWENTY YEARS TO DO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE NEED TO
DO TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
FUNCTIONAL TRANSIT THAT SO MANY
OF THE CALLERS FROM THE BAY
AREA FROM LA FROM EVEN DOWNTOWN
SAN DIEGO. ALREADY ENJOY SO ONE
OF MY QUOTE YOU KNOW QUESTIONS
MAYBE WE AGREE TO DISAGREE ON
THIS IS YOUR BILL DOESN'T IN MY
MIND PROPERLY DIFFERENTIATE
BETWEEN QUALITY TRANSIT AT WHAT
POINT THEN THESE PARKING
MINIMUM- DISREGARD BECOMES
VALID. SO FOR EXAMPLE IN MY
DISTRICT WE HAVE TRAIN STATIONS
ALL ALONG THE COAST. BUT YOU
CANNOT GET FROM A TO B. AT ALL
BECAUSE THERE'S NO CONNECTION
ANYWHERE ELSE THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO YOU YOU CAN'T EVEN IN MY
CITY IF YOU LIVE DOWNTOWN GET
TO A GROCERY STORE. YOU KNOW
UNLESS YOU WANT TO GO TO A VERY
EXPENSIVE ONE SO THAT'S NOT
PRACTICAL RIGHT NOW AND IF WE
DON'T TIE REDUCTION OF PARKING
MINIMUMS TO INCREASE IN TRANSIT
FUNDING FOR THOSE AREAS THAT DO
NOT HAVE FUNCTION TRANSIT. I
THINK WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
ACTUALLY CREATING A PROBLEM
THAT WE DON'T NEED TO CREATE SO
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE WILLING
TO WORK WITH ME ON THIS I DO
HAVE VERY SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT WHAT THIS WOULD DO
SPECIFICALLY IN MY DISTRICT. IN
SUBURBAN DISTRICTS GENERALLY
WHO DO NOT WHO WOULD MEET THE
QUALIFICATIONS IN YOUR BILL FOR
THE PARKING REDUCTIONS YET DO
NOT HAVE THE MEANS OF
EFFECTIVELY INCREASING. OUR
PUBLIC TRANSIT NETWORK. THANK
YOU I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CONCERN AND I'M VERY HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU AND
OTHER MEMBERS- THAT FEEL THAT
THE BILL- MIGHT. HAVE YOU KNOW
DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES. I WOULD SAY THAT.
FINDING WAYS OF SPRING
COMMUNITIES TO DO BETTER LOCAL
TRANSIT WHEN YOU HAVE RAIL IS
AN IMPORTANT GOAL OF THE BILL
AS WELL. AS CHAIR
TRANSPORTATION I'M ALSO VERY
COMMITTED TO GETTING MORE
FUNDING FOR TRANSIT IN ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES INCLUDING YOURS
BUT VERY HAPPY. THE FIRST
COMMITTEE HEARING IS A LONG WAY
TO GO AND I'M SURE WE'LL BE
DOING YOU KNOW WORK ON THIS
BILL THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS BUT
I DO APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERNS
AND THANK YOU FOR VOICING THEM.
OTHER QUESTIONS. REMAIN
LACKING. YEAH THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I DO HAVE SOME
OF THE SAME CONCERNS. AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM OCEANSIDE. BUT
IN THE SAME RIGHT AT. I DIDN'T
HEAR YOU ACCEPTED MEMBERS. I'M
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT. ACCESS FOR
THE HANDICAPPED I GUESS I DID
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AND THE
BEGINNING OF AND I AM ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS. SO THERE WILL
BE THE HANDICAP WILL BE
PROVIDED AND HE BE CHARGING
THIS WHILE I'M ON I WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE SOME CLARITY ON WHAT.
HOW YOUR BILL ADDRESSES THE
HANDICAPPED. WITH THE AMENDMENT
WHAT WHAT DOES IT MEAN- YOU
KNOW THE AMENDMENT CAME FROM
THE COMMITTEE STAFF SO I. I
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW IT'S
WORDED I'D ACTUALLY HAVE TO
PULL THE BILL OUT AND TAKE A
LOOK MAYBE- I UNFORTUNATELY
DON'T HAVE A STAFFER HERE YOU
KNOW WHO CAN HELP ME BECAUSE OF
BECAUSE OF IT. I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S A COMMITTEE STAFFER
FROM- FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHO
MIGHT BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT.
WE CAN GET YOU THE ANSWERS AS
WELL AND ONCE AGAIN AND I'M
GONNA LET THE CHAIR BUT WE ARE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK AND WE
CERTAINLY KNOW THAT THERE ARE
VULNERABLE PEOPLE WHO NEED
PARKING. AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
DOES HAPPEN BUT- CHAIR DID YOU
WANT TO HELP US WITH THAT. I'M
I CAN DO THAT IN A SECOND BUT
WELL I CAN DO NOW- THIS TOO WAS
AN ISSUE FOR ME AND SO- WE-
WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE
RECOGNIZE THE ADA PARKING
STANDARDS SO. IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR THE CONSISTENCY WITH OTHER
STATE POLICIES ENSURING THAT WE
DO NOT BACKSLIDE ON
REQUIREMENTS AND ENSURE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE. SPACES ACCESSIBLE
TO PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES SO
WE DID PUT SOMETHING IN ADDRESS
THAT IN. THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS SO THEY'LL HAVE TO
STILL PROVIDE THE EIGHTY
PARKING SPACES THAT WE WOULD.
HAVE HAD TO PROVIDE A WOULD ONE
CENT. THE LAST THING WE WANT TO
DO IS. BATHROOM WELL NOT ONLY
THAT BUT I MEAN I I'M VERY
SENSITIVE TO THAT FOR NUMBER
REASONS- BY ONE OF THE MOST.
WAS THAT MY FATHER WAS VERY
DISABLED FOR LESS LIVING YEARS
OF HIS LIFE AND REQUIRED. HE
WAS NON AMBULATORY SUMMIT HAD
NEVER WILL CHAIR EVERY WENT AND
MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT. AND
WHEN THERE'S NOT. ADEQUATE
PARKING THEIR LIVES ARE
MINIMIZED SUBSTANTIALLY SO.
THANK YOU YEAH AND I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR POINTING THAT OUT
TO US AND WE ABSOLUTELY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE ADA
SPACES THAT ARE REQUIRED-
LEGALLY. WILL BE REQUIRED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL. YES-
ONCE AGAIN IN MY DISTRICT I
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT PROBLEM I. HAVE A
VERY RURAL DISTRICT BUT ALSO
ABOUT 60% OF IT. OUR YOUNG
GROWING CITIES WITH LIGHT RAIL
THROUGH THEM. SO THOSE CITIES
TEND TO LIKE PARKING. AND THEY
REQUIRE EXTRA PARKING. IN THE
PARKING SPACES- EVEN BIGGER
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE PEOPLE IN
THAT DISTRICT. DR LARGE TRUCKS
THEN IF THEY GOT A GIANT SMELLY
DIESEL TRUCK IT'S EVEN FUNNIER
FORM SO- WHAT I'M THINKING IS
WOULD THERE POSSIBLY BE AN
AMENDMENT- THAT WE COULD DO-
THAT WOULD EXEMPT. CITIES A
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND BELOW.
FROM THIS PARTICULAR BILL
BECAUSE I'M I'M SPOT ON WITH
YOUR OF FOR. THE GIANT URBAN
AREAS I MEAN SAN FRANCISCO LA
SAN JOSE. GOT IT THIS IS A
GREAT BILL BUT FOR SOME OF THE
OTHER SMALLER AREAS MAY NOT BE
SO GOOD SO I'D LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU TO. IF POSSIBLE IN THE
FUTURE ON THAT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THANK YOU AND WE'RE CERTAINLY
WILLING TO TALK TO ANY MEMBER
AND MAKE SURE THAT THIS WORKS
FOR EVERYONE I WILL SAY THAT
NOTHING IN THE BILL. OF
PROHIBITS DEVELOPERS ARE ADDING
PARKING AND THE EXPERIENCE
MOTHER CITIES HAS BEEN THAT THE
DEVELOPERS WANT PEOPLE TO USE
THEIR DEVELOPMENT- AND WHEN
THEY'RE LEFT TO THEIR OWN YOU
KNOW THE FREE MARKET I WILL SAY
WORKS IN A LOT OF CASES AND FOR
INSTANCE PEOPLE BUILDING HIGH
END LUXURY APARTMENTS ARE
PROBABLY GOING TO PROVIDE MORE
PARKING THAT I WOULD LIKE THEM
TO PROVIDE. BUT THEY'RE GOING
TO DO THAT BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THAT IF THEY DON'T DO THAT THE
UNITS WILL READ FOR A LESSER
AMOUNT OF MONEY THIS IS REALLY
GOING TO HELP THOSE MIDDLE
CLASS DEVELOPMENTS WHERE
THEY'RE TRYING TO AIM AT THE
MORE COST CONSCIOUS YOU KNOW
YOUNGER PEOPLE WORKING YOU KNOW
WORKING PEOPLE. AND IN AREAS
WHERE THEY KNOW THEIR CUSTOMERS
ARE GONNA SHOW UP IN A PICKUP
TRUCK. THEY'RE GOING TO SAVE
THE HOME DEPOT DOWN THE BLOCKS
GOT THE SPACES I'M GOING TO ADD
THE SPACES HERE OR THE CITIES
CAN HELP THEM BY BUILDING A
MUNICIPAL PARKING LOT THE
DOWNTOWN CITY OF GLENDALE HAS
THREE YES THREE OR FOUR
MUNICIPAL LOTS AND IT'S
DOWNTOWN. IT'S ALLOWED FOR A
REALLY VIBRANT MAIN STREET
FEELING THAT EVERYBODY LOVES
AND THE SMALL MOM AND POPS. YOU
KNOW THEY CAN OPEN THEIR LITTLE
SHOP WITHOUT HAVING TO PROVIDE
ALL THE PARKING THAT OTHERWISE
WOULD BE REQUIRED IT'S REALLY
WORKED OUT WELL SO CITIES HAVE
OPTIONS TO HELP WITH THAT
MANAGEMENT SHARED PARKING.
THAT'S WHAT BUFFALO FOUND
BUFFALO IS NOT A HUGE CITY I
USED TO LIVE NEAR THERE IN
ROCHESTER AND WHEN THEY TOOK
AWAY THE PARKING FROM THEIR
CITY VERY CLEARLY THEY FOUND
THAT THE DEVELOPERS ARE
ACTUALLY SHARING AND SAYING HEY
LET'S LET'S SHARE THIS PARKING
TOGETHER SO THERE'S A LOT OF
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE OUT THERE
AND I. I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
CASE WHERE THE MARKET'S GOING
TO HELP WITH THAT- AND. PEOPLE
WANT THE PROJECT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. BUT WILL WE WILL
WORK WITH YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLUE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
WAS LAUGHING A LITTLE BIT
DURING THE LAST DISCUSSION
BECAUSE I HAVE A THREE CITIES
UNDER A HUNDRED THOUSAND AND-
AND IN MY DISTRICT- AND THEY'RE
ALL VERY DENSE AND TO MOST OF
THEM ARE A 100% WOULD PROBABLY
QUALIFY- AS BEING WITHIN A HALF
MILE OF TRANSIT SO WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE LANGUAGE WE WANT TO
CRAFTED VERY CAREFULLY BUT- I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY I THINK THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT POLICY IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT POLICY DISCUSSION WE
HAVE BEEN. OVER PARKING AND
BUILDING TOO MUCH PARKING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES FOR MANY MANY
YEARS AND IT HAS- YOU KNOW IT'S
IN LARGE PART A RESPONSE TO
PEOPLE BEING AFRAID OF
DEVELOPMENT- FEAR OF
DEVELOPMENT HAS LED TO- ACIVIR
CONSTRAINT ON THE AMOUNT OF
HOUSING THAT WE HAVE BOTH
MARKET RATE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND- PARTICULARLY-
HOUSING FOR THE HOMELESS AND IT
IS NOT THE ONLY REASON THAT
HOUSING COSTS ARE HIGH BUT IT
IS DEFINITELY ONE OF THE
DRIVERS SO THE TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE CAN. HAVE A DEBATE
ABOUT HOW TO REDUCE- THESE UP
UP UP PARKING GOT REQUIREMENTS-
IT'S A VERY VERY IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION FORCE. I WILL- POINT
OUT THAT- WE LEARNED IN
DOWNTOWN THAT WOULD NOT
DOWNTOWN IN THE- BERGAMOT
STATIONARY OF FIVE OF SANTA
MONICA FOR THOSE OF YOU ARE
FAMILIAR WITH IT- THAT THERE
WERE HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
UNUSED PARKING SPACES-
PRIMARILY IN COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS IN THAT AREA- BUT
WHEN A STUDY WAS DONE THEY WERE
JUST YOU KNOW THEY THEY HAVE
BEEN THIS BILL THEY HAVE BEEN
SO OVER PARKED THAT THERE WERE
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF SPACES
THAT WERE GOING ON USED. EVERY
DAY WAS A TOTAL WASTE OF MONEY-
AND WHEN IT COMES TO HOUSING-
WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO LOWER THE
COST IS IMPORTANT THE OTHER ONE
CONCERN I HAVE AND- I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT IT- IT'S NOT GONNA
AFFECT MY BOOK TODAY- BUT I DO
BELIEVE THERE ARE SOME- AND I
HAVE TO SAY HAVING GOT- AMIR
KHAN THIS AS YOUR WITNESS- GOOD
GIVES GREAT CREDIBILITY- TO-
YOUR ARGUMENT IS THE AUTHOR ON
THIS. OTHER IT WON'T AFFECT A-
THE PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT SOME OF THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROVIDERS
ARE EXPRESSING SOME CONCERNS-
PRIMARILY BECAUSE- IT IT IT'S-
UNFORTUNATE- AFFIRMATIVE. OF
FROM THE- OF THIS ISSUE OF OVER
PARKING BUT- PARKING IS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE NEGOTIATED.
WHEN IT COMES TO DENSITY
BONUSES AND- PENCILING OUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS- SO
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT- OF
THESE POLICIES ARE NOT IN
CONFLICT WITH ONE ANOTHER-
BECAUSE THEY'RE BOTH. OBVIOUSLY
A HOUSING PRODUCTION IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT- AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS THAT YOU
HAVE OUTLINED IN YOUR
PRESENTATION ARE IMPORTANT AS
WELL- SO- WITH- WITH THAT ONE
ISSUE- HANGING OUT THERE- WHICH
I HOPE WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS. I'M HAPPY SUPPORT
THE BILL AND I MAKE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
SAYING NINE- WE- WE HAVE A
MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND. WE
HAVE A SECOND FROM-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I'LL JUST SAY
THAT IT'S VERY IRONIC WHAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING THIS AT RIGHT
NOW IN LOS ANGELES THEY'RE
LITERALLY USING UNUSED PARKING
CAPACITY TO. PUT TENTS UP TO
PUT HOMELESS PEOPLE IN THIS IS
THESE ARE THIS IS LAND THAT
REALLY SHOULD HAVE BEEN HOUSING
GOING WAY BACK AND THE FACT
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO MOVE
CARS TO DO THAT. THEY HAVE
ENOUGH JUST UNDER UTILIZED AN
UNUSED LAND THAT'S JUST
LITERALLY OCEANS OF CONCRETE-
WE NEED TO REPRIORITIZE WE NEED
TO PUT PEOPLE FIRST AND I'M
SURE THAT WE CAN NO THE REST
WILL SORT OUT AND INVEST IN
TRANSIT ALL OVER OUR STATE TO
MOVE PEOPLE AROUND IN A WAY
THAT'S MORE SUSTAINABLE WITHOUT
I WOULD REQUEST AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER DID
YOU. TAKE THE AMENDMENTS YES I
COULD BE A MEMBERS AGREED TO SO
MAKE SURE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FOR
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO REDUCE
THE COST OF HOUSING WITHOUT NEW
FUNDING. THERE IS A FAIR AMOUNT
OF EVIDENCE THAT MANY OF THE
PARKING STANDARDS THAT EXIST AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL HAVE LED TO
OVER DEVELOPMENT. OF COMMERCIAL
AND RESIDENTIAL PARKING. WITH
PARKING IF YOUR- IT THEY WILL
COME. ADDING MORE PARKING
MEASURABLY INCREASES DEMAND FOR
VEHICLE PARTNERSHIP. WHICH CAN
FRUSTRATE OUR ABILITY TO
ACHIEVE OUR STATE'S CLIMATE
GOALS. REDUCING PARKING
REQUIREMENTS AROUND TRANSIT
AREAS CAN MAKE. HOUSING MORE
AFFORDABLE AND OUR COMMUNITIES
MORE WALKABLE. I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ENSURE THE BILL
RECOGNIZE EXISTING EVEY AND ADA
PARKING STANDARDS. AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIKE HE HAD ALSO.
REQUIRED THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR
CONSISTENCY WITH OUR STATE
POLICIES IN ASSURING THEM. YOU
DO NOT BACKSLIDE ON THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ENSURE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE SPACES ARE
ACCESSIBLE. TO PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. WITH THAT I WILL
BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS A MAN TO
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. AGUILAR KERRY HI.
AND YOUR KERRY IRAQI. BLACKIE
NOT BOW. BLUE BLOOM I.
BOERNER HORVATH RAMOS RAMOS I
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS HI
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL VOEPEL
ALL RIGHT YOU CURRENTLY HAVE
FIVE ZERO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH. OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FIVE ALSO. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX ZERO TWO I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL AND NOTE THAT
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS BEFORE I
DIVE INTO THE DETAILS OF THE
BILL I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO TALK ABOUT PROCESS
AND HOW WE ARRIVED AT THIS
POINT. THIS BILL IS A PRODUCT
OF EXTENDED NEGOTIATIONS WITH A
WORKING GROUP COMPOSED OF
CITIES COUNTIES SPECIAL
DISTRICTS UTILITIES AFFORDABLE
AND MARKET RATE DEVELOPERS AND
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS THROUGH A
SERIES OF DISCUSSIONS FIVE
DISCUSSIONS ACTUALLY WE ARRIVED
AT SEVERAL CONCEPTS THAT I
BELIEVE PROMOTE ACCOUNTABILITY
WHILE NOT ADVERSELY AFFECTING
THE ABILITY OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO FUND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO SERVE
NEW HOUSING THESE CONCEPTS ARE
ALSO SUPPORTED BY A ROBUST
RESEARCH FROM UC BERKELEY'S
TURNER CENTER ON HOUSING
INNOVATION. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED
IN THE WORKING GROUP FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THIS IS TRULY AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW DIVERSE INTEREST
CAN WORK THROUGH THEIR
DIFFERENCES TO CREATE A GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY NOW ON TO THE
BILL AB SIX ZERO TWO IT
ESTABLISHES TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY STANDARDS FOR
THE NEXUS STUDIES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PREPARE WHEN
IMPOSING DEVELOPMENT IMPACT
FEES V. THESE INCLUDE
REQUIREMENTS THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS STATE THEIR
EXISTING LEVELS OF SERVICE
PROVIDED A CAPITAL FACILITIES
PLAN FOR PROPOSED EXPENDITURES
AND COMPLY WITH PUBLIC NOTICE
AND OPEN MEETING REQUIREMENTS.
THIS BILL WILL TIE FEES MORE
CLOSELY TO THE ACTUAL IMPACTS
OR NEW DEVELOPMENT BY REQUIRING
OR FORTY DEVELOPER BY REQUIRING
THAT FEES BE PROPORTIONATE TO
THIS WE'RE- OF A PROPOSED UNIT
OR UNITS. AN ADDITIONAL BENEFIT
OF THIS POLICY IS THAT THE
VOTERS WILL BE GIVEN AN
INCENTIVE TO DIVIDE OR SUB
DIVIDE PROJECTS INTO SMALLER
MORE NATURALLY AFFORDABLE
UNITS. THIS BILL ALSO DIRECTS
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
DEVELOP A TEMPLATE FOR NEXUS
STUDIES THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS MADE SHOES TWO
YEARS M. MAKES CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO THE WAY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS POSTER IMPACT
THESE ONLINE. RECENT AMENDMENTS
NARROWED THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
THE ONLY AFFECT FEES REGULATED
BY THE MITIGATION FEE ACT
STRENGTHENED AND CLARIFIED THE
REQUIREMENTS TO CALCULATE FEES
BY SQUARE FOOTAGE. AND
INCORPORATE SEVERAL BEST
PRACTICES SUGGESTED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ADVOCATES. COMMITTEE
COMMITMENTS WILL LIMIT THE
REQUIREMENT TO UTILIZE A
CAPITAL FACILITIES PLAN TO
LARGE JURISDICTIONS THAT WOULD
BE COUNTIES OVER TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND POPULATION.
AND TO MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING CHANGES TAKEN
TOGETHER THESE COMMONSENSE
REFORMS WILL PROVIDE
CONSISTENCY CLARITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE WAY THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DETERMINED
DEVELOPMENTAL IMPACT FEES. HERE
TO SPEAK ABOUT THE RESEARCH
BEHIND THIS BILL AND IT'S
IMPORTANT IN ADDRESSING OUR
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS R.
DAVID GARCIA POLICY DIRECTOR AT
UC BERKELEY'S TURNER CENTER FOR
HOUSING INNOVATION. AND LAURIE
FEILER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT
SAN DIEGO HABITAT FOR HUMANITY.
OPERATOR THE SUPPORTERS PLEASE
GIVE OPEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DAVID GARCIA
ON THE POLICY DIRECTOR AUDITORS
AND ACCOUNTING DIVISION UC
BERKELEY WHICH IS A RESEARCHER
POLICY CENTER FOCUSED ON ALL
MATTERS OF HOUSING ISSUES THE
LAND USE REFORM TO INNOVATIVE
CONSTRUCTION PRACTICES TO THE
HIGH COST OF BUILDING NEW
HOMES. TODAY I'M HERE TO LIFT
UP SOME OF OUR RECENT WORK ON
DEVELOPINGIMPACT FEES AND HOW
EIGHTY SIX OH TWO ALIGNS WITH
SOME OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS-
THIS OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS
THAT WE PUBLISHED THREE UNIQUE
PIECE THE RESEARCH ON THIS
EXACT TOPIC WITH THE SUPPORT OF
THE STATE HOUSING COMMITTEE
DEVELOPED PARTNER THE FIRST
THING I WANT TO SAY IS THAT. WE
DON'T FEES ARE VERY IMPORTANT
SOURCE OF REVENUE FOR CITIES
LOOKING TO MITIGATE THE REAL
IMPACT OF NEW HOUSING THE BUT
BECAUSE CITIES ARE GENERALLY
CONSTRAINED ON HOW WE CAN RAISE
REVENUE FOR THINGS LIKE PARKS
AND ROAD INFRASTRUCTURE. WBZ
ARE OFTEN TIMES THE ONLY WAY
SOME OF THESE CRITICAL PROJECTS
CAN GET FUNDED IT ISALSO TRUE
THAT FEES ARE NOT ALWAYS
CALCULATED OR ENCLOSED IN
TRANSPARENT OR EQUAL. MATTERS
WHICH MAY LEAD TO. ONLY BY FEE
AMOUNTS ON YOUR- WHICH- SHOWS
CLEARLY. ULTIMATELY UP. THE FOR
THAT NEW HOME- WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY ISSUE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE HOME PRICES
ARE. REALLY CONTINUE TO
SKYROCKET. AND OUR RESEARCH
SUGGESTS THAT SIMPLE CHANGES IN
THE CALCULATION IN THE
POSITION. OF DEVELOPMENT IMPACT
FEES CAN MORE PROPERLY ALIGNED
HE SEES. WITH THE ACTUAL
IMPACTS. WHILE ALSO LOWERING
DEVELOPMENT COSTS OVERALL- FOR
EXAMPLE. THAT SHIFTING TO A PER
SQUARE FOOT CALCULATION FOR
CERTAIN FEES RATHER THAN- J. A
PER UNIT BASIS WHICH IS WHAT
MANY TO DETECT- THAT CAN. IN
SOME CASES MORE ACCURATELY
REFLECT THE NEW ATTACKS THE
RESULT IN MORE RECENT COST- IT
IS CHANGE ALSO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALLUDED TO IT DOESN'T AND
INTENTIONALLY PUNISH SMALL UNIT
DEVELOPMENT. AS WE SEE TODAY IN
THE CITY THAT YOU THEY KERR
UNIT CALCULATION- AND SO EIGHTY
SIX OH TWO MAKES IT PRETTY
SIMPLE CHANGE. ALSO ALLOWS FOR
FLEXIBILITY IN INSTANCES WHERE
AS YOU CHANGE MAY. NOT BE
POSSIBLE OR OR ACTIVITY JUST
SO. AGAIN A CALCULATION IN A
POSITION OF IMPACT THESE IS A
REALLY TECHNICAL COMPLEX
PROCESS BUT THEIR PROPER
CALCULATION IMPLEMENTATION IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. TO ENSURE
THAT THESE ARE REASONABLE AND
TRULY REFLECTIVE OF THE IMPACT
WILL GROW HELLO- THIS BILL
TAKES. OF REASON THAT TOWARDS
BRINGING MORE TRANSPARENCY AND
BEST PRACTICES TO DIVIDING. THE
THESES- IN LINE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE FOR SO
FOR THESE REASONS WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CHANGES
PROPOSED BELT AND I'D LIKE TO
ATTEND ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FOR ALL
OF HIS WORK ON THE ISSUE- AGAIN
IT'S COMPLEX AND TECHNICAL
TECHNICAL BUT. IT IS REALLY
NEEDED SO I'M ALSO- JUST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AND THEN
YOU THE CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE
OR- FOR HAVING COME. NEXT WE'RE.
I DON'T KNOW YEAH RIGHT AFTER
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND LAURIE FEILER
I AM OVER SAN DIEGO HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY AND THE FORMER AND
FORMER MAYOR FOR THE CITY OF
ESCONDIDO I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
THOUGHTS AND EXPERIENCE WITH
THIS COMMITTEE AND I THINK YOU
A FAMILY MEMBER GRAYSON FOR
TAKING THIS ISSUE ON. WE ALL
KNOW THAT. THAT CALIFORNIA IS
IN HOUSING CRISIS COMES ABOUT
THAT EVERY DAY. AND AS A
PORTABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER
CALIFORNIA IS BECOMING
INCREASINGLY MORE EXPENSIVE TO
BUILD. IMPACT FEES ARE
SIGNIFICANT COSTS FOR OUR%
PROJECT ASK FOR OUR LAST
PROJECT IN EL CAJON WE WRITE A
CHECK. FOR A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
CONNECT WIDER TO FIVE HOMES AND
THAT WAS THE IMPACT FEE AS WELL
AS PAYING THE DISTRICT OR THE
ACTUAL CONNECTION. THAT WAS A
HARD CHECK TO WRITE. IN FEES.
OVERALL YOU TAKE ALL THE IMPACT
ARE CAN BE AS MUCH AS AND ARE.
OF THE TOTAL COST TO BUILD AND
CRASH THAT MEANS FIFTY TO
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER UNIT. AND THAT DID NOT
INCLUDE THE PROCESSING FEES
WHICH CAN ALSO ADD UP AND
CONTRIBUTE SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE
HIGH COST OF BUILDING. AT
HABITAT WE ARE SELLING OUR
HOMES AT THE AFFORDABLE PRICE
TO OUR FAMILIES. OF BETWEEN
THREE HUNDRED AND THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS BUT
THEY ARE COSTING AT. FIFTY TO
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
JUST TO BUILD AND WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING TO HELP WITH THE COST
SIDE OF THAT LEDGER- EIGHTY SIX
OH TWO PROVIDES TRANSPARENCY
AND CLARITY AS TO WHAT THE FEES
ARE DIRECTLY CONNECTED TO- BY
CREATING CLEAR GUIDELINES THAT
HELP TO CITIES AS WELL. IN A
CONTABILIDADE FOR THE NEXT TWO
STUDIES- WHILE I WAS THE MAYOR
PUBLICITY THAT CAN BE- I ALWAYS
WONDERED WHY DEVELOPERS BROUGHT
FORWARD HOMES THAT WERE SO
LARGE AND COVERAGE SO MUCH OF
THE LACK. AT LEAVING ANOTHER
CONSEQUENCE OF VIRTUALLY NO
YARD FOR CHILDREN TO PLAY- BUT
HE JUST WONDERED WHY ARE WE
BUILDING SUCH LARGE HOUSES THEY
CAME TO UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
ARE SO HIGH YOU HAD THE BILL
THAT THE FEES STRUCTURE.
MEANING HOMES WERE I'VE BEEN IN
THAT EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT RANGE AND
THAT SITE IS MORE OF YEAR
GRADUATED HOMES AFTER. AFTER
YOU HAVE PURCHASED YOUR FIRST
HOME AND THE NINE HUNDRED TWO
ELEVEN HUNDRED SQUARE FOO
RANGE OF THE STRUCTURE DOES NOT
SUPPORT THE BUILDING OF
NATURALLY OCCURRING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHICH WOULD. BE MORE
LIKELY. IN THAT NINE HUNDRED
TWO ELEVEN HUNDRED. THIS SPELL
I READ. THAT HE'S BECAUSE- TO
THE SQUARE. OF A PROPOSED UNIT
OR UNITS. WILL BE IN EXCELLENT
FIRST THAT INCREASE MORE.
HOUSING YOU FOR PER. I THINK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TEST
AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
FINISHED- AND BAKED. MEMBER FOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THANK
YOU FOR MUCH HAVE WITNESSED IN
THE GALLERY. ONCE AGAIN MADAM
CHAIR ALEX TAURUS WITH
STRATEGIES THREE SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES ONLINE FOR.
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB SIX OH
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF
ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS LOSE MONDAY ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIAN B. HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT AS A CO
SPONSOR OF AB TWO COULD DO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF TWO
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE A CLAIM ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY AT
HOME IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE NINE
ONE NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE MATTER
THAT WE HAVE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF TFG
PARTNER YOU CAN HELP PROPERTY
REPORT YEAH. THANK YOU. MEXICO
LINE OF TWO SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CHOPPERS BACK ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ALSO ON SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE A
ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON ABOUT
BOOKBINDER CITY CAMPBELL
WITHOUT THE INDIAN I SUPPORT
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO VOTE TO LINE UP TO
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROBERT BROOKMAN
SAN FRANCISCO CAN BE- AND SCORE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
CAROLINA OF TWO TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE HEAD
RECALL WITH PEOPLE HELP ORANGE
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
EIGHTY SIX OH TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO TIMELINE OF
TWO OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MEDICARE MEMBERS MICHAEL
DOWNING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATE THE WORK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LIKE TO GO TO
LINE UP TO FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS JORDAN GRIMES ON BEHALF
OF HOUSING ADVOCACY GROUP THAT
SOUGHT FOR EVERYONE PULLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX
OKAY. THANK YOU THAT'S ABOUT TO
LINE UP TO SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS KELLY
CALLING CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE DAIRY COUNCIL IN. THANK YOU
NEXT TO A LINE OF TWO HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MEXICANUS FROM THE INTER COUNTY
INDIAN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AN EXTRA VOTE TO LINE A ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON BACK PULLING
REPRESENTING YOU IN THE ACTION
AND ALAMEDA FOR EVERYONE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ONE NINE SORRY YES
I'LL BE FINE. OKAY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIX OH TWO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
VOTEL LINE OF ONE SEVENTY TWO.
ONE SEVEN TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE IN A CAMERA HELD AT
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION- WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR
HARD WORK OUT WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING OUT ANY
REMAINING CONCERNS OR- ISSUES
WITH THE BILL ONCE IT GOES ON
THE CURRENT- WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND I AGAIN EXPRESS
OUR GRATITUDE TO EVERYONE
INVOLVED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT CALL WILL COME FROM
THE LINE OF TWO SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU
HAVE A SON YOU. HELLO OKAY
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP TO TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS JESSICA
GEIGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION SANITATION AGENCIES
AND ALSO TESTIFYING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF. ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES AND
THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION WHO ALL
SHARE THE SAME POSITION ON THE
BILL. THE AMENDMENTS ACCEPTED
TODAY WE BELIEVE SUFFICIENTLY
ADDRESS OUR- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WE DO HAVE YOU ONE
MOMENT. AGAIN AT THE ONE AND
THEN ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF ONE EIGHTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA- WENT INTO THE
HEARING THIS AFTERNOON WITH
OPPOSE IN A LESS AMENDED
POSITION BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENT AND-
OUR POSITION ON THAT BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE UP TO SIXTY TWO YEAR LINES
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
CRITICALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES- WE ALSO CURRENTLY
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS WITH OUR MEMBERS- TO
SEE WHAT REMAINING ISSUES-
THERE MIGHT BE BUT DO YOU WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THE WORK- TO
MOVE THIS LEGISLATION IN A
POSITIVE DIRECTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I BELIEVE THAT'S THE
END OF OUR OPPOSITION. ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE THAT'S CORRECT. THANK
YOU ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
THING NINE- DRIVEN MOTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS. I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND I DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT AND MEANINGFUL INPUT
AS WELL AS COMMITTEE STAFF AND
THEIR HARD WORK IN GETTING THIS
BILL TO WHERE IT IS TODAY WHEN
CONSIDERING LEGISLATION RELATED
TO DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES THE
PRIMARY CHALLENGE PLANS AND
BALANCING TO LEGITIMATE POLICY
PRIORITIES. PRESERVING THE
ABILITY OF LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO FUND THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT NEW HOUSING
AND ENSURING THAT NEW HOMES AND
NEW HOME OWNERS DO NOT BEAR A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THIS
COST THIS BILL THROUGH ITS
COLLABORATIVE IN STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS STRIKES THE RIGHT
BALANCE BETWEEN THESE GOALS IT
WILL MAKE MEANINGFUL CHANGES
THAT IMPACT AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF HOUSING COSTS AND
IS A STEP TOWARDS MAKING MORE
HOUSING MORE AFFORDABLE FOR
MORE FAMILIES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I'VE- THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRING A BILL
FORWARD. AND YOU KNOW FIRST
LIKE TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR ENGAGING RELEVANT
COMMITTEES AND STAKEHOLDERS
EARLY IN THE PROCESS AND I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN DOING THESE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS FOR MONTHS
AND MONTHS AND MONTHS. TO
IDENTIFY MEANINGFUL REFORMS TO
THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING LOCAL
IMPACT FEES- WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS I THINK YOUR BILL
STRIKES A GOOD COMPROMISE ON A
VERY COMPLICATED ISSUE.
REQUIRING MORE FREQUENT NEXUS
STUDIES TO JUSTIFY FEE LEVELS
AND INCREASING THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THOSE STUDIES. IS A GOOD
GOVERNMENT REFORM MEASURE THAT
I AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT. SHARE
YOUR COMMITMENT AND DEDICATION
TO THE ISSUE I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE WITH YOU. IN THE FUTURE.
MOTIONS DO PASSES AMENDED TO
THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EGGY ARE
KERRY HI. AGUIAR-CURRY IRAQI.
BLUE BLUE ALL RIGHT
BOERNER HORVATH. RAMOS RAMOS
SIDE THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL PATEL
HI YOU CURRENTLY HAVE. FIVE
ZERO- CONTEMPORARY. FIVE FIVE
THANK. BERMAN MAY. THANK HAVE
KIND OF FOR. SEVENTY ONE. RIGHT
AFTER ALL. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MANAGER. THANK YOU ALSO I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
PALM DESERT FOR ALLOWING ME TO-
JUMP IN FRONT FIRST ME DESPITE
THE CONSULTANTS. FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU AND YOUR
TEAM FOR YOUR WORK AND I WILL
BE TAKING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHICH MOVE THE
DEFINITION OF GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS IN PROVISIONS FOR
THE RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL AB
TWELVE SEVENTY ONE AGAIN
CLARIFIES AND STRENGTHENS THE
SURPLUS LANDACT A BILL FOR AN
ACT I'VE WORKED ON IN TWO
PREVIOUS BILLS WHICH BEEN
SIGNED INTO LAW. I IN
PARTICULAR- THIS BILL
CLARIFIES- REALLY CRITICAL
PROVISIONS FOR ESTABLISHING
PROCEDURES APPLICABLES TO
DISPOSAL OF LARGE MULTIPLE
PAUL'S PERSONAL FIGHTS
ESPECIALLY MILITARY BASES
UNFORTUNATELY DUE OF ONE CITY
WHICH SHOW REMAINS IN
OPPOSITION SAYING THAT THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TARGET OF
25% CANNOT BE ACHIEVED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS SOMETHING
THAT WE DESPERATELY NEED IN ALL
AREAS OF THE STATE. THIS BILL
AGAIN STRENGTHENS THAT AND
HELPS GET US MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ESPECIALLY IN OUR
MILITARY BASES LET ME JUST-
ALLOW R. TWO WITNESSES- PETROL
GO VIRAL FROM A NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA INMATE MICHAEL
RAWSON FROM THE PUBLIC INTEREST
LAW PROJECT. THEY ARE HERE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. IF YOU
HAVE I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE-
OKAY- REMEMBER THIS IS A LOT OF
THIS IS. WE HAVE A LOT OF FIFTY
FOUR DOLLARS. I'M SORRY I CAN
BARELY HEAR YOU. I THINK I NEED
TO HIT THE BUTTON SORRY. FERRE
CAL DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
AND WE END UP. IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. OKAY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND WE
WILL GO TO A LINE OF ONE NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE ENSURING
MEMBERS DOESN'T MATTER NOT LIKE
HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF BIRDS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL HM. THANK YOU AND
AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION- SO SUPPORT WE'RE ON
AB TWELVE SEVENTY ONE. AND ONE
MOMENT WE DO HAVE ONE MORE IN
Q. AND AGAIN AT THE ONE AND
THEN ZERO. FOR ANY SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE UP BY TWO SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JEAN HURST CALLING INTO
DANTE HAPPENS DURING COUNTY TO
CALIFORNIA AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WE HAD AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THAT BILL. AND TO
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE AUTHOR AND- COMMITTEE STAFF
LOOK FORWARD TO REMOVING THAT
OPPOSITION WHEN THE MANAGER AND
PRINT. GREAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER TOM
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION THANK YOU
OPERATOR- DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THINGS NONE- WOULD LIKE A
MOTION. OKAY WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALMOST ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM. WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE TO
SUPPORT FOR US RIGHT UP- THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORD
AND WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
ON THE AMENDMENTS. THE SURPLUS
LANDS ACT PROVIDES UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITIES SECURE LAND FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I RESPECT
YOUR DEDICATION THE ISSUE SINCE
I'VE HAD YOUR **** SAID YOU'VE
DONE THIS A COUPLE OF TIMES AND
SO I APPRECIATE THAT YOU AND
THE SPONSORS ARE PROACTIVELY
TRYING TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES OF THE- SURPLUS LAND
ACT. CREATES FOR CITIES PASSED
WITH MANAGING THE REDEVELOPMENT
OF SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNTS OF LEAD
ASSOCIATED WITH SHUTTERED
MILITARY BASES. I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU AND RESPONSES OF
YOUR WORK TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND SPONSORS OF THE
SIMILAR SENATE BILL AS BOTH
BILLS MOVE THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. MOTIONS TO
DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE NEW
YORKER HI. ADD LACKEY. BLOOM
MMHM HI BOERNER HORVATH ALMOST
ALMOST ALL RIGHT LOS RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS HI ROBERT
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL. THE
AVAILABILITY YOU CURRENTLY HAVE
FOUR ZERO. THANK YOU FRAZIER.
THIS WILL BE A PART OF LIFE.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES
AND RIGHT AFTER THAT WE'LL DO
ITEM TEN A. B. TEN TWENTY ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES. SO WE'LL
START WITH FOR TWENTY EIGHT.
WELCOME WELL THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU TODAY ON AB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT- THIS BILL AND- IS RATHER
SIMPLE IN FACT IT'S ABOUT TEN
WORDS- AND I IT STRIKES AT THE
CORE OF OUR DEMOCRATIC
INSTITUTIONS WE MUST ENSURE
THAT OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
STRUCTURED IN A WAY THAT LEADS
TO THE BEST ELECTED
REPRESENTATION POSSIBLE THIS
BILL SIMPLY GUARANTEES
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR COUNTY
SUPERVISORS BY ALLOWING THEM TO
STAND FOR REELECTION AND GAIN
EXPERTISE ON THE JOB THROUGH A
MINIMUM OF TWO ELECTED TERMS IN
OFFICE. WHILE ALSO ALLOWING
THEM ADEQUATE COMPENSATION SO
WE HAVE QUALIFIED CANDIDATES
THAT AREN'T JUST INDEPENDENTLY
WEALTHY BEFORE THEY THEY SERVE.
NOW I'M JOINED TODAY BY A JEAN
HURST ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA. AS WELL
AS C. SACK TODAY AND ALSO-
TERRY BRENNAN ON BEHALF OF SEIU.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WELL
HAVING WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NOW WE HAVE ONE HERE IN THE
GALLERY. THE JUDGE GOING OUT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TERRY MORAN
AND ON BEHALF OF S. YEAH
CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE A LONG
HISTORY WITH TERM LIMITS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND- WE HAVE A
VERY- RELATIONSHIP I'VE BEEN
FOR AND AGAINST IT BUT IN NO
INSTANCE HAVE WE EVER SUPPORTED
ANY EFFORTS. TO LIMIT IT TO ONE
TERM- THAT PART OF WHAT IS
GOING ON INSURE FIT THERE'S
NEVER GOING TO BE THE LEVEL OF
ACTUAL EXPERTISE WE- APPRECIATE
WANT TO SEE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IN ADDITION B. COMPENSATION
LIMIT- PREVENT FOLKS FROM MY
UNION BY MEMBERSHIP- THE
WORKING CLASS FROM
PARTICIPATING IF THEY CAN'T
AFFORD TO WORK SOME OTHER JOB
AND HOBBYIST AS A LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND THOSE OF YOU COME
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT NOW VERY
WELL IT'S NOT A HOBBY PUBLIC
SERVICE IS A FULL TIME HARD
WORK A JOB FOR THAT REASON WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A COUPLE OTHER
SPONSORS JEAN WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT BLEACHING HER SINCE
GENE HEARST PLACE. I'M NOT A
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I. ANGIE AND HIRTH-
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA A
COALITION OF FOURTEEN OF THE
STATE'S MOST POPULOUS COUNTIES
I IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT I WOULD SEEK
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO A TERM
LIMIT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR A
MINIMUM OF TWO TERMS. OF THE
BILL ALSO CLARIFIED THAT BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR PRESCRIBING COMPENSATION
FOR ALL COUNTY OFFICERS
INCLUDING THE BOARD THEMSELVES-
WELL THEY COUNTY SAN BERNARDINO
WAS FACED WITH SOME IMPACT OF
ITS RECENTLY APPROVED MEASURE
K. THAT MEASURE IS PROSPECTIVE
EVAN STATEWIDE IN NATURE
IMPORTANTLY- YOU CAN IMAGINE
MANY OF OUR BOARD MEMBERS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE MILLER
FUTURE MEMBERS. MEASURES THAT
SEEK TO PROVIDE A SINGLE TERM
LIMIT AND DRAMATICALLY LIMIT
COMPENSATION AND WHAT THAT
MEANS FOR THE FUTURE COUNTY
GOVERNMENT IN CALIFORNIA IF YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA COUNTIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR A BROAD ARRAY
OF LOCAL SERVICES AS WELL AS
FEDERAL PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED
ON THE STATE'S BEHALF IN FACT
THE RECENT PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY MAY BE THE BEST
EVIDENCE OF THE COMPLEX SET OF
SERVICE OBLIGATIONS AND
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY IS
COUNTY FOR A MOMENT ON A DAILY
BASIS. A SINGLE TERM SIMPLY
DOES NOT ALLOW FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF EXPERTISE
NECESSARY TO EFFECTIVELY MANAGE
THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF A
CALIFORNIA COUNTY SUPERVISOR
ESTABLISHING A MINIMUM TWO TERM
LIMIT IS BOTH REASONABLE AND
PRACTICAL TO ENSURE THE COUNTY
TO PROVIDE YOUR COMMITTED
ACCOUNTABLE AND CAPABLE OF
GOVERNING IN THE MODERN DAY AND
UCC STRONGLY SUPPORTS THIS
MEASURE AND RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST YOUR AYE BUT TODAY.
THANK YOU. OPERATOR THE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WISH TO
SAY SUPPORT ON AB FOUR TO EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWO FIFTEEN
YEAR LINES OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS HOLD
LITTLE MAN ON BEHALF OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY AND THE PORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE OF TWO SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINES OPEN. NIELSEN JEFF
NEWCOME THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ALSO
IN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE
RIGHT THANK YOU- THREE HOW MANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
JENNIFER IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WELL
BOTTOM LINE OF ONE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS A SCOTT KAUFMAN FROM
THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION- TIMBER NEAR THE
MEASURE CAME INTO THE COUNTY
CHARTER TO BONE TERM LIMIT OF
ONE TERM REDUCE THE TOTAL
COMPENSATION PREACHER THE BOARD
SURVIVES FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
A MONTH. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THAT WHEN TERM LIMITS
ARE IMPOSED LIMITS BE NO FEWER
THAN TWO TERMS IT WOULD ALSO
SPECIFY THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. IS INCLUDED IN THE
DEFINITION COUNTY OFFICERS FROM
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
REGARDING PRESCRIBED
COMPENSATION IT SEEMS CLEAR TO
US THAT AB FOUR TO EIGHT IN
DIRECT RESPONSE AMBER IN THE US
MEASURE K. WE UNDERSTAND THAT
OTHER COUNTIES ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT PERSONAL SIMILAR
MEASURES. BUT THIS BILL COULD
ESTABLISH REASONABLE STANDARDS
FOR TERM LIMIT INITIATIVES AND
OTHER COUNTIES WITHOUT
TRAMPLING ON THE RIGHTS OF A
TWO THIRDS MAJORITY OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY VOTERS TO
APPROVE MEASURE K. WIN THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION ON THE
MEANING OF SECTION ONE
PARAGRAPH THE- PARAGRAPH B.
CONTAINS TWO SENTENCES THAT WE
BELIEVE HAVE SEPARATELY
OPERATIVE A FAX. THE FIRST
SENTENCE WE BELIEVE DOESN'T
FACT CREAMS LOCAL OTHER
INITIATIVES THAT REGULATE THE
TERMS THE NUMBER OF TERMS AND A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS CONSERVE.
THE SECOND SENTENCE NOT AT
ISSUE AS WE READ IT SIMPLY
MEANS THAT ANY LOCAL INITIATIVE
OR LAW WOULD ONLY HAVE A
PROSPECTIVE AFFECT AS TO THE
CURRENT CITY MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THAT'S
OUR PRIMARY DISPUTE IS WITH THE
FIRST SENTENCE WHICH WE
BELIEVE. TRANSLOCATIONS
INCLUDING MEASURE K. THE PEOPLE
HAVE SPOKEN AND I ASK THAT YOU
VOTE NO. ON AB FOUR TO EIGHT.
OUR THERE ANY OTHER UP BUT WE-
YOU AND BOOK ANY OTHER WITH.
NOT WHAT A LOT OF SIXTY FOUR
YOUR LINES OPEN. ONE SIXTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HE FROM THE
WEB BERMAN GROUP AND- I OPPOSE
AB FOUR TO EIGHT THE RED BERMAN
GOOD IS THE ORGANIZATION THAT
SPONSORED- THIS NATION BUILD.
BUT WAS APPROVED BY TWO THIRDS
OF THE VOTERS IN MY COUNTY.
YEAH I HAVEN'T WAYS TO GIVE
CONTROL BACK TO THE PEOPLE OF
THE COUNTY. AND WE FEEL THAT
THIS THAT AB TWO FOUR TWO EIGHT
DIRECTLY TARGETS THE VOTERS
WILL AND INTENT THEN WE WOULD
ASK THE COMMITTEE TO. OPPOSE
APPROVAL OF THIS- BILL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALMOST THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND- THANK YOU SOME AMERICA-
MAYES FOR A BRING IN THIS ISSUE
FORWARD. HOWEVER I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ON IT- YOU KNOW AS
YOU OPEN UP YOUR STATEMENT YOU
SAID THAT IT SIMPLE COUPLE
LINES SOMETIMES A COUPLE HINDS
COULD. LEAD TO A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS BUT YOU ALSO
SENSE THE DEMOCRATIC
INSTITUTIONS. ARE MOVING FOR
BUT ALSO- THERE'S THE
DEMOCRATIC RIGHTS OF THE VOTERS
RIGHTS OF THE PEOPLE TO BE
HEARD. BUT MY QUESTIONS- WILL
CENTER AROUND. THE BILL AND
SOME OF THE CLARIFYING AREAS
THAT I WANTED TO GET- CLARIFIED
SUCH AS- WHAT THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYER. BROUGHT UP IN THIS
SECTION BE- BUT IN THE LAST
PARAGRAPH YOU TALK ABOUT ANY
PROPOSAL TO LIMIT THE NUMBER OF
TERMS THE BOARD MEMBER
SUPERVISOR MAY SERVE. ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SHALL
APPLY APPLY PROSPECTIVELY.
MEETING IN THE FUTURE CORRECT.
ONLY AND SHALL NOT BECOME
OPERATIVE UNLESS IT IS
SUBMITTED TO THE ELECTORS OF
THE COUNTY AND A REGULAR
SCHEDULED ELECTION. AND
MAJORITY OF THE VOTES CAST. ON
THAT QUESTION- AND IT'S ADOPTED
A FAVORABLE AREA CAN YOU
ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THAT. DOES THAT MEAN THAT ANY
TERM LIMITS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ONE TERM LIMIT.
SPECIFICALLY IN SEMINOLE COUNTY
THAT THE CALLER'S BROUGHT UP-
BUT THIS BILL TALKS ABOUT GOING
BACK TO THE ELECTORS CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT OUR CAN YOU CLARIFY.
WHEN THAT PROCESS WILL ACTUALLY
GO BACK TO THE LECTORS. SURE
HI- AS YOU KNOW I MISS AROUND
WITH YOU AND I'VE HAVE- HAVE
KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR A LONG
TIME AND- YEAH WHEN I- YOU WERE
MY COUNTY SUPERVISOR- IN FACT
AND- WHEN I WAS THE CHIEF OF
STAFF FOR ANOTHER COUNTY
SUPERVISOR YOUR OFFICE WAS
RIGHT NEXT TO. WAS RIGHT NEXT
TO MINE- YOU ALSO KNOW THAT I
AM NOT AN ATTORNEY- AND WHAT
YOU WERE- REFERENCING WAS THE
SECOND PART OF THE LANGUAGE IS
ALREADY WHICH WAS. HAS ALREADY
A MATTER OF LAWYER TALK ABOUT
WAS PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW I
THINK THIS BILL WOULD CHANGE IS
THE LANGUAGE ARTS AS A PROPOSAL
TO LIMIT. TO NUKE NO FEWER
THAN- THEN THEN TO TERMS- AND
AS WE HAVE WE HAVE DISCUSSED-
MY CONCERN- IN REGARDS WHY I'M-
I'M CARRYING THIS BILL- IS
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IN FACT WHEN I WAS.
THINKING ABOUT COMING BEFORE
ALL OF YOU TODAY- I WAS
THINKING I THINK EVERY PERSON
THAT SERVED THAT SERVING ON
THIS- THIS COMMITTEE HAS
SERVED. IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND I AND I THINK- EITHER
COUNTY SUPERVISOR OR OR CITY
GOVERNMENT. WHEN I WAS FIRST
ELECTED WHEN I WAS TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OLD- BECAUSE I HAD A
DEGREE IN GOVERNMENT- I THOUGHT
I HAD ALL THE ANSWERS COULDN'T
WAIT TO GET. TO IT- TO SIT DOWN
AND BE ABLE TO. TAKE TO GET TO
WORK AND I REALIZED VERY
QUICKLY- THAT- I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I WAS TALKING ABOUT- I
WORKED INCREDIBLY HARD. AT IT
IN FACT I STILL REMEMBER GOING
THROUGH MY AGENDA PACKETS OVER
THE WEEKEND. AND READING EVERY
SINGLE WORD FROM THE BEGINNING.
TO THE END AND IT TOOK ME. A
GOOD THREE YEARS- WHILE I WAS
SERVING ON THAT COUNCIL TO
FIGURE OUT. WHAT I WAS DOING
WAS PROBABLY FIVE YEARS. I
BEFORE I REALLY UNDERSTOOD THAT
THE VOTE THAT I WAS TAKING. THE
IMPACT THAT THAT WOULD
ULTIMATELY THAT WOULD
ULTIMATELY HAVE. NOW I SERVED
IN THE COMMUNITY- THAT- HAD-
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
IT. A BUDGET OF TWELVE MILLION.
AND FIFTY EMPLOYEES AND IT TOOK
ME AT LEAST FIVE YEARS TO
REALLY. TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
IT. MY TO COUNTIES THAT I
REPRESENT A BOTH HAVE NORTH OF
TWO MILLION EOPLE COMBINED.
THEREFORE THERE ARE FOUR
MILLION TWO DIFFERENT BOARDS.
IN SAMBAR DINO COUNTY AS AN
EXAMPLE THERE OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES AND THEY
HAVE BUDGETS IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BOTH OF MY- MY COUNTY I
SERVED AS THE CHIEF OF STAFF
AND DOUG AND WORK FULL TIME.
AND I CAN TELL YOU FOR THE TIME
THAT I WAS THERE I STILL.
DIDN'T FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
CHIEF OF STAFF- FULL TIME
UNLIKE BEING A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER. ALL THE DIFFERENT
PARAMETERS OF COUNTY
GOVERNMENT. WHAT IS IT IS
AMAZING TO ME IS TO THINK THAT
WE HAVE A SYSTEM. IN WHICH THE
AVERAGE IF WE HAVE ONE TERM.
THE AVERAGE TIME FOR SET FOR A
FIVE MEMBER BOARD. WOULD B
EITHER ONE AND A HALF YEARS ONE
POINT SIX TO BE EXACT. OR TWO
POINT FOUR YEARS. OF TOTAL TIME
SERVING IN THAT CAPACITY. I
BELIEVE ELECTED REPRESENTS A
REAL ELECTIVE REPRESENTATION.
IN FACT I ALSO BELIEVE MY ALSO
BELIEVE IN TERM LIMITS. I THINK
TERM LIMITS IS APPROPRIATE. BUT
FOUR YEARS IS NOT ENOUGH TIME
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE. ENOUGH
UNDERSTANDING. TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE A DECISION SO WHAT THIS.
MEASURE BEFORE YET DOES. IT
SAYS. THAT COUNTY SUPERVISORS.
WE TALKED ABOUT ALL THE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT THEY DO.
THEY CAN SERVE FOR THERE CAN
STILL BE LOCAL NEST OF A LOCAL
MEASURE TO LIMITED. BUT THEY
CAN SERVE FOR AT LEAST. TWO
TERMS THE TOTAL OF EIGHT YEARS.
VERY VERY SIMPLE THANK YOU
MEMBER SIDE OF THE TECHNICAL.
WAS WITH THE GO BACK TO THE
LECTORS AS- IT'S ALLUDED TO IN
SECTION B. OF YOUR BILL. AND
I'M TAKING THAT THE ANSWERS NOW-
THE LANGUAGE HERE- IN MY BILL-
IS VERY CLEAR I THINK- IF I CAN
MISTER RAMOS YOU'RE
SPECIFICALLY TALKING ABOUT
SAMBAR DINO COUNTY NON SPEAKING
TO YOUR BILL- MR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MR MAYS AND SECTION
AGAIN B. THE SECOND PART OF IT
SAYS ANY PROPOSAL TO LIMIT THE
NUMBER OF TERMS OF A MEMBER OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS MAY
SERVE- ON THE BOARD- ONLY AND
SHALL NOT BECOME OPERATIVE
UNLESS IT IS SUBMITTED TO THE
ELECTORS. OF THE COUNTY AT A
REGULAR SCHEDULED ELECTION IN
THE MAJORITY OF THE VOTES CAST
ON THE QUESTION FAVOR THE
ADOPTION OF THE PROPOSAL SO MY
QUESTION- MISTER MASON- AND YOU
DID ALLUDE THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
NOT AN ATTORNEY BUT- I'M NOT
EITHER AND I'M READING YOUR
BILL. INTO ME I'M READING THAT
THAT WOULD GO BACK TO THE
ELECTORS OR OR NO THAT'S THAT'S
THE QUESTION. IN A SPECIFIC TO
YOUR BILL. FOR THE DAY EIGHT I
THINK WHAT WE'RE WHAT YOU'RE
REFERENCING IS THE LANGUAGE
THAT IS ALREADY A MATTER OF. OF
LAW MY BILL ONLY DEALS WITH A
LINE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE WHERE
IT SAYS TO NO FEWER. THAN TWO
TERMS. THE WHOLE SECTION OF BE
APPLIES IN THE FILES TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED YEAH WELL I'M
TALKING TO SO I WOULD. TAKE IT
I WOULD I DID NOT CORRECT THAT
WOULD BE I'D BE HAPPY I'M NOT
ABLE TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION OF
SOMEBODY FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MADAM CHAIR COULD COULD ASSIST
WITH THAT THAT MIGHT HAVE- A
MORE EXPERTISE THERE. YEAH I'LL
BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO COST
SAVING GET THAT CLARIFIED I
DON'T HAVE IN FRONT OF ME. THEY
FIND OUT. MANAGER WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO GO ON TO MY NEXT
QUESTION IS WEEK FROM CLOSURE
YOU'RE MORE THAN HALF OR WOULD
YOU RATHER HOLD NOT DISCARDED
THAT'S BECAUSE WE NEED TO KEEP
MOVING THANK YOU- FOR THAT- AND
AS WE GET THAT CLARIFIED. THAT
IT WOULD GO BACK TO THAT- A
LECTOR SOME HOPING THAT THAT'S
THE CLARIFYING POINT. THE NEXT
PART OF YOUR BILL TALKS ABOUT-
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
PRESCRIBE THE COMPENSATION. OF
COUNTY- WHAT IT WAS ORIGINALLY
OFFICERS WHICH MEANS IN THE
COUNTIES- THE ASSESSOR THE
SHERIFF IN THOSE DIFFERENT
ELECTIVES THERE. THAT THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS ON THE G. SO
ELOQUENTLY TALKED ABOUT THAT I
SAT ON IN EUROPE. CHIEF OF
STAFF- AND IT TOOK YOU SO MANY
YEARS TO FIGURE OUT HOW THAT.
WORKS RIGHT BUT WE DID HAVE
STAFF IN THE ORGANIZATION THAT
NEW. RIGHT BUT IT TALKS ABOUT
NOW WITH YOUR BILL. INCLUDING
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
BRINGING THAT INTO- THE FAULT
AS SETTING. THEIR SALARY AND NO
WERE MENTIONING IN THIS SECTION
OF TWENTY FIVE THREE HUNDRED.
DOES IT TALK ABOUT GOING TO THE
ELECTORS. AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS THAT CORRECT-
THAT. PORTION IS CLARIFYING OF.
OF EXISTING LONG WHEN USED SO
THAT'S THE COMMA SO ITS
OFFICERS COM INCLUDING THE
BOARD. OF SUPERVISORS- OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS UNLESS THERE'S
A LOCAL- LOCAL INITIATIVES
MMHM- THAT THAT- IS DIFFERENT
FROM THIS THEN THE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS. ARE ALREADY-
HAS THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH- THERE BUT THERE
COMPENSATION- AND- AND I'VE GOT
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
LANGUAGE THERE AS WELL MR
ALMOST AS WELL AS A SECTION B.
THAT I BROUGHT UP. THEY HAVE
SOME CONCERNS THERE ALSO. WELL
I MEAN DOES WELL I'LL BE HAPPY
TO BE ABLE TO DIG INTO THAT
SECOND PART BECAUSE I HAVEN'T
GIVEN A GIVEN THAT- THAT PART
BY MUCH MUCH THOUGHT I WISH
THAT WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT THIS.
THE OTHER DAY INTERVIEW IT
BROUGHT THAT THAT TO MY
ATTENTION SHORT SO I COULD HAVE
HAD ANSWERS FOR YOU. WELL TODAY
BUT ON THE ON THE LEFT. ON ON
THE LAST- A PART THAT IS JUST
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE. THANK YOU
AND- WE DID TALK A LOT ABOUT
THIS BILL WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE LOCAL I SAID. THAT MY
QUESTIONS HERE WOULD. CENTER
AROUND YOUR BILL IN THE STATE
WIDE. IMPACT WE HAD
CONVERSATIONS OF DIRECT-
MICROPROSE TWO SEMINAL COUNTY
ITSELF AND WE AGREED THAT. THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING IS THERE BUT
I'M NOT SURE WE COULD- TOTALLY
DIGRESS FROM TALKING ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
SALARY INPUT TO IT. BECAUSE
WHEN WE LOOK AT THROUGHOUT THE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. ARE MANY HAVE AROUND
LOCAL INITIATIVES. AND YOURSELF
KNOWING- IN SAN MARINO COUNTY
THAT. THE DISK OF SALARIES HAS
ONE THAT HAS BEEN A HEATED
DEBATE NOT JUST IN TWENTY
TWENTY BUT IT GOES FARTHER BACK
INTO WHERE I CAN REMEMBER TWO
THOUSAND FIVE. AND THEN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THERE WAS
COMPETING MEASURES THAT TOOK
PLACE THAT ULTIMATELY THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS INITIATIVE ONE
THAT. ONE THAT WITH A CLOSER-
CLOSER PERCENTAGE THAN THIS
LAST ONE. IN A TWENTY TWENTY
CAME THE COMPETING MEASURES
THAT SET THIS FORWARD. SO IT
SHOWS A PATTERN OF THE PEOPLE
YOU STARTED OFF WITH YOUR WITH
YOUR- TOPIC IN YOUR TESTIMONY.
THAT IS A DEMOCRATIC.
INSTITUTIONAL RIGHT BUT I.
COUNTER AND SAY THAT IT'S ALSO
A DEMOCRATIC RIGHT FOR THE
VOTERS OF THE PEOPLE TO DECIDE.
THINGS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE SEE HERE THAT
A PATTERN HAS BEEN SET. A
PATTERN HAS BEEN SET YEAH AND
THE LARGEST COUNTY IN THE STATE
OF SETTING SALARIES SO WHY. AND
I'M STILL WAITING FOR
CLARIFICATION ON B. AND I'M
HOPING THAT THAT WOULD GO BACK
TO THE ELECTORATE BECAUSE THAT
HELPS SOME. BUT ON SECTION
TWENTY FIVE THREE HUNDRED
THERE'S NO MENTION OF IT WHEN
WE KNOW THAT THAT'S AN ISSUE
THAT THE LOCAL LOCAL CONTROL AT
ITS FINEST. IS THE DEFINITION
OF SENDING THAT SALARY WHICH
THE TAXPAYERS OF ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES PAY INTO THAT
GENERAL FUND TO PAY THE
SALARIES OF THOSE SUPERVISORS
AND I'M SAYING THAT THERE
SHOULD BE A VOICE. A COMPONENT
FOR THEM TO BE HEARD SUCH AS
THE PATTERN THAT WAS SET IN
SAMBAR. THIS LOCAL CONTROL
ISSUE FOR ME TO MAKE SURE THAT
VOICE IS BEING HEARD- AGREE
WITH YOU MISTER ALMOST IN FACT
AS WE AS WE MOVE FORWARD ON
THIS- AS YOU KNOW THERE HAD
BEEN SOME ISSUES IN THE PAST-
IN REGARDS TO YOU- SOME OF THE
LOCAL COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO- DECIDED- THAT
THEY WOULD- REYES THE EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION- IN TERMS OF
HEALTH BENEFITS AND OTHER
THINGS TO TRY TO PAD- THERE.
OTHER SALARIES- I DO THINK THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME LIMITS
TO WHAT- COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS CAN DECIDE THAT
THEIR OWN PAY- SHOULD BE AND SO
YOU AND I ARE IN AGREEMENT WITH
THAT- ON THAT THAT THAT MAY BE
AS WE AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD WE CAN- WE CAN WORK ON
THAT- YOU KNOW TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ARE SOME SOME LIMITS
SO THERE ARE BAD ACTORS- THE
DATE THAT WE'VE GOT SOME
CONTROLS THAT ARE THERE. YEAH
THANK YOU FOR THAT. ALSO MEMBER-
BUT WE KNOW THAT- THAT THIS
CHECK A BALANCE OF THE LOCAL
GUY IS THE VOTE THE P. MUCH SO
THAT TERM LIMITS HE HERE IN THE
STATE LET. WAS OUT WITHIN A-
START IN THIS BY IN THE- THAT
WE TO THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE TO
VOTE ON TERM LIMITS AS EARLY AS
TWO NINE. AND THEN LATER ON-
STARTED AND WENT BACK AGAIN TO
THE ACA PROCESS HERE TO GO BACK
TO THE PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE THAT VOTE ON
TERM LIMITS THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY ARE UNDER NOW WITH
THE TWELVE YEAR CYCLE. SO THE
POINT IS IT'S NOT ABOUT. IN MY
ARGUMENT IS NOT JUST ABOUT
SAMBAR DINO COUNTY MY ARGUMENT
IS ABOUT THE VOICE OF THE
PEOPLE AND GETTING THEM
INGRAINED SO THAT THEY COULD
BETTER- TRUST THE GOVERNMENT
THAT SERVES THEM WHEN WE START
TO SET OUR OWN SALARIES WHEN WE
START TO SET. AREAS BECAUSE
CERTAIN ELECTIONS DIDN'T GO ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER WHEN THERE'S A
PATTERN AND WE COME STRAIGHT TO
THE STATE THERE'S A PROBLEM ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT RIGHT WE SAT
IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD WE
BLAMED. THE COUNTY FOR A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT WERE AFFECTING US
ON THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE BLAME THE STATE
FOR A LOT OF THINGS THAT ARE
THAT ARE HAPPENING HERE AT THE
STATE LEVEL WERE WAITING FOR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
REIMBURSE US ON CERTAIN THINGS.
THIS IS A PROCESS THAT NEEDS TO
GO BACK TO THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL CITY
COUNCILS HAVE ORDINANCES
INVOLVES TO SET UP THE SALARY
FOR MAYOR CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS.
AND I BELIEVE THIS SHOULD BE
THE SAME IN THIS SITUATION AND
WE'RE WAITING FOR CLARITY ON
THAT SECTION B. AND THE
QUESTION IS WHAT THAT GO BACK
TO THE ELECTORATE FOR A VOTE
BECAUSE WE'RE CLEAR. RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES THAT.
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY THREE
HUNDRED DOES NOT EVEN. MENTION
GOING BACK. TO THE ELECTORATES.
I'M SO. WHAT'S WE DO REFERRING
TO THEIR MANAGER CAN WE GET
CLEAR IS WE HAVE CLARIFICATION
ON SO BE I HAVE. THE MIKE COME
SINCE THAT. SO ONE I CAN RIGHT
NOW IS THAT WE ARE LOW GO. SO
TALKING LOCAL. IF THIS SORT OF.
IN ELECTIONS THEY ARE STUDENTS
ON THE ELECT PROCESS WE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER THAT BUT LET'S
SEE WHERE MISS ROSS IS WITH
THIS. AS OF RIGHT NOW LOOKING.
THAT'S A LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS
ONE BECAUSE ON. IF THIS GIFT TO
GO TO A LOT. AND THEN THE WHERE.
THE NITTY GRITTY IN THE LAW FOR
LIKE MAY BE THE PLACE TO
ADDRESS PORSCHE OF IT I
UNDERSTAND MISTER. RAMOS YOUR
CAN FROM- SOME MATTER CHAIR-
WHAT WERE THE QUESTIONS THAT WE
REYES I THINK THIS WAS A TO THE
BELL- THE WILL THE PEOPLE WE
SINCE. OPPOSITE BLATTER'S COME
THROUGH- THAT ON THE HOWARD-
JARVIS TAXPAYER A SENSE OF NO
WORSE THE STRIP VOTER OF THE-
TO. THEIR PER LINE OF TERM AND
SET HEY OF COUNTY SUPER.
BECAUSE WE THE OUTCOME. OF AN
ELECTION. THIS IS A- A CHILD
FOR ME BECAUSE- IN THE FORM
LOCAL. THE VOICE OF THE P. WHAT
MOVE FOR THEY- US TO THE OFFICE
WERE IN. I WOULD. THESE THESE
THESE ARE TROUBLESOME FOR ME-
TO EVEN VOTE ON TODAY. AND SO
WITHOUT CLARIFYING SOME OF
THESE SIMPLE QUESTIONS ARE TWO
LINER THAT YOU SAID WAS JUST A
COUPLE SECONDS SEE A COUPLE
SENTENCES COULD LEAD TO A LOT
MORE DISCUSSION. THAT I WOULD-
RESPECTFULLY THE VOTING NO ON
THIS BILL. WELL LET'S THANK YOU
AS FROM A SE- AND I- YOU YOU
GOT ALL TO THIS- THIS JOB JUST
LIKE I GOT A- THIS JOB IN. I
DON'T ACTUALLY- VERY MUCH OF.
WHEN THERE IS DISSENT BECAUSE I
THINK THAT ACTUALLY THAT
DISSENT- MAKES OUR OUR
LEGISLATION. A BETTER TOO MANY
TIMES IN FACT THAT WE RUN BILLS
THROUGH COMMITTEE WE DON'T PAY
MUCH ATTENTION SO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- FOR YOUR HARD
WORK AND REALLY DIGGING INTO
THIS AND- SO I WASN'T BE ABLE
TO ABLE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
THOSE ANSWERS- FOR YOU ON-
WHAT'S A MATTER OF EXISTING
EXISTING LAWN AS THIS MOVE PARK
FOR THIS BILL PROGRESSES-
HOPEFULLY- THROUGH THE NEXT
COMMITTEE MAYBE WE CAN WORK
WITH THE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE.
TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER SOME OF
THOSE QUESTIONS. THANK FOR. THE
FROM. BACK HERE A CRUSH. YEAH I
JUST AFTER THAT- THANK OF. I
JUST TO GIVE YOU A CHECK TO THE
CONCERN. THE ARRAY ABOUT PROPER.
THE PROPOSAL MEASURE K. I'M
SURE YOU HAVE A REASONABLE
EXPLANATION I WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR IT YEAH NO I MEAN I THINK
THAT THE VOTE THE VOTERS HAVE
SPOKEN IN FACT I WAS WATCHING A
LITTLE BIT- IN REGARDS TO ONE
OF THE BILLS- BEFORE YOU KNOW
TALKING ABOUT LOCAL MEASURES
AND AS I WAS LIKE CALL LOOKS
LIKE WE'RE GONNA HAVE A COUPLE
THESE CONVERSATIONS- HERE HERE
HERE TODAY. OF THE BILL BEFORE
YOU ON THAT THAT IS CONCERNED
WITH THE FUTURE- AT THE
PROSPECTIVE LEE- IF YOU WERE TO
ASK ME WHETHER IT'S A GOOD
IDEA- THAT WE HAVE- A FIVE
MEMBER BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I
THAT WILL HAVE AN AVERAGE OF
ONE AND A HALF TO TWO AND A
HALF YEARS CEMEX MATTOON I HAVE
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE AND THEN
THEY'RE GONE. IF THAT'S GOOD
FOR GOVERNMENT FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I WOULD SUGGEST T
YOU- THAT- I DON'T- AND- AND DO
I THINK AS A MATTER OF POLICY
HERE FOR THE STATE I SHOULD BE
PUT IN SOME PARAMETERS- TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THAT PEOPLE'S VOICES
CAN BE HEARD THROUGH THE LOCAL
INITIATIVE A PROCESS
ABSOLUTELY- THIS. BILL BEFORE
YOU SAYS- THAT- THAT
PROSPECTIVELY THAT OUT IF
THERE'S THESE MEASURES THAT
COME UP LOCAL MEASURES THAT
COME UP- THAT THEY WILL- THEY
CAN LIMIT THE TERMS OF COUNTY
SUPERVISORS BUT FOR NO LESS
THAN- THAN THAN TWO TERMS AND I
THINK THAT MAKES AN AWFUL LOT
OF SENSE SO- YOU KNOW IF WE
NEED SOME CLARIFYING LANGUAGE
OF WE NEED TO GET SOME
ATTORNEYS AND LAWYERS TO GET IN
TO TALK ABOUT THE NITTY GRITTY.
I'D LOVE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
AND AS IF YOU CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS MR MR LACKEY OR SOME
SOME QUESTIONS NEED I'D LOVE TO
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH YOU AND
ANY LEGAL COUNSEL TO TRY TO GET
THAT THIS IS THE FIRST HEARING
ON THIS ON THIS BILL- THIS IS
MY SEVENTH YEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE I KNOW THAT WHEN
THERE'S LEGISLATION THAT COMES
BEFORE. IT'S USUALLY THE FIRST
HEARING- WE WILL TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE IT TO THE- TO. THAT
APPOINTMENT MAY IT BETTER SO-
THANK YOU. BLOW THANK YOU MADAM
TO. OF MINORS IS THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT TURN OVER THE RESULTS
OF AN ELECTION THAT HAS COME
BEFORE- THAT IS ONLY
PERSPECTIVE GOING FORWARD.
THERE WAS HOWEVER AN ELECTION.
A REFERENDUM THAT- I CREATED A
SCENARIO WHERE I IN- ONE
COUNTY. THERE WOULD BE A
RESTRICTION TO ONE TERM YOU
COULD ONLY BE IN OFFICE FOR
FOUR YEARS IS THAT CORRECT
THAT'S CORRECT. AND IT IS. UGH
MISTER MAYES POSITION ONE THAT
I SHARE THAT FOR YEARS IS TOO
SHORT A PERIOD OF TIME- AND IT
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT SOMEBODY
CAN'T BE VOTED OUT OF OFFICE
BUT AFTER DOING A BAD JOB BYE
BYE BY THE PEOPLE THAT COULD
CERTAINLY HAPPEN BUT GENERALLY
SPEAKING FOR YEARS IT HAS- A
SUB OPTIMAL TIME- TO BE AN
OFFICE AND GET A JOB DONE- AND
THAT'S SOMETHING. THAT I AGREE
WITH- SO IF I UNDERSTAND THE
BILL CORRECTLY. ANY ELECTION IN
A COUNTY- THAT SEEKS TO SET
TERM LIMITS COULD DO SO FREELY
EXCEPT THAT THE MINIMUM AMOUNT
OF TIME- ONE COULD SERVE WOULD
BE TWO FOUR YEAR TERMS AT THE
FACT THAT RIGHT THAT'S CORRECT
I THINK THAT'S EMINENTLY
REASONABLE- AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT ALL SUPPORT AND I'M HAPPY
TO MAKE THE MOST. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YES TO THAT
QUESTION THAT SOME OF OUR
BLUMA- ASKED REALLY. CLARIFY
SOME OF MY- QUESTIONS AND
CONCERNS I BUT- SO THE BILL NOW.
STATES THAT THERE WAS A BALLOT-
WHICH PASSED AS WELL. AND WHICH
IS MY UNDERSTANDING IS A
CONFIRMED- THAT THESE TERMS
WOULD BE LIMITED TO THREE
CORRECT AND THAT IT'S IN A
SUPERVISOR PAY WAS TIED AT I
BELIEVE 80% TO THE ANNUAL. BASE
SALARY OF JUDGES IN THE
SUPERIOR COURT AND SO WITH BOTH
AND SO HELP ME UNDERSTAND- IF
YOU CAN. WITH BOTH OF THEM
PASSING BECAUSE MEASURE K.
RECEIVED A HIGHER THRESHOLD- IS
SO YOU KNOW I'M I'M JUST- IF
YOU COULD HELP. ME UNDERSTAND
BECAUSE BOTH OF THE PAST WHAT
IS THE YOU KNOW THE- STATUS OF
EACH. NO I THINK IT'S BEEN VERY
CLEAR THAT THE ONE I THINK THE
LAW IS CLEAR AGAIN I'M NOT NOT
AN ATTORNEY BUT THE ONE THAT
GETS THE MOST VOTES WITH THOSE
COMPETING- MEASURES OF WINDS-
WHICH IS I THINK WE WOULD ALL
AGREE THAT THAT IS- THAT THAT
IS THE RIGHT THING. I WANT TO
MAKE SURE TO BE TO BE CLEARED
FACT EVEN YEAH AND THE
ANALYSIS- ACTS I'M ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE VERY TRANSPARENT AS
WELL- WOULD I HAVE BROUGHT THIS
BILL BEFORE- HAD ASSEMBLY NO
COUNTY- AND NOT HAD TO THE
ISSUE I PROBABLY WOULDN'T HAVE
BECAUSE I WOULD HAVE THOUGHT
ABOUT IT- SO IS THIS BILL. A
REACTION TO. THE COUNTY IT IS-
BUT IF THIS ISN'T THIS BILL
BEFORE YOU ISN'T ABOUT-ONE
COUNTY AT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES- AND I
AM THINKING ABOUT THE FUTURE
WHEN WE ESTABLISH- WHEN THE
STATE ESTABLISHES GUIDELINES TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE- FIVE
MEMBER BOARDS- WHAT WOULD BE
THE PARAMETERS. FOR ALL OF THAT
AS YOU SERVED- IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY- SOME OF THEM ARE
RIVAS YOU SURGEON AT EIGHT AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL- AND FOR ME- I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
CLEAR THAT PROSPECTIVELY GOING
FORWARD. THIS IS ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT IF THERE WAS A LOCAL
A MEASURE- THAT THAT LOCAL
MEASURE STILL CAN ESTABLISH
TERM LIMITS BUT IT WOULD BE
LIMITED TO TWO FOUR YEAR TERMS
FOR A MAXIMUM OF EIGHT- INSTEAD
OF- INSTEAD OF ANYTHING LESS
THAN NOT. GONNA CUT IT KNOW
WHY- APPRECIATE THAT WAS YES I
DID SIR AT THE LOCAL- AS AS WAS
MENTIONED YOU KNOW THESE LOCAL
JOBS ARE CERTAINLY FULL TIME I
WAS PAID PART TIME THAT'S WHY I
HAD OTHER JOBS OR TO OTHER JOBS.
WAS BUT IS VERY CHALLENGING YOU
KNOW BUT CERTAINLY- YOU KNOW
KNOWING WHAT THE CONVERSATION
WAS I KNEW WHAT I WAS GET
MYSELF INTO IS EXCITED TO BE
ELECTED AND THEN NIGHT OF MY
LIFE MY WIFE LOOKED AT ME SAID
WHEN I GOT TO GO GO GET ANOTHER
JOB SO THAT'S WHAT I DID. BUT
NO- APPRECIATE THIS COME. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER COM. MISTER MS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BUT WE
HAVEN'T RIGHT WE HAVE. CAN'T
CAN MEET AN AWFUL LOT- I DO
THINK- THAT- AND WHEN IT
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH- THE
CHAIR- AND OTHER COMMITTEE AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AS WE
WORK THROUGH- THROUGH THIS
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE TO BE
ABLE. TO GET IT RIGHT- BUT- I
DO- BELIEVE WHOLEHEARTEDLY-
THAT FOR THE SAKE OF GOOD
GOVERNMENT I'M OUT ARE COUNTY
LEVEL THAT THIS BILL THIS BILL
IS NECESSARY- AND SO- WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
IS BEEN A YOU KNOW DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION- BETTER BROUGHT A
LOT TO THE- TO THE SURFACE THAT
WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT. WHERE
YOU ARE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE AND WHAT'S IMPORTANT
TO ME. IS THAT PEOPLE HAVE TIME
TO BE ON THE BOARD. AND I CAN.
I CAN TOTALLY UNDERSTAND I WAS
ON THE CITY COUNCIL I WAS LOST
FOR TWO OR THREE YEARS. I CAME
EVEN HERE LOS FOR COUPLE YEARS
SO. I THINK WE DO NEED MORE
TIME AND I THINK THAT PORTION
OF YOUR BILLS FAIR ENOUGH. AND
I THINK THAT PORTION FITS. BOTH
FEEL THE RIGHT BALANCE OF FOR
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. IN
OUR VOTERS BUT I WILL SAY I
WILL- SUPPORT THIS TODAY
BECAUSE I WANTED TO MOVE ON AND
THE REASON BEING IS THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF QUESTIONS
LEFT. A PARTICULARLY THAT WE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT I'M FROM I
DON'T THINK ARE SUITED TO
ANSWER SOME OF THOSE ELECTIONS
QUESTIONS. AND I SUPPORT-
MISTER PROMISES. CONCERNS BUT I
WILL SUPPORT THIS TODAY SO WE
CAN GET MOVED ON. 
YOU HAVE A- THOROUGH
CONVERSATION WITH ELECT
COMMITTEE AS WELL HAPPY SO
THANK YOU. OKAY THE MOST TO DO.
ELECTIONS COME SECOND PLEASE
THE ROLL AND YOUR CURLY HI.
AGUIAR-CURRY I. I'VE LACKEY.
BLUE BLOOM I. BOERNER HORVATH.
RAMOS WELL MOST. TO ROBERT
RIVER. ROBERT WILL PASS. MADAM
MADAM CHAIR- THIS ONE I HOPE-
IS- IS A LITTLE LIGHTER-
ALTHOUGH I'M FACT I'VE GOT A
WHOLE SCRIPT HERE AND I'M JUST
NOT GONNA DO THE SCRIPT- I LOOK
FORWARD TO SOME CONVERSATION
HERE AS YOU REMEMBER- MADAM
CHAIR- IT A BILL THAT WAS
SIMILAR TO THIS CAME BEFORE-
THIS COMMITTEE- TWO YEARS AGO-
BECAUSE- I HAD BEEN DEEPLY
CONCERNED THAT ALMOST 60% OF
THE PEOPLE OF THE RATE PAYERS.
WITHIN IDEOLOGICAL SERVICE
TERRITORY OF IMPUTATION
DISTRICT WERE DISENFRANCHISED-
AND DID NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO- TO VOTE AND SO WE
HAD A BILL- TWO YEARS AGO OF
THAT WOULD HAVE OF- THAT WOULD
HAVE MADE THE BOARD OF THE
IMPUTATION DISTRICTS- ELEVEN
MEMBERS- AND SIX OF THEM WOULD
HAVE BEEN IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
TO PROVIDE THAT BALANCE BETWEEN
THE TWO- THE AS YOU REMEMBER A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO- IT WAS A
PRETTY CONTENTIOUS- AND THE
REASON. FOR THAT- WAS- THE
FOLKS AT THE IMPALER GEISHA
DISTRICT HAD SOME VERY REAL
CONCERNS ABOUT- ABOUT THE BILL-
IN SPECIFIC THEY WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR WATER
RIGHTS AND THE IMPACT OF HAVING
MORE THAN- YOU KNOW THE
MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE ON THEIR
BOARD COMING FROM RIVERSIDE
COUNTY THAT THAT COULD THREATEN
THEIR FUTURE WATER RIGHTS AND
WE HEARD THEM TRIED TO WORK ON
THAT WORK THROUGH THROUGH THAT-
THIS BILL BEFORE YOU- IS
ACTUALLY A WATERED DOWN
VERSION- OF WHAT WE HAD BEFORE-
THIS STILL PROVIDE SOME LEVEL
OF REPRESENTATION- IT WOULD
INSTEAD OF. HAVING SIX MEMBERS
I THAT WOULD BE ELECTED TO THE
BOARD- IT WOULD PROVIDE FOR ONE
PERSON- FROM THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY- AREA OF THE ELECTRICAL
SERVICE TERRITORY TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE- AS AN EX OFFICIO MEMBER
OR NOT VOTE A NON VOTING MEMBER
OF THAT BOARD AND THEN IT
WOULD- WOULD HAVE AT THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY LASKO AND THEN
IMPERIAL COUNTY LASKO. I DO A
STUDY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BEST
COME UP WITH. ARIGHT THE LEVEL
OF REPRESENTATION- AND- AND
MADAM CHAIR I ALSO IN HERE TO
REPORT TO YOU- THAT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN- I MY
OFFICE- AND IMPALER GEISHA
DISTRICTS IS MUCH BETTER TODAY-
THAN IT WAS I JUST A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO I THINK WE STILL
DISAGREE. ON ON THIS POLICY BUT
WE DO HAVE- LINES OF
COMMUNICATION THAT ARE OPEN-
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTATIVES ARE
VERY ENGAGED IN THIS ISSUE- AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THEM AS WE MOVE. THROUGH
THROUGH THE PROCESS. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- LET'S MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ARE
THERE ANY IN THE GALLERY SEE
NONE- OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WEAKNESSES IN SUPPORT. YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN TWENTY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GET THEIR
LINE NUMBER. AGAIN I KNOW THIS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND IT WILL
GO TO A LINE OF. TWO SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
HELLO MADAM CHAIR THIS IS SCOTT
WEDGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS IN IN STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. WE
REPRESENT THE NINETY W.
REPRESENTS A MAJORITY OF THE
EMPLOYEES THAT ID. BUT WE ALSO
HAVE THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS. WHO
ARE UTILITY RATEPAYERS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. AND WE FEEL
VERY STRONGLY THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE REPRESENTATION ON THE ID
FOR. A VOICE FOR THOSE 60% OF
THEIR ELECTRICITY ELECTRICITY
RATEPAYERS NEED TO HAVE
REPRESENTATION THIS IS A
TENDENCY TAXATION WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION. WE HAVE HEARD
AS THE WORK FORCE AND ID WE
HAVE BECOME FAMILIAR WITH MANY
MANY MANY- CUSTOMER AND
CONSUMER REPAIR COMPLAINTS WERE
FOLKS DON'T FEEL THEY HAVE AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL THAT THEY CAN
TURN TO FROM THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE COULDN'T URGE THE
COMMITTEE MORE. ADAMANTLY MOVE
THIS BILL LONG WE BELIEVE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES HAS DONE
AN ADMIRABLE JOB OF STRIKING A
VERY FAIR BALLOTS THEN WE'D
ORGANIZE THE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY I BELIEVE WE
HAVE SOME OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. I'M LOOKING FOR A HENRY
MARTINEZ AS WELL AS THE JULIA
HALL. THEIR LIVES ARE OPEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. PLEASE
BEGIN- OKAY THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON A MAN CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ANDREA
MARTINEZ AND I AM THE GENERAL
MANAGER FOR THE IMPERIAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND CALLING
THEM TO TESTIFY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB. TEN TWENTY
ONE. IN TWENTY NINETEEN S.
MEMBER. ENTERED SIMILAR
LEGISLATION. AND DURING THAT
BILL HIT A BILLS HEARING IT
MEDICAMENT MEANT TO THIS COMMIT
TO THIS COMMITTEE THAT IT WOULD
INITIATE A DIALOGUE WITH THE
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA.
AND ALSO LOOK AT YOUR VALLEY
STAKEHOLDERS TO RECEIVE MINIMAL
INPUT. ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS AND
DETERMINE THE FUTURE OF IDC
ENERGY SERVICE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
ALL RIGHTY HAS KEPT THIS
COMMITMENT AND BELIEVES FIRMLY
THAT THESE CONVERSATIONS SHOULD
CONTINUE WELL BUT AT A LOCAL
LEVEL. FISHER COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS RIGHTLY POINTS OUT
LIVE CLOSE PROVIDE A FORMAL OF
A PROCESS TO ADDRESS QUESTIONS
RELATED TO DISTRICT BOUNDARIES.
ANNEXATIONS OR EXTENSIONS OF
SERVICE OR RELEVANT TOPICS TO
BE CONSIDER WHEN LOOKING AT THE
ARRANGEMENT THAT EXISTS TODAY
BETWEEN IT AND THE COACHELLA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT. MORE
SPECIFICALLY. IT IS FULL
SERVICE REVIEWS WERE ADDED TO
LIVE CLOSE MANDATE IN THE
PASSAGE OF THE PARTY'S KNOCKS
HERTZBERG ACT INTO TWO
THOUSAND. TO BETTER INFORM
LOCAL AGENCIES AND THE
COMMUNITY ABOUT PROVISIONS OF
MUNICIPAL SERVICES. SERVICE
REVIEWS SHOULD WHAT CAPTURED
AND ANALYZED INFORMATION ABOUT
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES AND
EFFICIENCIES AND IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GREATER
COORDINATION AND COOPERATION
BETWEEN PROVIDERS. THAT BEING
THE CASE. THEN THIS LEGISLATION
IS NOT IS CLEARLY NOT NECESSARY.
AB TEN TWENTY ONE WOULD ADD
NONVOTING MEMBERS. WHO THE
ALREADY BORED WHO WILL SHARE
ALL THE RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF BOTH WATER
AND ENERGY MATTERS. IN ADDITION
TO BEING AUTHORIZED TO
PARTICIPATE IN CLOSED SESSION
DISCUSSIONS. THIS RACE IS A
VERY SERIOUS CONCERN TO THE
DISTRICT AND SAYS ABOUT
PRESIDENT. FURTHERMORE THIS
BILL POTENTIALLY CREATES
SERIOUS CONFLICTS BETWEEN THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO HAVE
SERVICE REGION FOR NEARLY
NINETY YEARS. AS A COMMITTEE MY
RECALL IN NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR.
IDEA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT'S
SETTLE DISPUTES BETWEEN OUR
AGENCIES OVER WATER AND ENERGY
RIGHTS THROUGH A NINETY NINE
YEAR COMPROMISED AGREEMENT.
PERHAPS THE MOST NOTABLE
BENEFIT OF THIS PART
PARTNERSHIP HAS SPENT A
CONTINUOUS DELIVERY A LITTLE
COST PUBLIC POWER TO THE
RESIDENTS OF THE COACHELLA
VALLEY. UNFORTUNATELY AB TEN
TWENTY ONE NOW ATTEMPTS TO
INJECT THE STATE LEGISLATURE
DIRECTLY BETWEEN THESE TWO
LOCAL AGENCIES. JUST TWELVE
YEARS BEFORE THE AGREEMENT
REACHES ITS FULL TERM AND
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE PEOPLE
THAT THE CHILL OF. AN IMPERIAL
VALLEY'S THROUGH THEIR LOCAL
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES
DESIGNATED. THIS CURRENT
ARRANGEMENT. NEARLY NINE
DECADES LATER THIS PARTNERSHIP
IS WORKING AS A SIGNATURE WILL
CONTINUE TO EVOLVE TO MEET THE
COMMUNITY COMMUNITIES NEEDS.
THE BILL ALSO THIS ALSO POSE A
LARGE COALITION INCLUDING WATER
AGENCIES SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
PUBLIC POWER GROUPS
REPRESENTING OUR CULTURE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LIKE IMPERIAL
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
IMPERIAL COUNTY LASKO IN
VARIOUS CITIES. ENGROSSING ARE
YOU BEING STRONGLY OPPOSES AB
TEN TWENTY ONE. BUT WE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MAYES AND GARCIA BUT SHALL
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT THANK
WHICH ABOUT A STAKEHOLDERS TO
CONTINUE MOVING THIS DIALOGUE
FORWARD AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF ALL
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
FURTHER AND OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ASSEMBLY RIB JULIA
HALL YET. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JULIA HALL THE DISSIPATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES AND
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THE BILL THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE LEGISLATURE
RATHER THAN THE LOCAL AGENCIES
SHOULD DECIDE HOW A LOCAL
AGENCY SHOULD BE RUN AND WHO
SHOULD BE MAKING DECISIONS ON
BEHALF OF RATE PAYERS HIM
NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR IMPERIAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND
NEIGHBORING COACHELLA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT HAVE AN
AGREEMENT A COMPROMISE UNDER
WHICH COACHELLA VALLEY
RELINQUISHED ITS RIGHT TO
ELECTRICITY TAX ID. AND RETURN
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
IS GRANTED JUNIOR WATER RIGHTS
FROM THE COLORADO RIVER AND. 8%
AS AN ENERGY PROCEEDS. THIS IS
A LONGSTANDING AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE TWO AGENTS AND
THEIR CONTENT. AND THEY
CONTINUE TO WORK ON BETTER AND
MORE FORMALIZED CROP
COOPERATION TODAY. THE BILL
WOULD ALLOW THREE NONVOTING
MEMBERS OUTSIDE ID TERRITORY
FIFTY ON THE BOARD. ALTHOUGH
THEY COULD NOT FORMALLY VOTE
THEY WOULD HAVE TO TWELVE A
FULL BOARD MEMBER AND BE PRETTY
CLOSE NEED DISCUSSION. IDEAS
THE IRRIGATION DISTRICT THE NEW
NONVOTING MEMBERS WHO PROPOSED
PURPOSES TO REPRESENT
ELECTRICAL CUSTOMERS WOULD BE
INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN
DISCUSSIONS RELATED TO WATER
RIGHTS AND WATER CONCERNS.
WHICH JEOPARDIZES THE
LONGSTANDING COOPERATION AND
POSITIVE WORKING RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THESE TWO REGIONS.
FURTHER EIGHTY TEN TWENTY ONE
CONSTITUTES A TRULY UNNECESSARY
INTERVENTION AND THE OPERATION
OF A LOCAL AGENCY. MOTHER TOLD
INCREASE OUR PRESENTATION OF
LAUDABLE ID ALREADY HAS HAS A
MECHANISM THROUGH WHICH
DIFFICULT TO CHEAT. IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR I IDEAS MAINTAINED
AND ENERGY CONSUMERS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WHOSE ROLE IT IS TO
PROVIDE ADVICE AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE FULL ID
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. THIS
COMMITTEE IS COMPRISED OF
TWENTY MEMBERS WHAT KIND OF
THOSE BEING FROM THE COACHELLA
VALLEY REGION. AND NOMINATED BY
THAT REGION. THE PEOPLE ABOUT
AND VALLEY. HERE THEY'RE LIKE
DIVERT. HAVE DESIGNED A
ARRANGEMENT WHICH CONTINUE TO
OF ALL TO ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS.
ADDRESSING ISSUES BY EIGHT TEN
FOR ONE ISN'T ABOUT INTEREST OF
BOTH AGENCIES AND THE PEOPLE
THEY REPRESENT. IT'S ALSO IN
THEIR BEST INTEREST FOR THE
CHALLENGES TO BE SOLVED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ARE NOT ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
BOB. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE NOT
THE VISION OF AB TEN TWENTY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINES OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ANTHONY CAN
HELP CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWO
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS PATRICK WELCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISPOSITION AND ALSO CALLING IN
ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
LOTS OF OTHER ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NINE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO DRIVE IN
MOTION. SO MOVE. MOTION FROM
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LUCKY IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BORA BORA-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD
I- THAT MADAM CHAIR I DID NOT
START OFF BY THANKING YOU AND
THE WORK THAT YOU ARE-
COMMITTEE HAS DONE- I ALSO I
DID NOT LET YOU KNOW THAT I
WOULD BE TAKING AND THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- AND I'LL
BE HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO- TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT SO THAT COULD
BE ADDED INTO TO THE MOTION
THAT WOULD BE. THAT BE
WONDERFUL- OF THE OPPOSITION-
IS RIGHT ALL THE THINGS THAT
THEY SAID WERE ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT AND I AM ALSO A BIG
BELIEVER IN THE IDEA OF LOCAL
GOVERNANCE- THAT THIS YEAR I
WISH THIS COULD BE SOLVED- ATTY
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND I WISH
THAT THE STATE WOULDN'T HAVE
TO. I TO GET INVOLVED IN THIS
AT THE CHALLENGES AS WE HAVE
OUR LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSION SO- THAT I SERVE-
COUNTY BY COUNTY- AND- AND WE
HAVE RIVERSIDE COUNTY THAT
WANTS ONE THING FACT THEY DID A
SERVICE REVIEW- BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN- THAT SAID. THAT
THERE SHOULD BE THE RIGHT FOR
THOSE FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO- TO
VOTE AND THEN OTHER THE
IMPERIAL COUNTY LASKO WHO'S
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED BECAUSE DOWN
IMPERIAL COUNTY THEY DON'T WANT
TO HAVE TO GIVE UP ANY ANY
POWER ANY POLITICAL POWER TO-
THAT THAT THEY COUNTY IN FROM
THE NORTH. AND SO THE GOAL IS
IN FACT I THINK THE TERM IS
BEEN UNTENABLE- WE ARE IN AN
UNTENABLE POSITION- BECAUSE- IN
PURELY IRRIGATION DISTRICT DOES
FANTASTIC WORK IN FACT THEY
KEEP THEIR RATES ARE VERY LOW-
NOT JUST THEIR THEIR LOGICAL
RATES BUT ALSO THEIR WATER
OTHER WATER RATES AND THEY THEY
DO AN INCREDIBLE JOB. OF A
FIGHTING EFFORT FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY AT WHAT WHITES
UNTENABLE IS THAT WE HAVE A 60%
NOT 6% BUT 60% OF THE FOLKS
THAT ARE IN THEIR LOGICAL- A
SERVICE TERRITORY THEY DO NOT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
CHOOSE WHO WILL SERVE THEM. ON
THEIR BOARD AND SO WE NEED TO
WORK ON THIS I DON'T THINK THE
BILL AS IT'S AS IT'S DRAFTED IS
PERFECT- WE DO NEED TO CONTINUE
TO KEEP WORKING THROUGH THE
PROCESS. BUT AGAIN- MADAM CHAIR
I WANT TO THANK YOU IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR WORK.
AND A LOOK FOR WORKING WITH
WITH ALL THE YOU. TO RESPECT
THEIR REQUEST AND I WILL. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND- I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU SPEND A
LONG TIME WITH THE COMMITTEE WE
WORKED ON THIS FOR THREE YEARS.
SLOWLY MAKING SOME HEADWAY- I
ALSO WANT TO. APPLAUD YOU FOR
GIVING SOME- THANK ACCOLADES
TO. THE DISTRICT. BUT THEY HAVE
IMPROVED AND THINGS HAVE BEEN
GOING THE RIGHT DIRECTION. AND
THIS IS A VERY LONG STANDING.
COMPLEX ISSUE FOR BOTH THE
IMPERIAL IRRIGATION DISTRICT IN
THOSE RESIDENTS IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. IN FACT THIS IS THE
THIRD BILL THAT WE'VE SEEN OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS-
CONSIDERING THAT THIS IS A
REPORT TO GET MORE INFORMATION-
GROUP. THAT A LONGER TERM
RESOLUTION LIKE THINGS TO BE
REACHED. I BELIEVE THE BILL
PROVIDES A REASONABLE STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION WITH THE
AMENDMENTS I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY. I WILL TELL
YOU I HAVE WORKED ON A VERY
SIMILAR TYPE. PROJECT BEFORE.
AND SOMETIMES WE JUST HAVE TO
FIGHT IT OUT AND GET DOWN AND
GET DIRTY TO GET. TO WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO BE AND THESE
PROJECTS WILL BE WONDERFUL IN
THE LONG RUN. BUT THE MEANTIME
IS REALLY UGLY GETTING THERE SO
I WANT TO. APPLAUD YOU FOR
TRYING TO PUSH THIS ALONG. I
WANT TO THE PUBLIC SECTOR TODAY
BY MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY HI.
AGUIAR-CURRY ALL BLACK. LACKEY
I BLOOM. HELLO I BURGER.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS. FROM I.
THREE OF US ROBERT.
ROBERT RIVAS AB. WE'LL TELL ALL
RIGHT YOU HAVE A SEVEN. SEVEN
ZERO FOUR FOR THOSE NUMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO MUCH.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CORK WHICH LIKE TO JOIN THIS.
IT'S GOING TO BE A LATE NIGHT
HOPEFULLY NOT. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
THEIR HELP ON THIS BILL. COVERT
NINETEEN IS HIGHLIGHTED
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR
BROADBAND ACCESS AND THE GAPS
THAT STILL EXIST ACROSS THE
STATE IN SERVICE AND ACCESS. OR
FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO FILL
THAT GAP SO IS THE NEED TO
ENSURE RAPID DEPLOYMENT OF
BROADBAND PERMITS AB FIVE THREE
SEVEN MODIFIES THE STATE'S
BROAD BANDING PERMIT PROCESS TO
ENSURE THE LINES. WITH UPDATED
FEDERAL RULES AB FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN MAKE SURE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MAKES DECISIONS
WITHIN THE FEDERALLY MANDATED
TIMELINES WHICH ARE TYPICALLY
TWO TO THREE MONTHS DEPENDING
ON THE TYPE OF PROJECT. IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN I AUTHORED
LEGISLATION WHICH CODIFIED THE
GOVERNMENT'S SHOT CLOCK. FOR
BROADBAND PROJECTS IN THE SKATE
CALIFORNIA'S. AND ACCUSED ME
ESTABLISH CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT
PERMITTING TIME LINES SINCE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT UPDATED
THEIR SHOT CLOCK RULES IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AB FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN SIMPLY UPDATES CALIFORNIA
LAW ACCORDINGLY. HI THIS BILL
WILL MAKE A REAL DIFFERENCE TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS TO DESPERATELY
NEED IMPROVED INTERNET ACCESS
FOR SCHOOL. TELEHEALTH REMOTE
WORK IN COMMERCE. IT WILL MAKE
SURE THAT HIGH SPEED INTERNET
PROJECTS DELIVERED IN MONTHS
INSTEAD OF YEARS. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN THIS DOT DANCE
WHICH SIR. ON BEHALF OF CROWN
CASTLE AND JONATHAN. ERIN BELL
ON BEHALF OF CTIA RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR PERKINS-
OPERATOR. WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
GIVE THEIR LINES ARE OPEN. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DAN
SCHWEITZER I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR CROWN
CASTLE- FORGET YOU TAKE A LOOK
WORK AND SHARE I GAVE HER THREE
YEARS OF COMMITMENT TO
EXPANDING BROADBAND ACCESS IN
CALIFORNIA WE SHARE YOUR GOAL
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE PROUD TO
SPONSOR EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN BECAUSE IT WILL ALLOW
HIGH SPEED INTERNET PROJECTS TO
BE COMPLETED IN MONTHS. INSTEAD
OF YEARS. CALIFORNIA ALREADY
HAS PERMITS SHOT CLOCKS IN
PLACE THE BROADBAND PROJECT
THANKS TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK'S. AB TWENTY SEVEN FROM
TWENTY FIFTEEN. THIS BILL
SIMPLY UPDATES CALIFORNIA LAW
TO REFLECT THE NEW FEDERAL
TIMELINE. THEY WERE RECENTLY
ADOPTED TO THE CHOCOLATES ARE
CONSISTENT. WE BELIEVE THAT AB
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN STRIKES THE
RIGHT BALANCE THE PRESERVES
LOCAL CONTROL BY ALLOWING
CITIES TO USE WHATEVER PROCESS
THEY BALK TO EVALUATE BROADBAND
PERMITS. AND ALLOW THEM TO
APPROVE OR DENY THE BROADBAND
PERMIT. ALL THIS BILL DOES IS
SIMPLY IS MAKE SURE THE CITY IS
MAKE A DECISION WITHIN
FEDERALLY MANDATED TIMELINES
WHICH ARE TYPICALLY TWO TO
THREE MONTHS DEPENDING ON THE
TYPE OF PROJECT. THIS BILL WILL
MAKE A REAL DIFFERENCE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO DESPERATELY
NEED IMPROVED INTERNET ACCESS
FOR SCHOOL TELEHEALTH REMOTE
WORK AND COMMERCE. THEY WILL
MAKE SURE THAT HIGH SPEED
INTERNET PROJECTS ARE DELIVERED
IN MONTHS INSTEAD OF YEARS WELL
MAYBE FOCUS ON WILL MAKE SURE
ALL COMMUNITIES GET QUICKER
ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED INTERNET
PROJECTS. WHILE MAINTAINING
LOCAL CONTROL- WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AFTER I VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE NEXT
WILL BE JONATHAN GOT THEIR OWN
BILL. YEAH THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JONATHAN THEIR BELL HERE ON
BEHALF OF EPA THE TREE SO
SEDATION FOR THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY. I KNOW IT'S BEEN A
LONG HEARING CENTER RESPECT
EVERYONE'S TIME I WON'T USE MY
OLD THREE MINUTES REPEATING ALL
THE GREAT TALKING POINTS WE
JUST HEARD- I'LL JUST QUICKLY
ADD YOUR HAS BEEN MENTIONED THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AUTHORED AB
FIFTY SEVEN. IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT IT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
HELPING THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY
KEEP UP WITH THE DEPLOYMENT OF
WIRELESS TECHNOLOGY- AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN WILL ADD ON TO THAT
AND CONTINUE THAT SUCCESS AND
HELP WITH DEPLOYMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS OBVIOUSLY
PROVEN TO BE A NECESSITY IN
CALIFORNIA- THIS BILL TAKES A
REASONABLE YET INCREMENTAL
STEPS TOWARDS A MORE
STREAMLINED PROCESS. WHILE
RESERVING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
RIGHT AND YOU KNOW THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY IS PREPARING TO INVEST
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO DEPLOY
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S AWFULLY
CRITICAL FOR COMMUNITIES AND WE
CAN TALK ALL WE WANT ABOUT
INVESTING BILLIONS IN THE TALK
TO MANY BILLS IN THE
LEGISLATURE TRYING TO PUT
BILLIONS INTO INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT HE CAN'T GET A TIMELY
PERMANENT WE LIKELY WON'T SEE
THE OUTCOME THAT THE
LEGISLATURE STRIVING FOR WHICH
IS CLOSING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
IN GETTING CALIFORNIANS
CONNECTED. FOR THOSE REASONS
AND THOSE STATED BY THE AUTHOR
AND THE PREVIOUS. SPEAKER WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THEY
YOUR ARE THERE ANY OTHER WAY.
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE WILL GO TO LINE
OF INTO THIRTY EIGHT. YOUR LIFE
OPEN. HELLO TWO THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD YES
GO AHEAD. YES BETTER CARE
MEMBERS ARE COLLEGE EDUCATED
THAT THE WRONG NUMBER BACK
CANDLES REPRESENTING THE
WIRELESS INFRASTRUCTURE
ASSOCIATION A SISTER
ORGANIZATION THE C. C. G. A.
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO CAROLINA TWO EIGHT
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER
WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE'RE
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
AN EXTRA BOTTLE LINE OF TWO
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'M KAREN MEMBERS COURTNEY
JENSEN WHAT BRAND THAT THEY'RE
ON GOOD GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF VERIZON IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE RATHER
FOR THEIR SUPPORT IN Q. THANK
YOU NOW WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND I BELIEVE WE'RE LOOKING FOR
TRACY RYAN WITH THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
CALIFORNIA. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS A CHECKING LINE
REPRESENTS A WORLD CAME UP WITH
THE CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
URBAN CANADA CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION.
BUT THE POSITION OF OPPOSING
WHAT THE MANDATE TO EIGHTY FIVE
THREE SEVEN. THEY NEED FOR
ACTUAL ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED
RELIABLE INTERNET CONNECTIVITY
HAS BEEN MADE ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
AS MANY OF US STRUGGLE TO DO
EVERY EVERYTHING PERSONALLY
THIS YEAR. ROUND SHOPPING THIS
WALL THE HEALTHCARE OUR LIVES
ARE CONDUCTED ONLINE MORE THAN
EVER. AS WE ARE ALL AWARE OF
THE VARIOUS SEGMENTS OF
CALIFORNIANS TYPICALLY LOWER
INCOME IN RURAL AREAS THAT LACK
THE NECESSARY ACCESS EVERYDAY
SERVICES BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
CONNECTED THE IS EITHER
INADEQUATE. OR NONEXISTENT
WHERE THEY LIVE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
MADE. FOR ACT TO PRIORITY OUR
ORGANIZATION CAN AGREE WITH THE
STATED INTENT OF THE DELTA WIND
THE FEDERAL SHOT CLOCK
REQUIREMENTS THE CALIFORNIA LAW
AND EVEN ALLOW DEEMED APPROVED
REMEDY FOR THOSE NEW XCELERATED
COMMITTING TIMELINE. HOWEVER
THERE IS FAR MORE THAT IS
OUTLINED IN THE BILL MOST OF
WHICH IS UNCLEAR AND BOTH
INTENT IN FACT. THE TYPICALLY A
FIVE SEVEN ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE
TO THE TEAM TO PROVE PROVISION
THAT STATE THAT WIRELESS
FACILITY PERMIT IT ALSO BE
ISSUED AND CONSTRUCTION MAYBE
AGAIN. IS UNCLEAR WHAT THE
PROCESS MEANS AND THE EFFECT
AND FURTHER EXACTLY WHAT
PROBLEM THIS PROVISION
INTENSIFIED. ADDITIONALLY
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL RELATED
CONSTRUCTION IN THE PUBLIC
RIGHT AWAY CAN BE INTERPRETED
AS REMOVING ALL LOOKING
GOVERNMENT'S ABILITY TO REVIEW
OR DENY THAT SAFETY RELATED
ASSESSMENTS FOR THIS TYPE OF
CONSTRUCTION. ACTUALLY EIGHTY
FIVE THREE SEVEN STATE THAT THE
SHOT CLOCK TIME FRAME SHOT
BEGIN WHEN THE APPLET APPLICANT
HAS TAKEN THE FIRST PROCEDURAL
STEP OF THE PROCESS. THIS
LANGUAGE IS AMBIGUOUS AND
CAUSES SIGNIFICANT
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS. WE
APPLAUD ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK'S
EFFORTS TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
BROADBAND SERVICES HOWEVER WE
BELIEVE IT'S ONLY BE NARROWED
TO THE STATED INTENT TO CUT BY
THE FEDERAL TIMELINES AND
PROVIDED DEEMED APPROVED REMEDY
IN THOSE CASES WHERE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FAILS TO MEET THE
APPLICABLE TIMEFRAMES. WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
AGENT WITH OUR ORGANIZATION BUT
TO THIS POINT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
TOWARDS A SOLUTION THAT MOVES
US CLOSER TO BURGEONING
ADDITIONAL THE BY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH OF THEIR
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR ON THE PHONE
LINES IN YOUR IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE NINE ZERO FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU GOVERNOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL. OF
A COMMENT THIS SOME BILL IS
EXCELLENT. IT'S ABOUT AS
PERFECT AS YOU CAN GET. AND I
BASE THAT UPON- A FAMILY MEMBER
THAT DESIGNS BUILDS AND
PROGRAMS MANY OF THESE
FACILITIES- THIS BILL. IS
PERFECT IN THE SENSE THAT IT
RECOGNIZES. THE NEW TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S COMING OUT THERE WILL BE
IN THE FUTURE WITH FIVE G. AND
THEY'RE WORKING ON SIX G. THAT
WILL BE THE GIANT TOWERS SIX
CETERA THEY'LL BE LITTLE.
ALMOST INVISIBLE THINGS THAT
AMEND WHATEVER'S SUPPOSED TO
ADMIT. THIS IS SPOT ON I DIDN'T
GET TO TELL. THANK YOU. IT
EXCUSE ME- MISTER KIRK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK I FAILED
TO ADDRESS THE GENTLEMAN THE
TEAR OF HIS OWN HOUSING THE
BILL AND I'D LIKELY HAVE TO
GIVE HIM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK I APOLOGIZE SIR. READ
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON IS A
MIKE ON YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARK
GRAHAM ON BEHALF OF KEEP CELL
ANTENNAS AWAY THERE ARE TWO
REASONS YOU SHOULD VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL HEALTH EFFECTS FROM
CELL ANTENNA RADIATION AND
LOCAL CONTROL THE FEDERAL
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ACT OF
NINETEEN NINETY SIX PRESERVES
LOCAL ZONING AUTHORITY WHY
SHOULD THE STATE ELIMINATE
LOCAL ZONING AUTHORITY THAT THE
TCA PRESERVES. A CELL ANTENNA
IS CURRENTLY AND SHOULD REMAIN
A MUNICIPAL AFFAIR AS THAT TERM
IS USED IN ARTICLE ELEVEN
SECTION FIVE OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. THOUSANDS OF
STUDIES SHOW THAT LOCKED LEGAL
AMOUNTS OF ELECTROMAGNETIC
RADIATION CAUSES HARMFUL HEALTH
EFFECTS MANY OF THESE STUDIES
WERE PROVIDED TO THIS COMMITTEE
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ON SB
SIX FORTY NINE. THE UNITED
STATES NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH. THIRTY NOVEMBER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FOUND CLEAR
EVIDENCE OF CANCER FROM CELL
PHONE RADIATION. IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
INTERNATIONAL EMF SCIENTISTS
APPEAL SAID THAT
ELECTROMAGNETIC RADIATION IS
HAZARDOUS IT CAUSES LEARNING
AND MEMORY DEFICITS AND
STRUCTURAL AND FUNCTIONAL
CHANGES OF THE REPRODUCTIVE
SYSTEM. THERE WAS A SIMILAR
RESOLUTION BY THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN DECEMBER
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN. SECTION
TWO H. OF THIS BILL EXEMPTS
FIRE DEPARTMENT FACILITIES WHY
IS THAT MEMBERS WE NEED SOCIAL
EQUITY. IF THE CELL ANTENNA
RADIATION RADIATION IS NOT SAFE
FOR FIREFIGHTERS WHY IS IT SAFE
FOR THE REST OF US. YOU DO NOT
NEED A STATE LAW TO ENSURE THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL LAW. DOES THAT MAKE
SENSE. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SHOT
CLOCKS IN THE FEDERAL
COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION HAS
SET THEM CURRENTLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN AND DO REGULATE
CELL ANTENNAS WHILE ALSO
FACILITATING THEIR DEPLOYMENT.
THAT DEPLOYMENT IS ALREADY
HAPPENING VERY QUICKLY. WE RELY
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PROTECT
US. MANY CALIFORNIANS HAVE
WOKEN UP TO SUDDENLY FIND A
CELL ANTENNA ON THE STREET
LIGHT POLE OR THE UTILITY POLE
RIGHT OUT IN FRONT OF THEIR
HOUSE. AND THEY SUFER FROM
CONSTANT HEADACHES INSOMNIA AND
RINGING IN THE EARS AND MANY OF
THESE PEOPLE ARE LITERALLY
DRIVEN OUT OF THEIR HOMES
FORCED TO SELL AND MOVE.
MEMBERS TURN OFF YOUR CELL
PHONE IN YOUR WIFI AT NIGHT.
YOU WILL SLEEP BETTER AND YOU
WILL HAVE BETTER ENERGY THE
DURING THE NEXT DAY. AND THAT
IS YOUR PROOF THAT THE
RADIATION FROM THE WIFI AND A
CELL PHONE HAS BEEN AFFECTING
YOUR- CITIES MUST RETAIN THE
ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT ORDINANCES
AND AGREEMENTS PLEASE ARAMBULA.
YES SUCH AS THE OLD IMPLEMENTED
IN THE CITY OF ELK GROVE IN
ORDER TO PROTECT PUBLIC FACIL
PUBLIC FACILITIES AND ADDRESS.
THE SPECIFIC AND UNIQUE NEEDS
OF A LOCAL COMMUNITY I URGE YOU
TO VOTE NOW. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY. WE'LL CONTINUE WITH
COMMITTEE- QUESTIONS ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE- WE HAVE A MOTION. MOVED
TO BUT YEAH I THINK WE HAVE THE
BILL ALREADY DONE. AM I CORRECT
SECRETARY FOR FIRST IN THE
SECOND. WE ALREADY HAVE FIRST
AND SECOND WE DIDN'T BEFORE
ALSO OCCURRED OKAY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF BOERNER HORVATH YOU
SEE THAT RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LUCKY JUST KEEP I KNOW. OKAY
WHICH I TO CLOSE MR FOR ALL YES
WILL CERTAINLY CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE RURAL COUNTIES- THESE
PARTICULAR CORRECT. CONCERNS
CAME UP RECENTLY WE CERTAINLY
DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS WHAT WE
MEAN BY WHEN THEY SHUT WHEN THE
SHOT CLOCK STARTS AND THEY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT- AND THE
OTHER ONE IS SOME HER AT
BELIEVE ME WE DO NOT INTEND. TO
CHANGE THE FEDERAL GUIDELINES
AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS IS TO
CHANGE- THE- IS TO HAVE A
REMEDY IF PEOPLE DON'T MEET
THOSE SO I GUARANTEE YOU THIS
BILL WILL NOT IMPERIL SAFETY
THANK YOU- IN ASKING ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK
FREE WORK ON THE BILL AND ON
THIS ISSUE AS A WHOLE. AS YOU
KNOW REMOVING BARRIERS TO
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT CONTINUES
TO BE ONE OF MY MOST PRESSING
PRIORITIES IF OUR DIGITAL
DIVIDE WASN'T STARK ENOUGH
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. OF OUR
RELIANCE ON THE INTERNET THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPORTS IT
WAS NOT CLEAR ENOUGH BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC THESE CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES SHOULD BE CRYSTAL
CLEAR NOW. THIS BILL CONTINUES
TO MOVE US IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WE MUST ELIMINATE THE
INEQUITIES IN INTERNET ACCESS
TO CONTINUE TO STYMIE OUR
COMMUNITIES I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY MOTIONS
TO PASS TO THE COMMUNICATIONS A
CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY HI. AND WE'RE AYE
LACKEY LACKEY I BLEW WILL ADD.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I ROMMEL'S FROM FIVE MOOSE
THREE. THREE OF US HI ROBERT.
ROBERT RIVAS CYBER. REPEL HI
YEAH EIGHT ZERO OKAY YOUR BILLS
I BELIEVE OUT HERE THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS LEAVE THE
LEAVE IT OPEN IF YOU'RE MISSING
ANYONE WE HAVE A VERY GOOD. ALL
RIGHT LET'S HAVE A ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB EIGHT ELEVEN
THRE OF US. I THINK YOU THE
LESSON FOR THE DAY GROW. THREE
DO YOU. HAVE A RIVETING. WILL
OKAY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
EVALUATION AB EIGHT ELEVEN SIX
TO STREAMLINE THAT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY'S
PROJECT DELIVERY AS LOS ANGELES
PREPARES FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC
GAMES TODAY ARE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT I HAVE THE BILL'S
SPONSOR MICHAEL TURNER WITH THE
LOS ANGELES METROPOLITAN TREND
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OTHERS MICHAEL TURNER- WITH THE
L. A. COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT ELEVEN I
WOULD FIRST LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
THANKS TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
FOR CARRYING THE BILL. AND ALSO
EXPRESS OUR THANKS TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THE BILL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTION WE'RE SPONSORING
THIS TO HELP EXPEDITE PROJECT
DELIVERIES WE PREPARE FOR THE
OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC GAMES
WHAT WE'RE DOING ISN'T AS
MODIFYING A STATUTE THAT WAS
CREATED IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES. WHEN AN ALTERNATIVE
PROJECT DELIVERY METHODS WERE
NOT THAT COMMON THE EXISTING
STATUTE REQUIRES THAT THE BOARD
FIRST APPROVED BY A TWO THIRDS
VOTE OF FINDING THAT AN
ALTERNATIVE PROJECT DELIVERY
METHOD IS EFFICIENT AND ONLY
AFTER THAT FINDING CAN THE
BOARD. APPROVE A CONTRACT WE
HAVE TO DO THAT EACH TIME WE
HAVE TO UTILIZE WE WANT
UTILIZED DESIGN BUILD OR ANY
ALTERNATIVE DELIVERY METHODS
AND WHAT IT DOES IS IT CREATES
A TWO STEP PROCESS WHICH IS NOT
ONLY UNNECESSARY AND CUMBERSOME
IT'S ALSO SOMETHING THAT THE
WEATHER AGENCY. IN CALIFORNIA
HAS TO GO THROUGH OVERTIME
DESIGN BUILD ANOTHER DELIVERY
MECHANISMS HAVE BECOME MUCH
MORE COMMON IN STATUTES OF- YOU
SEE ME EITHER A STATUE'S
IMMINENT OPTED AUTHORIZING
THOSE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
ASSEMBLY HARMONIZE OUR STATUTES
WITH THE OTHER PROJECT DELIVERY
STATUTES IN CALIFORNIA. AGAIN
I'D LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR
AND. THINK THE COMMITTEE AGAIN
FOR WORKING WITH US. THANK YOU
OTHER OTHER. HELLO SUPPORTERS.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
ARE THERE ANY WITNESS IS NOT
PLENTIFUL NINE POSTSCRIPT
EXCUSE ME I'M SORRY OPERATOR.
AND THE PHONE LINES- IF YOU
AREN'T SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE
ONE NINE IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. HER AS A REMINDER IT IS
THE ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR OUR
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT ONE ONE.
AND WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE. ONE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI IT'S
ME I WASN'T GIVEN A NUMBER BUT
I'LL TAKE IT JEREMY SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE MORE ONE
MOMENT. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
UP BUT YOU EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NORMAN ASPECT
WITH CARPENTERS FEVERS
REPRESENTING THAT CALIFORNIA
ASPHALT PAVEMENT ASSOCIATION
REPORTED AB EIGHT ONE ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THREE OF ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. BUT IN
THE FALL MIND IF YOU'RE NOT THE
VISION YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO UP IN OPPOSITION OF
AB. EIGHT ONE ONE. AND WE HAVE
NOT OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORTERS HERE IN THE
GALLERY AS WELL. ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY- WE HAVE A MOTION. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SURE YEAH
THIS BILL IS CRITICAL AS LOS
ANGELES PREPARES FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT OLYMPIC GAMES
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- YEAH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EVEN BRING THE BILL FOR WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE TO REFINE
THE LANGUAGE BEFORE OUR HEARING
TODAY I WILL BE VOTING ON FOR
YOU. QUESTIONS DO PASSED THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY HI. AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE LACKEY LACKEY I BLOOM. LOU
I BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS. RAMOS
I THREE OF US HI THIS RIVERSIDE
ROBERT RIVAS. ROBERT RIVERSIDE
VOEPEL. WILL TELL ALL RIGHT
EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU THIS BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISSING. WELL NOW DO LET. THE
CALLS AND DO THE OUT ON. AND
THANK WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO THE
FIRST STARTING WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. I HAVE THREE OF US
THREE OF US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVERSIDE YEAH EIGHT
ZERO ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FILLS UP ON CONSECUTIVE DROUGHT.
AB. ZERO FIVE. WELL AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO. THE VOTE IS. THREE
THREE AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I. THREE OF US
THREE OF US SIDE THE BOAT
THERE'S CURRENTLY FIVE THREE
BILL OUT. FIVE THREE. AB.
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX THE BROKER
ONLY IS FOUR ZERO AGUIAR-CURRY
HI AGUIAR-CURRY I. THREE OF US
THREE OF US HI ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVERSIDE SEVEN WITH
VOEPEL NOT VOTING. BILL IS OUT.
AB NINE OH THREE THE VOTE
CURRENTLY IS FIVE ZERO
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I.
RAMOS RAMOS I THREE OF US
THREE OF US FIVE EIGHT ZERO AB
EIGHT NINE OH THREE TOP. AB
FORTINO ONE THE VOTE CURRENTLY
IS FIVE. ZERO WITH LACKEY NOT
VOTING. BAR BOERNER HORVATH NO
BOERNER HORVATH NO THREE OF US
THREE OF US I THE BILL
CURRENTLY IS SIX ONE FIVE BILLS
OUT A. B. FOURTEEN A ONE OUT.
AB SIX OH TO THE VOTE CURRENTLY
IS FIVE ZERO LACKEY LACKEY I
BOERNER HORVATH. HI
BOERNER HORVATH I THREE OF US
THREE OF US I'VE EIGHT ZERO
FILLED OUT SB SIX THIRTY IS NOT.
EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY EIGHT THE
BOOK IS FIVE ONE.
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I THREE OF US
THREE OF US I THE BILL IS SEVEN
ONE AB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT UP. AB
TEN FORTY ONE THE BOOK
CURRENTLY IS SEVEN ZERO
THREE OF US. THREE OF US HI THE
VOTERS EIGHT ZERO AB TEN TWENTY
ONE SOUTH. AB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
IS ALREADY DONE. EIGHT ELEVEN
THIS THEN WE'RE NOW- AB TWELVE
SEVENTY ONE THE VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO. LACKEY SNUFFED LACKEY NOW
BOERNER HORVATH RIGHT
BOERNER HORVATH I THREE OF US
THREE OF US I WOULD VOEPEL NOT
VOTING THE BILL CURRENTLY IS.
SIX ONE. EVERY TRUST EVERYONE
TO HAVE. ACCESS THANK YOU
MEMBERS VERY MUCH IN RETURN THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
THANKS FOR YOUR PATIENCE TODAY
GUYS.